Holder.
I mean they're both older.
I think Johnny's probably 37 in Lombard is older than that.
I think Johnny's only 32.
So we just said,
oh,
you said we're live.
Oh,
we're trying to figure out how old Johnny Hendricks says.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm guessing probably,
uh,
Eddie bravos and how Ian Mccall is here.
How's it going guys?
This is a fight companion podcast if you've never heard one of these.
Most of the time we don't talk about the fights.
I had to wear it sense.
Yes.
But we are watching the fights and a,
we will tell you when it syncs up to the first fight.
This is a UFC fight night live from Halifax.
It's Johnny Hendricks versus Hector Lombard and Travis Browne versus a Derrick
Lewis.
So,
uh,
that's a big heavyweight bout very important fights.
Another scary guy.
Derrick Lewis has been frightening lately.
He looks good.
Damn.
He looks really good.
I was super impressed with them.
Against Roy Nelson.
Yeah.
He's got all sorts of endurance now.
He's been like really concentrating on is a strength and conditioning.
Yeah.
For,
for a man that size to carry that sort of,
you know,
just to carry that body over that amount of time.
So yeah,
he's,
he's definitely worked on a lot.
Hey man,
before we even get going,
we should talk about your last thing because you've,
you are the most cursed fucking dude in all of MMA.
He just had to cancel.
How many fights in a row is this now?
Five.
Five fights in a row.
That's crazy.
That is crazy.
It's gotten to the point where obviously people are pissed off.
They're hating on me or fuck or whatever.
I don't really,
we can't worry about that,
but just explain,
but explain what happened.
So the,
the,
you want to go from the very beginning made weight.
He made way you look,
you were smiling,
you were laughing and saw the video.
I've never made weight that easy in my entire career.
That was,
I mean you ask anybody the usually,
you know,
you stopped drinking water 24 hours out from Wayne's,
well,
I cut weight the night,
that night,
Thursday night and I,
it was going so well that I had probably five glasses of ice water.
Oh Shit.
Pop is the first fight.
So you bet to get us are gonna be excited to get cracking with a stupid story.
So then I figured,
fuck I can,
I can eat a little bit.
So I try to eat a little bit of salad and I threw that up,
but I figured that was just the,
uh,
just the,
the,
the dressing or something that there was messing my stomach up.
Right.
So I had at least a cup of a,
of almonds,
a lot,
five cups of water.
I cut the rest in the morning.
And then when I was trying to gain any weight back,
my body wouldn't,
I couldn't,
I couldn't hold on to anything.
He just kept throwing up.
I kept throwing up everything.
So you have,
see I woke up Saturday morning at one 31 should,
I had only gained five pounds and four of those pounds had been because UFC gave
me two ivy bags.
And how much did you cut?
The UFC gave you ivy bags?
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
You are allowed to use an IV?
Yeah,
because they were just,
they would do that.
I'd go to the fucking hospital,
but hold on a second.
I thought you can't use an ivy and then fight.
Well,
no,
they,
they were just doing it as,
as a precaution because either way I was gonna need it.
Right.
But,
but isn't that the whole thing about cutting weight is that it's much more
difficult now because you can't use an IV.
So they gave you an exemption.
I got so some sort of an exemption,
but I didn't even have to get an exemption because I ended up getting pulled.
Does anybody know?
But is this like a new,
is this like the first time anyone's hearing this that you did an ivy get yelled
at?
Um,
what do you mean yelled at by?
Who People Online.
Is that what you're saying about UFC?
UFC?
Like who,
oh no,
no,
I'm just kidding.
But who said that you could do the ivy?
Oh,
Jeff came up to my room.
Jeff.
Yeah,
Jeff Novitsky.
So this jet you have this key doctor d like they all were with me the entire
time.
I made weight so easily that it was,
it was crazy because anything I'd put in my body I'd throw back up.
So what the fuck man,
can you use it?
You can use an ivy or you can't use an ob.
He's an ivy.
You get the exemption,
which I don't know the rules.
And then again,
I was also sick the whole time,
so I don't what the fuck was going on.
And then,
you know,
they,
they gave me the two ivy bags.
I ingested maybe a pound of water or whatever myself.
That's the only thing I keep down.
But like I said,
I buy by the next morning,
you still hadn't eaten.
I,
it's,
it's still only gain five pounds.
So,
but you'd only eat,
drink water.
You hadn't eaten anything,
but I was born and I hadn't eaten any of everything.
I tried to eat.
I threw up and I was throwing up in front of all the,
all the other fighters,
every single chance we ended up had to be in a group in public.
I ended up fucking throwing up.
So then you go to the doctor I the next day I'm like,
okay,
give me two more.
I'd be bags.
Give me some Zofran for ivy backs total.
I asked what I ended up getting more,
but um,
I asked him and I'm like,
listen,
like,
just let me fight.
Give me,
give me,
give me two more heavy bags,
condition,
Zofran so I can go brown to help your stomach.
So then I can hold some food down,
some antinausea stuff.
And they looked at me like,
no dude,
you need to go to the hospital.
Like,
and then they fade out.
Then they were going to do emergency gallbladder surgery,
which they didn't have to do.
Then go hats.
Um,
emergency gallbladder surgery.
Like what?
Remove your gallbladder.
They've did this whole thing is scared the shit out of me.
Like,
what,
what did you sit on it up?
She says,
Oh,
you know,
you could die and never know.
I'm like,
what in the fuck do you mean?
You never know.
So when they say emergency gallbladder surgery,
they're like,
what is going on with your broader,
like what would they say?
It was super,
uh,
it was what was shrunk,
I guess when you say contracted,
just from the dehydration I guess.
And then so then they saw shadowing and some other stuff and they thought I had,
you know,
the gallbladder,
they thought I had gallstones.
So then the Aza,
as they're trying to set everything up,
they go,
well let's get a more in depth,
the more advanced version of what we just did.
So then they took me in the back,
hit me with a bunch of morphine and I'm like,
if you have to dig anything in my stomach again,
I'm gonna Punch him.
Like,
so just at least knock me out and a bunch of morphine and sent me on the table.
What is your gallbladder do?
I don't know if you know toxins,
right?
I thought that was where your liver does.
Does the gallbladder do that as well?
If,
I don't know,
does anybody know what a gallbladder does?
It's one of those things where if you had a name,
like a crucial Oregon's,
you'd go,
uh,
I think we got them.
What's that?
Yes,
exactly.
So then they do a more advanced version of the,
uh,
of the ultrasound and they didn't see anything,
so I didn't have to do that.
And so basically we're just running tests.
I've been running tests all week.
So your gallbladder is obviously,
there's an issue because of the dehydration,
like yes,
it was falling apart.
Yeah.
So that sucked.
And then,
I mean,
I didn't,
I wasn't even,
I'm still skinny,
but I,
I think,
I mean,
I hadn't been,
I went home a day later and I was supposed to go home and I was still under 135
pounds.
It's probably 132 pounds.
And will you eating by then?
I wasn't able to hold food down until like Tuesday.
I think it was so good in my body.
Just fucking failed me.
Okay.
Make that a little larger please.
It says,
when is that?
Uh,
when is the Tue not required for an ivy infusion if the athlete has an acute
medical condition where an ivy lines essential for treatment in the hospital
admission surgical procedure or clinical investigation.
Examples of be a severely dehydrated athlete with signs of circulatory
compromise.
Hmm.
A need for an ivy line during a surgical procedure and an IV line in the
antibiotic treatment of an acute infection,
et cetera.
So I guess they decided they made a judgement call.
They decided but they were going to let you fight with an IV,
which is kinda crazy.
I think they kind of knew I wasn't going to fight the whole time.
They were just a really pat me on the head.
That one.
Oh yeah,
you'll be all right.
Little Buddy.
So you think they're giving you the ivy just to make you stay alive or some just
to keep me not nine cry fucking hate weight cutting with every ounce of my
being.
The really difficult part is I had the best weight cut of my let you didn't you,
you had the best weight cut of your life where you obviously got down to 125
pounds,
but your body was shutting down.
I mean,
you can't say I had the best weight cut of my life.
If you almost died,
you have a point.
I mean it's,
it's the whole thing is so until that point,
up until that point.
Yes,
exactly.
It's so bananas at the fucking practice of weight cutting is so crazy.
Yeah.
And of course there's something still tied to what happened in Ireland with me
and most people don't know.
But I was in the hospital two,
three,
four times before that fight with some Vasovagal syncope where my,
my,
uh,
my esophagus would,
would freak out and I've done it passing out.
And this is before the weight cut.
This is before,
this is in training camp for the Ireland fight.
And then what causes that?
I don't fucking know.
I've been trying to get tests done.
They've have had endoscopy.
I gotta get another camera.
He'll be down my throat pipe sticking out of my ass.
And you were like,
I'm just going to fight anyway.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That's what I liked doing.
I understand.
I'd rather do this.
Okay.
This fight is about to start.
So let's go with the very first round.
Um,
could we get the card up on the screen so we could tell who's fighting here?
Felder is so much fun.
Yeah,
he's great.
He's,
he's exciting.
And homeboy.
Who was he fighting Ricci.
Oh,
we tagged him right away with a left counter hook.
What is,
um,
what's reaches full name
reach?
He's got the old school tie tattoos on his back.
Alessandro,
I think Alessandro Ricci.
Yeah.
Oh,
Sandra Ricci.
Where's he from?
I don't know.
Good question.
Uh,
sounds like Italy.
Yeah,
like his heritage for sure.
I love those.
A weirdo tie.
Tattoos like he's got on his back or they tap 'em in,
you know,
Oh,
good left hook over the top.
A lot of Thai guys have in there,
but you better be legit if you get one of them tattoos.
You can't be a fucking poser with them.
Hold homemade.
Ready?
Yeah.
Bangkok ready?
Did you see John John Wayne Park made a t shirt.
Bangkok radio.
He's an amazing human.
He's awesome.
God,
I was watching this,
his daughter the the day online.
She's so fucking good.
She's bad ass.
Well Magic of your dad's John Wayne Bar.
Yeah.
Better learn how to strike.
Shit's going to come up.
Yes,
it's going to have to come up.
You know,
this is a Felder like to start off the card.
It's interesting because like this is not a fight that a lot of people have been
talking about,
but this guy,
you know,
Felder just like a year ago was like the guy to watch at one 55 and then,
had a few losses lost of Barboza and a great fight and he,
he is technically great just watching good head movement,
punching off his ankles and everything.
Yeah,
I mean his losses,
it just been a ban against super elite fighters.
I mean,
he's just fighting really good guys and that's just,
nobody knows better than you.
That's just how it goes.
It happens.
Oh,
nice.
Straight.
Right.
Beautiful.
So what happens now with your,
your medical treatment?
Did they,
I mean,
is there a way that it can do some sort of a comprehensive scan and find out
what's going on with your body?
Yeah,
that there,
you know,
we're doing a lot of testing.
We were trying to figure out they've done like blood,
hair,
whatever else,
you know,
and that check your hair.
Yeah.
That's check your hair.
I don't fucking know.
I don't ask questions.
Imagine that.
If they like the hair tells you everything we check,
is there an area above and beyond like to check everything,
doing eastern medicine,
like all kinds of shit.
So hopefully within the next couple of weeks I'll,
I'll at least understand,
um,
what's wrong.
Yeah.
Partially what's wrong and we can fix it.
Cause I'm,
I'm in amazing shape.
You know,
I've,
I've just had a really string of bad luck.
Whatever it is though.
It sounds pretty significant.
I mean if you,
if every time you're getting down to weight,
your body starts falling apart,
that seems Oh,
beautiful spin there.
It'd lucky turned it from a spinning back fist to spinning elbow in the middle
of that Oh right hand.
But yeah,
you got a good point.
I should probably get this under control before I cut weight and I don't come
back.
You think as a professional fighter that there is a way to get people to stop
cutting weight.
Do you think there's a way,
if the UFC made a concerted effort the same way they've made an effort to cut
out all the,
uh,
performance enhancing drugs by having Novitsky and Usada run the program and
make sure that they're doing all these random tests on people and brutal,
brutal sanctions.
That's enough though,
because people would still cut weight and try to,
I'm not going to get crazy.
People get crazy if they got,
you got a data recover,
you're going to go full blown nuts,
soy,
so that if you got to fight the same day,
you don't go that crazy and you might be right because you'll lose.
There's no way you're going to make it through.
Like,
that's what,
that's what we do in an Ebi 35 at,
at a,
at [inaudible] up any lower than that in a way.
Do you think though that a,
you would worry,
I mean that was the reason why they had,
um,
for day before Wayne's in boxing was I think it was the duck who Kim fight.
I think they changed the wins and I think they also changed the number of
rounds.
I think it was 12 yeah,
I think that was the fight that did that.
But they used to weigh in the day of the fight.
Yeah.
And you know,
guys used to mean that was,
that was the standard.
It was the way they did it.
You know.
And I think if you go back to like those old school Tommy Hearns sugar ray
Leonard fight with us,
there wasn't,
there wasn't no 15 rounds in those fights.
Oh I'm sure.
I think so.
Right.
Kim Can fight was when the seventies eighties he was the eighties six I was in
high school cause I remember I was a big rain man,
senior fan and when that guy died it was just like a Dharma loud.
Oh Felder got them until over.
I want he,
yeah,
he caught him with something before
you know Ibj Jeff Does Matt side,
wham.
Like you weigh in and then you compete.
I liked that too,
but,
but guys in fights,
it's a different feeling to go into a fight and there's so much psychological
shit going on that there's certain,
oh he's limping to this crazy.
You're not going to go crazy with the weight cut.
You're not going to do all that extreme stuff.
You can't.
But that's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is some guys just wouldn't make the weight if they had a Duke
cage side and then what the fuck do you do?
Backups,
make it part of the sport.
There's some,
there are some guys,
we all know that this happens.
Some guys that just get real close and I'm good man.
They get real close.
And then the day of the fight,
they just don't fucking make weight.
That's when they do big events.
But if you,
if you're forced to not be,
there's no way you can make a big cut of it's same day or Matt side.
Right.
You can't do that crazy gnarly shit.
It's trying to do it.
You could cut a little bit,
but it's not going to be 15 pounds.
Don't you think that's when it gets dangerous?
Don't you think also they need more weight classes.
I liked the way classes.
Did they bake it?
I like more,
but I think it would be,
don't you think there's a giant gap between 85 and two oh five and that giant
gap between two oh five and heavyweight.
Cause there's a bunch of people that just don't have a home.
I have no problem with the weight,
with the weight divisions.
Zero problems with that.
I like it.
Well it's,
it's certainly debatable.
I think they could do 10 pounds.
Yes.
I feel like every 10 pounds.
55 right?
Yeah.
But I see it.
But yeah,
55 657585905205 to 15 I like dentistry of the way it is now.
You'd have to rewrite it.
You'd have to change.
They'd be like,
what they did,
you know,
they used to be 200 used to be light heavyweight,
and then they turned to change the two oh five when Tito Tito Ortiz first
started competing and he was 200 yeah,
they've changed it.
Yeah,
they could do that.
They own the fucking,
first of all,
lay Aleke weight.
Light heavyweight is never been two oh five and boxing.
It was always one 75 they turned light heavyweight into two oh five which is
bizarre as it is.
Like welterweight welterweight was one 47 when we were kids.
Sugar Ray Leonard One 47 right.
And then all of a sudden welterweight was one 70 like that's bizarre.
Like in boxing,
that's a Weirdo weight class.
That was when Roy Jones Jr was one 68 he was super middle away and it was like,
what kind of bullshit division is that?
Like there's middleweight and there's light heavyweight kind of nonsense is
this.
And everybody thought the idea of going from middle to light heavyweight,
it's crazy,
but that's only 15 pounds in the UFC.
That's a normal jump.
You know,
it was way too big.
I'm telling you man,
Rogan fighting championship.
He wants to organize the,
my idea of doing it in a basket,
the and the man of basketball court.
So way to go.
Yeah.
In rash guards.
Yup.
If you want to know your force it,
you have to where you have to wear rushcards and tights because sports
organizations at every year they meet and they discuss how they can make their
sport more offensive.
Basketball does it.
That's true.
Baseball dot.
It's all about how can we make it more offensive and they really need to look
into the greasing problem.
In MMA there's a,
greasing is definitely an issue because it's officially illegal.
It's officially illegal to Greece.
Explain how people get away with it though,
because a lot of people don't know.
Well.
Um,
in MMA,
you know,
a lot of times the matchups will be a striker against a guy who has way better
Jujitsu.
Uh,
it's really,
it's old school.
It's an old school MMA tactic that a,
you know,
if you're a Moyie Thai guy and you're going against a Jujitsu guy in an MMA
fight,
grease up,
and some people do it by,
um,
getting in a bathtub.
I've never seen anybody do it,
but everyone talks about it as getting in a bath tub of baby oil the night
before.
And then the,
and then it soaks into your pores so deep that you could take like a light
shower and you're,
you know,
if you sweat in the fight,
the oil's going to come out again and then you're gonna be really great.
Yeah.
You just get more slippery.
And the difference being is your,
it's not like anything that they could put like something on your skin and find
out that you,
yeah.
The only way that you can do that flicker,
it's illegal,
but there's no test for it.
So there's a problem there.
It is a problem.
And what it does is if you,
you want the sport to be more offensive,
the more grease the less offensive on the ground.
That's why people want standups.
Cause in the third round it's just a grease fest.
They,
they put Vaseline all over their faces that gets all over the body.
They're super greasy,
hard to submit.
When it's super greasy,
it's illegal.
The grease but no one's checking,
there's no test.
It would be better and easier instead of developing some kind of tests like
after the fight they get a swab and then they go down the fighters backs and if
it has 85% oil or whatever,
then they're busted.
They could do something elaborate like that,
I don't know.
But it's easier to just have them wear rash guards.
The Reebok rash guards,
Reebok tights that solves your problem.
You can grease if you got a girls were rash guard sort of.
They don't want anything to covers their arms but I they shouldn't.
They should.
It's backwards thinking,
you know,
you want to promote or offense on the ground.
If the let the,
if we eliminate all the grease and have everyone aligned rash guards,
people aren't slipping out of stuff.
Less defense more often.
That's what,
that's what happens.
The more grease,
the more defense,
the less authentic you want to see a grease a slop fest on the ground or do you
want to see awesome submissions?
I'd rather see submissions from a business standpoint.
If we were able to do more sponsorship stuff,
yes we look like fucking NASCAR's.
Yeah.
But Reebok into it.
If we can make money off it,
but I don't know.
I don't,
I don't like fight with clothes on.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying and don't purchase.
I get what you're saying.
Point of view too.
I think maybe making it an option wouldn't be the worst idea because if you do
have a rash guard and your opponent does,
it doesn't have one,
you definitely would be able to control
better.
Yeah.
You still have a barrier.
It's still,
there's still that barrier.
You want less,
uh,
less of a Turkish oil wrestling match on the ground.
You want to go away from that.
Right
is a good point.
And I think that the idea of seeing more submissions,
also being able to control people on the ground more would probably lessen the,
uh,
amount of,
standups that you would have to have because guys would get things done better.
It would sound solve the greasing issue just like that.
You make Reebok rash guards,
Reebok tights,
no grease problem.
It's,
it's definitely a problem with,
it's illegal.
There's a problem and no one's doing anything about it.
And if you think guys are guys that fight Jujitsu,
black belts are in Greece and well then you,
you'll probably be crazy.
Watch CNN.
Oh,
don't go there and talk to it.
Yeah,
it's um,
it's not,
we're not done.
I don't think this board has done as far as figuring out all the best ways to go
about it.
No,
I don't think ever.
We're always going to be evolving.
What do you think about longer rounds or short around?
Do you think that the five minute round is the right length or do you think like
some,
I've heard people argue they should have three minute rounds because people
could fight,
fall out faster and harder for three minutes,
then they can for five and then I've heard the other arguments for 10 minute
rounds because you get to go out of the ground like the old pride days.
You have that first round and you have plenty of time to get something
happening.
I would,
I would like the longer rounds fucking drown.
Somebody's taking in a deep water and that that's,
that's,
that's separate.
Yeah.
It's a big deal.
It also,
it allows more tactics.
Yes.
It allows you to figure out how to pace yourself more.
It allows you to figure out,
like to be very smart about when you put it on them,
you know,
and and be able to feel a person's timing out and feel whether or not they're
fading.
Guy,
I agree with you guys on that.
Think 10 minutes is
the right way to go.
It's a bit sad.
Being an opportunist.
I would,
I can see the benefits of fighting with,
with,
with a rash guard on if you're going to choke somebody out,
whether we haven't have,
have better or grappling or,
you know,
positional stuff.
Yeah,
for sure.
It'd be better rapport and there's no problems with it.
Like if you were,
yeah,
like crazy rules are still exist.
Like you can wear tights,
compression shorts to your knees,
but not to the end goal that hang the calf is dangerous.
You know what I mean?
Crazy.
I hope you rack up your ankles and some places,
George,
that George Schlatter apolis yeah.
Then we made them happen.
It just fucking,
he used to have
the less grease,
the more often you want more avance particularly on the ground for it to sound
crazy that you could fight in a rash guard and it's not going to be a problem.
People aren't going to grab it.
Girls on grabbing each other's rash guards and sports bras,
they're not being grabbed it.
It's just like,
oh,
they do.
If you were a rash guard took on a grubbing,
no,
no.
Grabbing is illegal.
You don't grab them real simple.
Nobody's grabbing anything.
Rash guard is way better than shorts cause shorts could grab all the fucking
time.
Yeah,
I think honestly like what do you see Tyron Woodley wearing right there?
That's the way to go.
Let's do it.
Let's do,
it should be the way to go on a basketball court.
See it's time for that.
I'll put it all together.
Kind of take some of my time is your money
and I'll produce it.
I need less.
That's what I need less show up.
You just show up that night.
I can't do Rogan fighting champion.
Just so busy.
I'm so much more busy than I should be.
I should have bought courts a genius idea to do.
I should be half as busy as I am right now.
Okay.
Maybe.
Maybe it'll happen.
Maybe someone else who will take that idea and run with it.
It's already being done in Russia and Russia.
They had it on a football field in the grass.
Those dudes are beating the shit out of each other at some amateur event.
So the Russian speaking of,
Oh,
the Russians thought I got cut.
This was not that long ago.
Sent me a nice to offer,
which Russians,
I don't know which ones it is and I know these people know
insurrections and it was talking to my agent and he's like,
yeah.
He's like,
guess how much the average is six figures.
I was like,
wow,
holy shit.
Well then it's a nice,
I'm going to be bargaining bargaining chip.
Hopefully I can use in the future with EFC.
Fabrizio over dooms trying to get cut so we can go over there.
They're,
they,
they're paying fucking big money.
Well,
probation for dooms always hanging in with that Chechnyan leader dude,
who's,
that scares the shit out of me.
That's like one of those things where you get over there and you just like,
you just get over there and hang out just in time to get out of there before
some crazy rebellion breaks out.
They start bombing from the sky.
Yeah.
I mean that,
I just,
man,
it was,
I was like,
okay.
Like maybe
it'd be,
is that Russia?
It's all a part of the,
uh,
old Russia.
Well,
it's,
I don't know.
They get along with Russia.
Yeah,
yeah,
they'd love MMA and Jujitsu people get mad at us,
but we don't know Jack Shit about Russia.
People get so pissed.
We'd started talking about the Ukraine.
I didn't know that.
The Ukraine speaks a different language and they were like family.
They were all part of the whole big landmass.
I loved them all.
It's amazing how many tough motherfuckers come out of,
they are the world's Sam's is Christ such bad asses over there from the top to
the bottom.
What?
James James is going to give us a map here.
The Russian republic.
It is,
oh,
there you go.
So,
uh,
that guy,
he loves MMA,
that Chechen leader and he's always got like MMA fighters from the UFC over
there.
What is he?
The president,
but I don't know what kind of leader.
Just paying them money.
I don't know.
Like what the name is to find out what the Chechnyan Lieber leader is.
Is he like,
like what does Putin is the president of Russia,
right?
They call it president.
I think he said some other others.
Not an MRI or minister prime minister.
I don't know.
We should know.
Yeah.
But we're American.
There's a computer somewhere in Magens.
Don't know Jack Shit about what's going on the rest of the world.
We know what's Brexit here about Brexit,
Britain,
but they're doing another wolverine movie.
Thank God Logan.
Apparently they made this one extra fucked up so it had to be PG 13 like they
decided to make it way more violent.
It's rated R.
Oh,
that's right.
Radar.
Not PG 13 because they wanted to do it the right way.
Super violent.
Could tell she'd been Luke in much three [inaudible] hands.
[inaudible] that's his name.
Is this supposed to be prequel or sequel question?
He looks older there,
so I guess it's like later in his life,
several weeks ago,
a baffling image made the rounds on social media.
Chechnya is menacing and unsavory.
President.
There we go.
He's the rams.
And how'd he say his name?
Cadre.
Cad.
Cad caddy.
Rove jubilantly positioning side by side with UFC heavyweight champion for
Reesey over doing,
well,
he's not heavyweight champion anymore.
Holding his oversized belt.
Was is an old picture,
is that what it is?
Or this is an old article.
You have champs.
Complicated Russian ties.
Well,
yours is from brushing
my boy.
He's doing some,
some espionage.
Yeah.
Well some,
some rich famous,
some rich leader just likes him.
So yeah,
I paid him to fucking go hang out with him.
What?
He likes those dudes to come over and party with them.
I mean,
when you're a super powerful baller in some other country,
that's like the ultimate,
you get the heavyweight champion,
the UFC to come hang with you.
Yeah.
Here,
put this hat on.
Take a picture with me.
Here it is.
Eddie Bravo,
Tony Ferguson,
Habib number,
Madoff.
Holy Shit.
That's just a couple of weeks away.
That's going to be,
you're going to be there for that.
That'd be awesome.
It's going to be fucking nuts,
man.
Dude,
we're doing it.
You mean Tony is,
that's,
that's an exciting fight man.
I know.
We can't talk about strategy.
Yeah.
But um,
it's uh,
it's crazy fight between the number one and the number two contender in that
division.
The obvious strategy for Khabib is to try to take Tony down and the obvious
strategy for Tony is to keep it up and dot.
I'm up on his feet.
That's the obvious and everybody knows that.
Let me think.
How much do you think,
uh,
like opinion changed when he got clipped by Michael Johnson and got wobbled?
People are saying,
and I mean if you're looking at,
I mean it's pretty obvious.
Okay.
He,
he,
he's human.
Yes.
That's really what you saw.
Exactly.
Cause for 24 or five or 23 fights before that,
right.
[inaudible] mall and motherfuckers basically says that he does,
he's not one of those guys that can take anything.
You know,
there's guys out there that can take any shot.
They haven't been rocked yet.
Right.
We're seeing a little,
maybe a little chink,
a little tiny Cenk.
Everybody's looking at that.
You know what I mean?
It's going to give people confidence,
but he's so good at taking people down and mauling him.
You know,
that that is the hardest thing to stop.
But you know,
we're doing everything we can to prepare for the best.
The worst,
the worst case scenario.
The best scenario where we're,
we're doing,
I mean Tony's doing everything really.
Tony is a fucking,
he's a maniac is the most fascinating fight in the division for me outside of
Conor McGregor versus IB.
Those two fights.
Conor McGregor versus,
that'd be even Tony Ferguson versus could be.
Those are the two most exciting fights and in my opinion,
without giving anything away,
everybody knows based on the past that Tony can seriously choke people.
Anybody out like any,
any wrong move on the ground and he could hit that Doris from any position and
he just,
it just keeps
growing and expanding and he's,
he's become so unorthodox on his feet on the ground is pulling guard,
flying him a nice,
he's all over the place.
He's doing gymnastics,
he's doing flips.
He's doing but he's doing now what he's doing.
He does ever all thing.
I don't even really know.
I tried to do it in big bear.
I'm like Ah.
He does [inaudible] ball.
Yes.
Steel Bowling Ball and he does all this crazy like almost like dancing does with
it.
It looks like he brought a wing Chung dummy up to big bear.
He's into wing Chung.
He's into everything.
Everything man.
He is a true sign.
That wasn't like a joke that he's really into it.
He likes,
he trains like no one I've ever seen before.
It just hours and hours just out in the front up in big bear.
He built everything,
the bags,
the stands,
everything.
He builds everything.
He's got a house out there.
He's the ultimate macgyver.
No,
he rented it and built it the first two days.
Brought it all out
dude.
He's like the ultimate macgyver,
a construction carpenter.
He can build a Sarah McMahon would take down.
Damn do when I put my hands on her,
you know,
like when I put my hand by the interviewer,
her back is like glaze and t bowels.
Yeah.
She,
she gorilla.
She's stupid.
Strong,
strong woman.
Stupid,
strong Olympic silver medalist.
Right?
Yeah.
See this.
Here's Tony working with that.
The weighted ball.
Yeah.
It's just so what a weird way of working out.
Like he does all these strange moves with it.
Like did you ever ask him like what his philosophy is?
Philosophy is,
uh,
obviously he believes in movement training cause this is all just like some
crazy Capoeira Wera but with a steel ball,
he's doing this all day.
Yeah,
he does just,
we always just mixes it.
Oh yeah.
He's always doing something for people trying to sync this up at home.
It's round one.
I'm sorry I didn't do this for the first fight.
Round one,
three 53 50 to 351,
three 50 [inaudible] triangle task.
That's a wrap.
Sam Sarah McMahon.
He just pumped that girl back.
Gorilla squished her.
Yeah.
You know what she's hoping around?
Maybe she may be the first girl Jesus that's known for taking people down,
passing their garden,
choking him out like that there.
Go to,
you got to stop that fucking,
what did she say?
I don't know what the hell she was saying.
She's fucking scary.
Yeah.
One of the girl.
Does that take some down passes that garden chokes?
I don't can choke the shit.
That could be your shit right there.
Well,
you know she got tagged by Amanda Nunez,
choked out herself like her stand up.
She has power and her punches.
She's a big power puncher but she doesn't have the kind of power that Nunez as
Nunez is going to be a real problem for post guidance.
She might not need it.
The way she closed that arm triangle.
It's so professional.
She's,
she could,
she could take most girls down because of a ruffling.
She understands she's a finisher.
She can't take
her husband's.
Did you get to black belt right?
Yeah.
Isn't he a,
I believe he's a Jujitsu instructor.
She did it from the mount to,
yeah.
Very interesting.
I saw total pumping that grow up.
That's what she's doing and he's coached.
Shown her she's going to be going to be all right.
I had,
I had some doubts about her early cause she said some things about Jujitsu when
she first came out in the UFC,
the judge,
she didn't like Jujitsu.
She doesn't train Jujitsu or something like that.
She was like old school wrestler type of mentality but it looks like she finally
had her mind opened.
You know that was some good,
that was good.
Solid guard passing wrestlers just don't pass guards like that unless they train
Jujitsu,
you know,
wrestlers.
Some wrestlers never learned how to pass the guard.
It kind of seems like that's a thing of the past though,
doesn't it?
No,
exactly.
That's why I was kind of worried cause she would say something like that.
She was saying,
Nah,
I don't train Jujitsu.
Go wait a minute.
It's 2017 everybody needs to train Jujitsu.
If you're fighting in the UFC.
Yeah.
You have to love it.
I never heard her say that.
Did you,
what did she say that it was it like real early,
early on,
man.
Uh,
she did say something that she,
something to the effect that she hasn't liked Jujitsu.
Well my,
I guess being a wrestler early and it's an old school wrestler mentality,
that's all.
No big deal.
The only rust like that.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They're still Russell's like that and there's been a bunch that were famous to,
well there's always a bunch of people that get super attached to their style
that they started out with.
They want to prove that.
I don't blame you.
I don't blame.
The rest was,
look what happened.
Hawaii's shows up.
Everyone,
these,
these Midwestern wrestlers are looking at this.
Who's this little Mexican kid choking everybody out beating Russ and they're,
they're doing challenge matches and great.
They're like,
fuck these guys,
Huh?
How are they going to take me down and do that shit?
Most of,
most of the rest of that I ended that are like that.
They don't,
they do that because they're fucking lazy.
That's what it says.
That's what it is because they,
they're,
they're so good at wrestling and they just,
I just seems like it's just a weird little like lazy thing for one because it's
extra work in too,
because you're going to get fucking choked out and don't want to lose.
Right.
It's that kind of thing where it's hard for wrestlers to progress.
Hey,
look,
I think it stems from,
it stems from the Gracies coming out,
challenging everybody and beat him getting wrestlers.
Uh,
Dan,
Dan Severn gets choked out.
Mark Coleman's coming in,
mark homeless and trying to pass the guard.
He was trying to beat Jujitsu to hold you down.
But it also stems from the same thing is with kickboxers.
Kickboxers don't want to train Jujitsu either.
I mean that was always the problem with certain fighters.
They just didn't want to get tapped because we're still good standing again.
That's from the UFC cause you also saw the strikers getting taken down easily
and getting choked out easily.
So right away dude has been training 15 years striking.
It's thinking fuck these Jujitsu guys fucked though.
I want to learn a little take down the fence and I'm a fucking knock 'em out.
Well that's learning it.
Fuck learning yet I'm alert.
Some take down the fence and I'm still,
I'm going to still knock us cro cop.
So back in the day,
yeah there was not to stand up.
Even this whole,
even this whole thoughts on the cage and his training in different,
you know,
you're like no man,
you and then that was wrestler versus striker that that rivalry when you eat
gorge bulb [inaudible] Mark Kurt,
are you kidding me?
That do you remember how that fight went down?
Mark change can crack them.
Yeah.
Mark and mark curb took him down at will and then got tired,
would never pass the guard.
Never tried passing the gods above.
Changin had a decent guard.
He had a good survival guard.
He had good guard recovery and Mark Curtain,
uh,
admittedly never worked on passing.
He just felt that he could just stay in the garden,
pound someone,
but you couldn't do it.
Devolved off chance involved,
potentially kept tying them up and then late in the round,
late in the fight,
he couldn't take them down anymore.
They were both on their feet.
Marker was folding and that's when you got to vote.
Changin
lit him up.
Remember that?
It was very interesting back then.
If Mark Kerr what had just spent day one,
once he decided to do MMA,
let me get rid of good passing and mountain.
Okay.
But will.
But in all fairness,
that was the least of his problems.
That guy was on a million different drugs that documented this smashing
machines.
Such a crazy documentary.
Shouldn't find out what exactly he was doing.
Like,
whoa.
Like that guy was fighting the toughest fighters in the world while he was
shooting heroin.
I mean,
he was,
he was shooting like all sorts of crazy paint.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
do,
did you ever see this smashing machine who shooting up opiates shooting now he
was.
It was all pharmaceutical grade,
you know,
painkillers.
He raised up all the steroids and stuff.
Crazy documentary.
You never saw a number this?
Yes,
but I just remember the steroid part.
Oh,
that was nothing.
He was slamming painkillers and it was fucking veins and he would just sit in
there and letting them film the whole thing.
Yeah.
It's like fucking yes,
exactly what I was described for help.
But you know,
fresh bottles of whatever painkiller he was fucking taking,
judging it straight in his arm.
They thought when they were filming him that they were filming the baddest
motherfucker on the planet earth and they were like,
oh my God,
we're watching this guy.
Right as he falls apart,
like right as the filming started beginning getting,
he was falling apart.
Here it is Tony Ferguson.
So here's the sleep.
Sheer luck,
luck.
What's going on,
it's going to be very hard to take down.
And if Khabib takes him down,
he's got to be really worried about them.
Chokes that we've already seen.
Yes.
So He's,
he can just take down Tony,
like he did Michael Johnson and not worry about legit chokes from all sorts of
[inaudible].
It's,
it's all in the transition.
So it tends to in great Marcella teens,
if he raps,
he's always looking for Darcy.
So,
uh,
could be,
you know,
he's one of the best grapplers in the UFC.
No doubt.
He may be the best at a grounding and pounding and controlling you like a,
like a legit high level black belt.
He passes.
Who knows how it's going to match up against Tony Man.
But we're preparing everything we can.
We,
we're doing everything we can.
I don't know how it's going to look when it's all said and done,
but we're doing the best we can to prepare for the worst case scenario.
Who knows what's going to happen.
But uh,
the one thing's for sure is one mistake on the ground and Tony's going to wrap
your that.
Yes,
but this motherfucker as well.
I mean,
one mistake on the ground and Habib number,
good Madoff's going to fucking break your arms.
He's,
he's a freak.
And that's why this is so an interesting,
because Tony's a freak too.
And like when you see Tony fucking up Hofeld dos Anjos here.
I mean,
man,
Tony Ferguson easily could have been the UFC lightweight champion of the world
if he caught Hofeld Dosantos when dos Anjos had the bell,
he could have got him.
And you know,
Tony,
I think Tony could do that to anybody.
How did the,
how did he beat,
um,
Barboza was he,
did you just choke Barboza yes,
he dodged him,
right?
Yeah.
That was it.
Right here.
I'm standing and I'm
finished him off on the ground.
It was perfect.
Tony.
Something special and that's why this fight is so interesting because hubby was
obviously something special.
He's the only guy that's a contender that has been fighting the best guys in the
world and is undefeated as he fights for the title.
That's so unheard of.
Everybody may get one or two.
Everybody's got early in their career.
They've got a fight or two that they lost,
but he's one of the very few guys that has only shown one moment in his entire
career inside the octagon where he really didn't look so good.
And that was a brief moment where Michael Johnson hit him.
Obviously he recovered from that and came back to that as much smashed him
smushed down.
He just,
when he gets guys on the ground,
it's almost like he's a different weight class than them.
Yeah.
There's levels,
thousands of levels of being heavy and he's super heavy.
He sticks on.
He's a great guy.
I saw him in person at my fight.
That fight the law was supposed to happen is passing a big his passing to from
full guard or to like open guard right into he forces a,
a z guard or a quarter z.
Like right away there's movement to set up the half guard that he's going to try
to pass.
Brilliant.
His knee slash is brilliant.
Uh,
his mount is control.
That crucifix move,
man.
He's a black.
Everybody knows it.
Very few people do it.
Yeah,
he's,
he's always looking for it.
And obviously he's,
you know,
if you look at his earlier fights,
he's got triangle chokes.
I mean,
he could finish off your back too.
He's,
so that's a tall order,
tall order for Tony.
But believe you me,
Tony is looking pretty damn good to me right now on the ground.
So it's going to be,
um,
crazy seeing how it all plays out.
Yeah.
I'm so excited for that dude.
I'm,
my head's going to explode.
Yeah.
It's so crazy fight and it's,
it's going to be even more crazy if you just got so much invested in it.
You know,
for me as a guy that gets to sit there and call that fight,
I'm fascinated just because when you see a guy like Tony Ferguson,
you know,
he's a problem.
Like how do you solve that problem?
Like what's the solution to that problem?
And,
um,
I don't know what the answer to that is.
You know,
I would say a guy who can keep the fight standing up and tee off on them and
land good strikes,
like maybe a guy who takes advantage of the aggressive style that number grew
Madoff has.
But you know,
maybe Tony's that guy,
it's going to be interesting as as,
um,
Michael Johnson Shell,
you can't,
you can't punch him,
you can't hit him and we can land and get shot.
You can rock him.
And I think that that's going to be the main place to catch him.
But if you can catch him,
keep on the outside,
you know,
you don't want a guy like that who fights of that way,
that good at grappling and that could arresting and takedowns and constant
pressure in your face the whole time.
He got to keep them outside.
And then I think Tony tell him up to do it because again,
seeing how small could be was last weekend I was like,
man,
he's not that big of a guy.
You know,
I'm a huge fan of his,
I think he's fucking awesome.
But he walks around big 75 maybe,
maybe,
you know,
he just didn't see he,
and you know how the Russians travel there always in groups of fucking a
hundred.
Yeah.
So it's always entertaining and they're,
they're fucking hilarious.
But he's just didn't seem that big at all.
I was like,
wow,
huh.
That was,
that was the only thing that shot him because he's so strong magnets.
Everybody we saying something.
Oh I'm hearing the,
I thought that was you.
Okay.
The problem with the TVs up a little loud.
I'm confused.
You would think like,
he,
he'd be built like he bow to ragdoll seem like the,
I think the glaze and t bell thing only works without Usada.
Yeah.
Do you know when Grayson got popped and they,
they found like a punch of different shit in them.
They're like,
dude,
I mean if anybody was going to get caught glazed and t bow looked like it was
300 pounds and it was fighting one 55 so fucking big.
I'd never seen anybody that was remotely as big as glazing when Grayson was at
the top.
See,
gets so massive.
Like he was so big,
he was so big.
He was Jack.
He cutting from,
from over 200 pounds and Sha readed like completely,
totally shredded.
I was a,
I was touched sparring with um,
with RDA the other day cause he's,
you know,
I'm trying to get Ruca now and,
and he's over there a little bit and I was like,
dude,
you're not that much taller than me.
But he's probably 205 pounds.
Wow.
Fucking huge.
And he's welterweight now.
Yeah.
But I'm just trying to move him and trying to just,
you know,
are playing but trying to foot sweeps and I do the fun shit.
Jesus Christ,
he's really heavy.
Really?
Yeah.
He's decided to go the way of Donald's Serone move on up.
I don't think it's a bad idea.
Not Mom.
Again,
I keep going back to this,
but I'll say it again.
I think it's the worst thing in fighting his weight.
Cutting.
I think it's the worst thing.
I think you're seeing guys that make the weight but they can't fight up to their
ability,
their bodies compromised even though their mind is willing and they feel like
pretty gangster about it all.
They,
they dose don't fight the way they can.
And when they move up you see him fight much better.
I mean,
barring Donald,
his last fight,
which,
um,
I think Brendan Schaub had a really good point when he said it was just too
close to that fight that he had with Matt Brown.
He got rocked in that fight.
He got dropped in that fight and he just looked like he was vulnerable.
But then again,
he's also fighting Jorge Mosbey Dahl,
who's a bad motherfucker.
Jorge's a very interested,
very talented guy and very diverse.
He can do everything and slick [inaudible] guys that's been under pressure so
many times,
not even in his fighting career.
You see where the guy came up and all these crazy ass videos,
even fighting on the street and back yards that he is very calm under pressure.
He is,
and he is also,
you know,
he's unpredictable.
Yeah.
Like he likes to mix things up.
He's real good at doing whatever the hell he wants.
You know,
he's had fights where he got hurt.
Like Darin Cruickshank heard him and uh,
he said,
all right,
dude,
turn this into a wrestling match.
And he just wrestled him to the ground,
beat the shit out of him.
He's a real versatile,
he can do anything.
And so Donald lost to him.
I think that's a tough fight for Donald,
even if Donald wasn't hurt.
Yeah.
You know?
So take that out of the way.
I think Donald at one seven he's look better than he's ever looked at.
One 55 by far.
And I just think that's,
you know,
I think that's a function of this disintegration of your skills that comes with
the losing the weight.
It's like what's the point of diminishing returns?
When do you get where the diminishing or the cutting of the weight,
the,
the benefit that you get in the size is not enough to overcome the amount of
weakening.
Yes.
That your body's done.
Like Tony's a good size for 55 like Tony probably done get over one 75 like what
does telling me walk around at very easy cuts.
Yeah.
He don't fuck around.
Yeah,
that's the right way or easy cut.
That's the right way.
He's dude,
I'll never forget her leaving.
Cutting.
Never Forget Travis Luder when Travis Luder fought Anderson Silva for the title
and I've watched Travis shuffle to the,
to the scale because he couldn't walk because he couldn't pick his legs up.
He was shuffling,
his lips were all cracked and he was like,
there was blood coming out of his lips.
Like you could see the skin,
like the skin.
It was broken.
Yeah.
Like his body had no water in it,
there was nothing left.
He was done and he did it.
Still didn't make the weight and he took Anderson Silva down at will mounted
them.
I mean Travis Luder was a bad motherfucker.
He's one of those people that people forgot cause he was one of the best
American Brazilian Jujitsu black belt at the time.
Like super respected Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
black belt.
And does ea world any world titles?
I don't think so.
I don't know what he's one as far as grappling Edie.
Andy,
what do you think?
I don't know.
But he was upset,
was one of the best in his,
in his time.
You know,
he was up there,
he was right up there with anybody as far as grappling goes.
And you would see it when he was fighting guys,
he would just pass their guard,
get the mount fucking spin for an arm bar and be like,
Ooh,
that's how he's supposed to do it.
And they're hyping this fight up.
I love it.
I boob attorney focusing.
You see Josh Koscheck fight yesterday.
That was kind of sad.
Koscheck got rocked.
They got taken out and that Thompson got Josh.
Josh got knocked out.
You right.
Yeah.
Taken out too.
I just think after a while,
man,
you know,
there's nothing,
not that much durability left in the brain.
Thompson got it looks like you've got headbutted first.
And then he got clipped with a little bit of a left hand and then they read
engaged and then he got caught with a big upper cut.
He just slumped that.
That pit bull dude can punch though.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I bought those brothers can crack.
Yeah.
Both those brothers.
So it's uh,
you know,
Bella Bella,
tor is no fucking joke right now,
man.
Bella tour has guts,
especially they're 170 pound division.
Douglas Lema is a killer.
He's a fucking killer dude.
The way he took out Corish cloth and after Korskoff fucked up Benson Henderson.
Yeah.
Just lets you know like that is a shit division.
It's a really good guys.
And now you got Paul Daley there and you got Michael Venom page and then you got
Roy MacDonald that they uh,
who had Robert Down with fights,
which one?
He fights.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
What do we just say?
He fights a device.
One of them in April.
Paul Dale.
Jesus Christ.
Why can't I say his name?
He fights Paul Daley.
Yeah,
that's a,
and I think it's in May.
That's going to be,
if it's a big fight.
Yeah.
It's a big fight because all I do has to do is just barely connected to your
brain.
Well,
Roy has been having a problem for a long time with his nose,
so he decided to take a full year off and let us know his heel.
And,
uh,
that was when he signed for belt or that was the understanding that he was going
to take all this time off and let us know as heel because every time you get
punched in the nose we just start bleeding bad and he wouldn't be able to
breathe out of it.
And you have to open your mouth up.
Yeah.
I don't know if he's any surgery or anything to to fix it,
but he thinks he could fix it by taking time off maybe.
And then that seems like something you have to have some sort of surgery done.
Yeah,
I mean I don't know what can figure everything.
Yeah.
I don't know what the damage was.
But after that Robbie Lawler fight,
I mean that,
that knows.
Got smushed.
This is an interesting fight.
The last Theodore.
Oh versus say Zolpha hey ya
say hey.
It was highly touted after he won the ultimate fighter in Brazil.
I think I found on the same card as him a long time ago.
So big fella.
Yeah.
So big fella to be making 185 pounds to two guys giant.
What does he,
is he the one that was like a protege to be Twitter?
Yeah.
Okay.
The other key,
he's the one that,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's large.
He's eat.
Door's gonna Fight Calvin.
One Dat is interesting.
Calvin.
Looks good.
We're going to be building up buzz saw through veto I think.
I think so.
But Vito is fighting in Brazil.
Is that going to have any factor?
I am.
Don't know.
I thought they do.
They go down like who's they do Sada.
But you'd make a terrible mobster,
you know the thing God,
well,
the thing that,
that the,
you know the guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
They're a man Jeff to Wicki.
I got it.
I,
you know,
I've,
I've become a fan.
He's a bulldog.
He's a fucking Aye.
Aye.
You know,
you can see how most athletes would look at him and be like,
fuck this guy,
you know,
just,
just strictly for his job alone.
But the guy's been,
you know,
been very good to me.
He's a good dude.
Yeah.
Jeff's a good dude.
He's a very smart guy too.
Yeah.
And um,
he's not fucking around,
man.
He's cleaning sportup singlehandedly.
You seen people fall off the map?
Yeah.
And some of them are on this car tonight.
One.
Yeah.
I mean I literally like you've seen him fall off the map because they're not the
same without the shit.
Exactly.
Ooh.
Oh Hey.
I caught him with that left.
I mean there's a,
there's a big difference between guys on Shit and not on shit.
Yes.
I mean anybody who's doing help,
you're crazy.
Go fight Vietor
go fight DRTV door or shut the fuck up.
Because of course they help.
They help in a giant way.
Anybody who tells you differently is just,
they're either lying to themselves or they're on fucking steroids too.
Because here's the thing,
there's guys that are mentally strong and durable and they're warriors and
they're on steroids.
Like the idea that you can have either or,
you know like either you have a guy who was tough or you have a cheater.
No,
you have tough cheaters.
Like those are real,
there's really tough cheaters.
Like,
especially if they know that everybody else is cheating.
Yeah.
They'll cheat too.
And I think that's,
you know,
I mean when you see me,
no disrespect,
but when you see cro cop come back and win rise and we're in the horizon back in
Japan at 40,
whatever he was,
I think he was 43 or 44.
Oh four nine two how will he,
his legs are back to being just fucking 34 inches shredded six pack look in huge
looking to be about two 35 to 40.
Again,
cracking dudes beat the fuck out of Kim Mo.
Yeah.
King King Mo was,
I mean that was King Moses.
Serious fighter man.
He's a tough guy and he fucking crumpled him.
Yeah.
And just shucked off the wrestling and caught him with some hard strikes
and he's uh,
he's just such a hard kicker to that.
If you just take one of those in the arms,
I mean your,
your life level,
like in a video game,
he kicks you so head down it changes your whole outlook on life.
One kick to the arms and you're like,
oh,
you just,
you just start going,
what am I doing?
Like Zig when I should have zagged.
And that fucking thing catches me.
Yeah.
These are coming in my face,
but wait a second.
So let me ask you this,
Ian,
now that you've gone through these five fights,
they did Ooh,
beautiful leg kick and returned.
But people,
it's interesting,
you know,
you talked to Maureen Thai guys and they'll tell you don't ever try to return a
leg kick after someone throws a light kick,
cause they're gonna know you're going to do it and they're gonna check you
because it's human instinct.
Yeah.
But in MMA kind of works sometimes.
What now you're dealing with five fights in a row.
That didn't,
didn't happen.
Are you?
You starting to think like,
Hey,
maybe I'm not going to do this anymore.
Of course you must be right.
Yeah.
And I mean,
I thought about,
I thought about that before when I signed a fight,
this most recent fight against Scoggins.
Um,
I literally was like,
I laughed as I was signing it and I was like,
I'm not gonna my arm wasn't working.
I'm like,
sure,
whatever.
Sure.
I'll,
I'll take a fight.
What arm wasn't working?
My right one after my surgeries.
You shoulder serve after my shoulder surgery.
So if people don't know,
I've had three surgeries on my hand,
I fractured dislocation on my elbow.
Show your,
show you the fist that you're capable of making.
And that's my,
that's my fist.
Yeah,
it expands to that and close to that.
So I get to beat people up with this,
which is real cool because when you spot have a good day of sparring,
it just nice and swollen.
Um,
the joking,
joking,
the people only listen to us.
Ian Can't totally close his hand and his index finger,
his index finger protrudes.
So like if you punch someone wrong,
I'd probably just re breaks.
Yeah.
Um,
and you can't really,
I mean,
can you actually punched them with your knuckle?
No.
How do they let you fight like that?
I ran,
I'm,
everything's corked.
I just figured it out and a lot of elbows and I,
I mean I,
I,
it's why I've been kicking for most of my,
you know,
for the last,
how many years has been three years cause my hand and then I ended up having my,
um,
my shoulder we done,
I had a fully torn bicep tendon to labral tears in the fully torn rotator cuffs
and then there's that Jamie.
Oh,
so that's my right arm and I just wasn't working.
And then finally,
uh,
I asked my doctor,
I'm like,
I want to get another Mri because I have,
I just signed for a fight.
So we got an MRI and he's like,
okay,
you want the good news?
Yes.
He's like,
stop being a bitch.
you want to fight?
He's like,
just fucking fight through it.
it's going to hurt,
but your shoulder's fine.
[inaudible] causing the pain.
It was just from all the scar tissue and all the impingements I'm whatever.
Do you ever hang buddy shoulders?
They were hanged.
How often you do that?
Not often enough.
I do it every day.
I need,
I need to get one from my house off for 30 seconds and I worked my way up to two
minutes.
Nice.
And Yeah,
30 seconds of my warmup.
You know,
I warm up,
I hold for 30 seconds,
but a,
I get to the point where I'm holding them hanging for two minutes.
Nice.
I've been doing the shit out of my hands too.
Got To chalk up one hands or your elbows complete.
Locked debt is locked.
Like my hands gripped.
I grip,
I death grip that bar but thumbs out like you know,
Jujitsu style and they're actually hanging,
hanging.
There's no pull up at all.
No,
no portal.
Just total locked arms out and I feel stuff loosening.
Yeah.
You feel my shoulders pull up if you do it pop two minutes a day,
whatever.
Good for your shoulders man.
It's,
it's supposed to be one of the most amazing things for rehabilitating shoulders
because seconds and then two minutes,
well I worked my way up to 30,
I'd go 30 seconds and I'll do another set of 30 seconds and then I'll do a
minute and then I'll do two minutes for like my final one.
And then I do Chin ups and I do chin ups.
Now lately I've been doing heavy chin,
so instead of just regular checkups now do chin ups with a 70 pound kettle bell
strapped to my waist.
I put one of those bars,
you know,
those uh,
weight,
those vests,
not best belts with the chain,
you know,
like for depths and shit.
And I put a kettle bell in there and I'll do chin ups with 70 pounds.
How many can you do?
Five.
Holy Jesus.
Yeah.
What?
No,
that's not,
that's true.
It's not that bad.
There's some lucky,
it's okay.
Five is not a lot.
I could barely handle my own weight.
How much I may chat ops.
Can you do a when I'm in shape?
Yeah,
probably when I'm in shape.
1213,
just straight strict.
All the way down.
All the back up.
You're not locked out though.
I can do 16 chin ups all the way down,
all the way back up,
all the way down,
completely locked arms.
And then all the way chin over the bar.
I can do 16 I can do 24 if I just go like this.
You know that shit that people do when they say I do 24 Chin ups.
Oh I can too if you do them that way.
But if you go all the way down,
sometimes they'll wait a bat,
but also want to do it that way.
When I'm doing it,
I'm not doing it to show how many chin ups I can do.
So when I do the negatives,
my negatives are twice as long as my positives.
And sometimes I fuck around and do real slow negatives for Hay is not really an
Armbar guy,
but he's got the back.
I thought he was gonna slide over for it.
Now he's riding the guy,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
but he's got decent Jujitsu.
I like how he's staying close to him.
He's squeezing the shit out of him.
Oh,
lost it.
Good defense.
Yeah.
That's grease right there.
You're right.
See,
I was going to say,
yeah,
he gets ups right off that guy.
Go like this and then your slider.
And there's no need to put Vaseline over their eyes cause they grapple and get
in the way.
It's true.
I mean,
it definitely becomes a factor in a fight.
There's no doubt about it.
Stop.
Put the Vaseline on the eyes.
Yeah.
That grease gets everywhere.
It fucks up the ground.
We'll get so slippery.
Well,
it's one of those things that they have to kind of do to stop bleeding though.
If there is a cut,
they have to do it.
But they do it even when there's no cut.
Yeah.
They should eliminate that.
They don't let the,
uh,
the corner do it anymore.
Now it's a,
it's gotta be a come in.
Yeah.
Do you remember when Pat Miletich fought Carlos Newton and Jeremy Horn was in
the corner and he even jokes about like,
he doesn't even know why he did it.
He was like putting Vaseline on Pat's neck.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's like,
I don't even know what the fuck I was doing.
And he's like,
I can just massaging of him.
He goes,
he's like,
I don't even know why I was doing it.
And then anyway,
it turned out to fuck him because Carlos Newton got him in that bull dog choker
and just whip slipped right under the chin.
You remember that?
Yes.
Carlos got Pat Miletich and one of the first bulldog chokes we ever saw in the
UFC.
It's only been like three bill dog chokes and the UFC is actually,
um,
at lunch.
Um,
Ashley Evan Smith got choked out by Raquel Pennington.
That was a fucking wild one.
Raquel Pennington.
Raquel Pennington is one,
two UFC within one second where I was screaming so loud,
I was blown out.
People's ear drums like,
oh,
I'm going to look like the one with Ashley.
Evan Smith though was crazy because there was blood everywhere and she gets her
in the bulldog choke and she's got her face down and then she,
it's like the end of the fight fucking thing.
I let her off and she's out.
Colon is blood everywhere.
It was a chaos.
And um,
the other one was Chris Lights out.
Lidell against Dki.
He got,
he got to have a tight
that head out hair grease.
Now how much,
how much grease can you get in those dreads?
Yeah.
How about that?
Huh?
Oh,
ground
and pound there.
Doro.
He's a tough guy.
Lies.
Theodora
um,
but yeah,
so that was the other bulldog choke.
There's been three that I could think of.
Maybe there's been another one that I forgot or maybe I didn't call the fight.
That's a rare move though.
But it's one of those things,
man,
if you're in front and you're sitting out and you've got it locked in,
you've got someone's neck trapped on your forum.
Ooh,
that's a good chuck.
It's very hard to,
very hard to get out of that because you're a good move Eddie,
to get out of that.
If someone's got it locked in and they're sitting out and they really got that
fucking head in there and you're back this way and like you're on your knees
like a lot of guys who seem to get it.
What the fuck do you do to get out?
I mean obviously move forward and try to take the back.
Oh,
well I'd have to get down on the mats and you'd have to show me exactly what a
hard show to get out of.
It's hard to uh,
explain with words.
Hmm.
You know what I've been seeing guys do too,
I've been seeing guys get like,
get into like a guillotine position from the back and lean forward on a dude
like getting like a gay teen.
Like he'd do like this,
but they've getting it from behind and leaning forward on a guy.
I saw somebody do that recently where he didn't,
he didn't,
it was like from a north south position.
He didn't have hooks in.
He caught like,
like a gay teen from behind and had his head trapped by his shoulder and lean
forward.
And I was like neck cranking him and choking him at the same time.
It looked fucking nasty.
It's like you see a thousand fights and he'd say,
well,
I pretty much never see everything.
And then someone comes up your shit and you go,
Whoa,
let me see that again.
Whoa.
I got put in a,
uh,
just a regular school yard chuck wants and it,
it fucked me up,
man.
I,
I did little league baseball and I sucked.
I always led the league and strike outs.
I was terrible.
I was a,
but I had my moments.
I remember like I connected once and it was fucking dead center and they caught
it.
And was it,
that was my glory as I hit like a,
a ball deep into center field.
It was caught though,
but at least I hit it.
I would strike the fuck out.
But I played catcher and um,
so he didn't have to move.
I sucked.
So it was like ages eight to 12.
Right.
So there's eight year olds and then there's 12 year olds.
I sucked.
But I was born in,
in a,
in a month where I made the costs.
I was an old dude now and I could still play little league and they go,
you want to play another year?
And I didn't,
I was tired of being humiliated,
but I was older than most of the guys.
So even though I shocked how was like two,
three years older than most of the guys on the team.
So they wanted me to be the,
like the captain and Oh man,
I was such,
I so didn't want to do it.
I was being a total debugged.
Everybody,
everybody on the team and our right fielder had a plastic glove and I would make
fun of his plastic glove.
I was such an asshole.
Why didn't make fun of his glove?
I was just an asshole because I was an older,
an old,
I was the older of this team.
We are,
I mean,
I'm hanging out,
forced to be hanging out with eight year olds and nine year olds and I'm 12,
you know,
and I don't want to be here,
but the coaches want to be there because they thought I had leadership skills,
but I still sucked.
I still couldn't hit anything.
I still,
I couldn't connect ever.
I was just always striking out.
And um,
but um,
they had me pitching and shit just cause I was older than them.
I was a terrible picture.
But um,
anyways,
I was taught a Raphael who had the plastic glove.
We were all huddled together after practice and I was talking shit on him,
on his plastic glove and he just got me in a headlock dude and just held me
there and I didn't know what to do.
And he fucking used all his,
his hate towards me.
He squeezed my motherfucking head.
This guy hated the shit out of me and I couldn't do anything.
I had no more.
I was 12 years old and in front of the whole baseball team,
he finally was the one that snapped because I was a dick.
To everybody and I was just like the older kid and I,
you know,
my ego was exploding because I'm the older kid and I'm the captain of the team
even though I suck.
Yeah.
Um,
I just was that,
I learned my lesson,
man.
I learned my lesson because he put,
he,
I,
I stopped talking as much shit after that cause I quit the baseball team.
I just disappeared.
Man.
I was gone.
You embarrass me in front of everybody.
I was like,
can you imagine,
you know,
was he,
he was like nine or 10.
He was the,
it was an eight to 12.
Literally it was something like that.
He was a younger kid.
You need a tissue.
But he grabbed my motherfucking head and embarrass the shit out of me.
Man.
I was,
I felt like I was going to die.
I had no idea how to get out.
Yeah.
Those,
that's a real choke if you can get it right.
I mean,
you've got to figure if someone like Marcella Garcia who has an insane
guillotine,
if he can get you in the oil school yard head chokes,
the squeeze is still there.
It's still very similar.
It's a very similar way of using your arms to choke someone's neck.
We haven't seen it all,
man.
You remember that?
There was one dude who had this crazy choke.
He was one of Tiger showman's guys.
God Damn,
I'm trying to remember his name.
He was about that.
Who's the founder from Gary Goodridge.
Oh,
Joe Herrera.
Goodrich.
Paul Herrera.
Is that up?
Can you find that?
Oh yeah.
You got the most brutal Kao still an MMA history.
It was a brutal,
brutal.
There's nothing more brutal.
Gonzaga versus Cro.
Cop's right up there,
dude.
He was not,
he was in the cotton.
A crucifix was getting elbowed and his faces.
I'm whining about blowing up,
but boy,
that was a brutal,
brutal man.
Yeah,
here it is.
He shoots in,
goes to the fireman's carry,
gets caught in a crucifix,
and this is where the g helped Gary goods at the sprawl.
Look at this.
Look at this right here.
Look a traps that arm and then once he's got that on Blam Blam Blam Blam Blam
Blam blam.
He is out fucking cold.
He was out cold and he probably got hit with like five the hard shot.
Did you see that Jamie?
While he was out cold?
The most brutal ever,
right?
That was brutality.
They didn't show a replay either when,
when it was online there was no replay.
They never got to replay blam blam they never wanted to replay that.
I mean that is crazy.
That is one of the craziest Kaos ever.
Do you remember,
wasn't it Paul Herrera that fought in that?
Do you remember?
There was a show that they did when the,
when it was illegal to have MMA in California.
So they had a show and they pretended that it was like pre scripted.
They're like,
hey,
this is just a show.
But then they had MMA fights.
The one that was in la.
Yeah.
I remember that years ago they were trying to find a loophole and I feel like he
fought Joe Merera did he call her rarefied show Maria?
And it was,
and everybody was like,
Hey,
this is a real fight.
Like what the fuck is this?
And,
but everybody was,
it was at the palladium.
What fuck was it?
I feel like it was somewhere in Orange County.
Maybe it says it forever.
I can't even wear it.
Well,
I've had a warehouse.
We got to go up the stairs.
Remember,
man,
there was this,
all of those underground days,
Eddie,
we saw so many fucking sketchy fights and sketchy places.
How many times do we go to Indian casinos and check this up.
Check this out.
I was talking to my students about this and now and how,
how I've been in the business and the MMA business making money since 2000 as a
purple belt.
I was commentating for King of the cage.
So I see all these brands,
all these fighting brands come and go.
Rage,
athletic,
death,
Kludge,
all these bralettes and going,
all of them.
All of them are gone.
Fucking gone.
Gone.
So,
and I hear it.
You know there's,
there's a man,
you know how hard it is for these companies that like rash guard companies,
man,
what does that hop up?
Hit man fighting.
That's it.
That was it.
Yeah,
it was hitman fighting promotions.
Yeah.
Going through.
So going through all my girlfriends fucking picture albums,
having sex with her is like having sex in the time machine.
Okay.
I grew up,
she was,
she,
I was raised in this fucking sport.
Like I remember going to King of the cage when I was 15.
She was there.
I remember I was going through a fucking photo album and I was like,
Oh shit.
And like you were at these fights,
the lion's den in nine in San Diego when I was like 15.
And she's like,
I put those fights on and I was like,
oh.
I remember looking across going,
Oh my God,
I'm going to,
I'm going to one day I'm going to grow up and be a professional fighter.
Just like Ken shamrock.
I'm going to fuck chick just like that.
17 years later.
Gotcha.
Bitch.
It's so fucking weird.
Growing up in this entire sport,
we should've done more stuff back in those days.
Man.
Those ones who went to those newer like babies,
we went to those,
uh,
fucking the ones in the Indian casino ones,
you know,
you know what?
I did film,
I filmed a lot and one thing that I found for sure it's two weeks before I went
to Abu Dhabi in 2003 I had my video camera with me the whole time.
I want her to make a documentary about and you are in it a lot.
And I kept this footage.
I kept this footage.
It's eight hours of two weeks,
my training camp.
Wow.
Last two weeks of the train come going to Brazil.
Did I got home video footage.
You're all up in it.
Going to Brazil,
coming back,
getting my black belt.
I videotaped the whole experience.
We never released it ever.
But um,
whereas it eventually I still got it.
I got it.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's interesting when you realized how much time has passed.
Gerald is in a lot.
He's a big star.
Get out of jail.
Yeah.
Sometime this year.
That's isn't that weird.
Like you could kill people as long as everybody agrees.
Well I guess you should have killed him or he shouldn't have killed them that
much.
So we're going to have to lock you up for a little while.
See and I remember Gerald from fucking biff from when I was at fucking teenager,
like a little kid.
He was
so weird.
That's how the whole story is so,
It's so sad.
You know,
the,
the plight of the American veteran that comes back with PTSD and the,
the issues that they have to deal with mentally and trying to,
just from being in a fucking war zone and shooting people all the time to not
shooting people all the time.
I mean,
that is a,
that is asking people to make that adjustment is one of the craziest things they
ask if people in the military,
it's pretty not to make the adjustment from military to civilian life.
Unbelievable.
I mean,
it's really a,
and you think about the length of this war from 2002 right?
2002 we've been in a perpetual state of war.
It's just so,
it's so crazy when you think of how many people have had to deal with that.
How many people have had a wrestled with that issue?
Doesn't Obama hold the record for president the most conflict or whatever?
Yeah,
he had,
he was in a war through every single day of his presidency.
Jesus Christ.
That's not true though,
right?
Well,
he inherited it.
I mean he came in in 2008 we were already at war.
Yeah,
we have.
We haven't had any,
any,
any piece since that since you said it doesn't too.
He said,
I wonder how much they can and can't do.
I really do.
I just really wonder,
I wonder how much power they have.
How am I mean?
What's what you're seeing now with Donald Trump is not the best indication of it
because he's,
he seems to be like imploding the most recent press conferences,
just like I have buddies,
they're conservative that were calling me up and go,
dude,
I'm fucking worried now or this,
this guy seems unstable.
Or there's the most recent press conference.
He did that rambling press conference when he was talking about how,
what the wide margin that he won the electoral margin.
And then this reporter says,
Mr President,
you stated that you want it by the largest margin ever when in fact Barack
Obama's margin was much larger.
And he goes,
well,
I'm meant a button.
Republican's goes,
George Herbert Walker Bush was much larger than that.
And he starts saying,
well,
this is this,
the information that I've been given I like,
he's like,
and you're watching these crows sheds,
so every,
it's so bizarre.
It's like we've never had a person that's the president like this.
We'd never had that kind of a president that you just see can't.
And then he goes,
well,
how is the American public's supposed to listen to you when you tell them that
the news is fake,
when the information that you're providing is not accurate?
And he's like,
well,
I won by a large margin,
did I?
I,
I am the president.
And the guy's like,
you're the president.
Sure you win.
It's just such a strange,
strange time for us as a country to have elected someone like that and to be
going through this process,
what we try to figure out what's bullshit and what's not and what's bullshit
about our political system.
Argue with people about everything about your life.
And none of it's ever nothing he says is ever right or even remotely factual
thing he ever says is right because it seems so stupid.
He's always full of shit about something.
He's full of shit about a lot.
Eddie.
You're just like,
what the fuck is this guy even saying like,
I don't what he's supposed to pay attention to.
Who's this homeboy?
Uh,
that I don't know.
Good.
So good.
There you go.
Derek Lewis as head coach Bob Perez.
Where's the Derrick Lewis trade out of?
You know,
I have no idea.
So this should be the next fight.
Should be Hector lumbar,
Johnny Hendrix,
Hendrix.
No one mark.
So yeah,
what's the next one?
Sam Sicilian.
Oh,
that's a good fight.
Gavin Tucker.
Sam.
Cecilia is fun to watch.
Talk about someone just throws lead.
Who is,
is there Gavin talker guy?
Just too many fighters.
I don't know anybody anymore.
I give up.
There's so many fucking be brought to research on the guys before I watch them
and you know what for I watch from fight or I have to call their fights,
but Goddamn,
it's too many people now and you have C's released.
A lot of them.
Did they little release Lorenz Larkin.
I have no idea.
That's a mistake.
I don't made engine anything.
That guy is fucking good.
Yeah,
he's,
he's so fucking good.
He's one of those guys on to watch.
Real fun to watch.
He's one of those guys that could put it together and be the champ at one 70
yeah,
you really could.
He's got that potential.
His standup is so,
oh,
so nasty and so on.
Orthodox,
that weird oblique kick that he does to the body that he used against Neil
Magni.
Did he throw in a way?
Nobody else throws it.
That's another new technique like we seen like a lot of Winkle,
John's guys doing it to the,
to the legs and no one ever,
no one ever throws it to that same side of the body.
Heal rens throws it to the body and fucking hard.
He sends you flying.
I've been practicing that on the bag.
It's,
it's a good kick man.
It's a really good kick.
There's a lot of power to it and I liked the impact a better then that's when he
fucked up Gonzaga.
I like the impact better than a front kick to the body because the front kick,
the thing about the front kick is even if you throw a front,
like a snap kick karate style,
your foot still gives a little,
your foot is kind of a flexible thing,
but when you throw it like that oblique style you're going,
he'll in and there's no give.
It's just wham.
It's a,
it's a really strong kick man.
And it's a,
it's one that very few people,
it's kind of wing Chung ish and a lot of ways,
you know,
I mean wing Chung uses a very similar technique to that.
They use it to the legs.
Right.
I don't know what I mean.
Where's the,
what's the origination of the oblique kick?
What's the origin of that?
Eddie,
do you know any idea?
Some asshole that,
I mean I'm trying to just some Kung Fu kick.
I don't know if it isn't comfortable kick.
I mean I just,
I'm trying to think of like a devotees in taekwondo because they didn't teach us
that in taekwondo.
I mean I'm,
the only thing that's similar to it was there was a,
you would do like a front kick in a different way sometimes where you would do a
stomp.
Like I would do a front kick sometimes where I would throw it and I would throw
it with the heel.
I put the money back now to the chest,
I throw it and I pull the foot way back and,
and land with the heel.
And you could get a lot of power off of that.
But I like this too,
man.
I think this might be even better,
just like a little bit of a twist to the leg,
the way,
um,
you're seeing Lorens throw it.
But Lorens might have moved on to bell tour,
man,
I don't know.
I haven't talked to him,
but I know that they were all negotiating.
And if Bella tour puts Lorenza in there too.
That's,
that's it.
That's who really good,
good way clash.
It's a fucking fuck.
Almost commensurate with the UFC and the UFC has Damien Maia,
cowboy Donald Serone.
Tell me you wouldn't want to see Donald Cerrone versus Lauren's Larkin.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
that would be holy shit.
Or Lorens versus Mazda doll.
I would like to see that fight too.
I just want to see one of those people put again now that you brought that up
please.
That's a fucking Christmas present for about
one 70 might be the most talent rich division in the UFC right now.
And the idea that Connor might one day step up to try to fight whoever wins
Woodley versus Wonderboy.
That would have been the craziest move.
I mean it looks,
lear really looks like he's going to fight Floyd Mayweather.
Connor.
Yeah.
It really looks like it's gonna happen.
It looks like there's too much money to stop.
That's what I'm saying.
So then I was thinking is that you have seen needs to,
they need to get a return on this.
All the money they borrowed.
What the best way to make that money back,
having that fight.
But it's a weird fight.
How do you,
what do you do with that fight?
You got to make an it in boxing.
You can't make it in an MMA.
It's not going to be an MMA fight.
Floyd is not going to agree to that.
So it's gotta be a boxing fight.
It'll be a and match.
So you don't have it in the UFC though.
So the UFC,
what cope promotes,
like what do they do?
They,
all three of them get together as a promotional entity.
And what kind of precedent does that set,
you know exactly as far as control,
like no,
no organization has ever had the kind of control that the UFC has,
right?
It's like it's an,
it's an epic level of control.
They,
they can choose to,
oh,
there's going to be for the interim title.
Hey,
Tony Ferguson,
Habib Neuro off.
Congratulations.
I know Connor just won the title a couple of months ago,
but the way we see it,
I've got another guy here.
You guys can be the champ.
I mean we have two interim champs right now if that happens.
Right,
because Max Holloway's the interim champ.
Max Holloway doesn't give a fuck about that title either.
I mean his,
he's just got his eyes on Jose Aldo when they gave him that belt.
I mean he literally was like this on the belt.
I want,
yeah,
I want the real one.
I want to fight all though.
So that makes at least some more sense.
Thank God they're doing another King Kong movie.
Exactly what we need.
Life and an even bigger can come even bigger than ever.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on man.
How are they?
They couldn't hide the first little one who is like,
he was,
you know,
fucking seven feet tall.
We have Google earth now,
bitch.
Yeah,
this thing's fucking 60 feet tall now.
He's not going to be high.
The first one was 50 feet tall.
This one's got Zillow was 500 feet tall,
which is one of the things that made Godzilla versus King Kong.
So fucking stupid.
Because when he went to Japan,
all of a sudden King Kong was 500 feet tall too.
So.
Well,
what the hell,
man?
Remember when he was climbing the empire state building?
He was not that big.
He was about,
yeah.
No,
not much bigger than I am.
They just vary it.
I just love,
they keep,
they run out of ideas I guess so they just keep doing the same idea with Martha.
How about the turtle?
Remember Gamarra he was spin around rockets would shoot out all his holes and he
would spin around in a circle.
Remember that shit?
You don't remember gamma?
No.
Oh Dude.
Camera was the stupidest fucking monster ever.
You Remember Camera?
If he showed me,
I would remember Jamie.
We'll pull it up.
He'll pull up gamma.
I remember Mothra.
Yeah,
I remember Mothra super moth was stupid as fuck.
Cause heat and everybody's sweaters broken.
A sweater factory is fucked it up.
Your sweaters,
man.
I have a lot of wool shit like like hunting stuff.
A lot of it is made out a wall and a fucking Moss will get in my house,
man.
And she was shit out of my wall.
There's a camera for sending me some stuff by the way.
Ah,
beautiful thing.
Would they send you?
Um,
just a little set of short or some pants.
I'm wearing a second.
Sitka,
Jack and now the mortal Emery enemies of you,
but not really.
I had to choose sides.
It's there.
Those people,
we're all so competitive with each other.
All those people in those businesses.
I guess that's the same with MMA too,
right?
Like the UFC in Beltour super competitive with each other,
but yeah,
I refuse.
Does tap out still exist?
No.
No they do,
but they don't look,
I just see it on the ground in India.
They do what?
They don't.
They're are there in pro wrestling now,
but they don't.
Yeah,
I mean it's just,
it was,
that's an example how wrestling pro wrestling is a thought with tap out now
bought out fucking years ago and then got what an hour.
Who knows?
They have some sort of a deal with pro wrestling now we're tap out is a big part
of pro wrestling.
They have to wear tap out shit.
Yeah.
That was the best thing.
They could go get that crowd.
I don't,
I mean,
I don't know if they can get them the right,
I don't know if they can get them.
Oh,
I think they did and they got him.
But did we,
do they have on though?
Do you see like people wearing tap out anymore?
I think I'd have tap out shirts with pro wrestling on it if I fucking hope mask
was a lot.
There we go.
Tap Out,
look.
Oh,
it's different.
Looked at new logo.
Okay.
Still Bulky.
Who's that guy?
Jamie.
They ticket to death.
They took it to his class.
He's got a totally different look.
The new logo,
the t above the old good move.
Fast move.
Still.
It's one of those brands.
It's just the genes there.
I see.
It just got so beaten down.
It's just one of those things that just can brands,
no brands make it not an MMA,
right.
No brands make it Reebok's.
Gonna make it though,
do you think?
No other bands.
So Reebok is a brand outside of MMA.
That's why it's going to make it an MMA sort of,
but the only reason why it's making it an MMA because of the UFC deal.
Yeah.
You know what?
It's forced.
I kind of pants now.
I wear them all the time.
I rock him right now.
Look and see that.
What are you saying Jamie,
do?
Just a few years ago,
tap out did no Reebok.
Oh,
okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Their stuff is comfortable.
I'd like it's gotten better.
The first I was critical like most,
but I actually like wearing them.
I wear them all the time.
They make good stuff.
That's not the problem.
The problem is what happened with the deal to MMA fighters had had sponsorships
before the Reebok deal came around and how much money they lost.
Yes.
That's the real problem.
It's not,
it's nothing to do with the quality of their items,
which is kind of fucked for the company.
Yeah.
Can we think about all the negative energy,
the negative press that they've gotten from MMA fans that are mad at the deal?
I was making very good money from sponsors and they like eight grand a month
when I first got in UFC
just from sponsors or sponsors.
And how much have you made from top out?
Oh,
tad.
That paid me so much that that would never thought.
How much did you made for me buck?
Uh,
I'll make five.
Five per fight.
Yeah.
And there's no other sponsors involved anymore?
No,
but I mean,
you know,
like I,
everything I had,
everything I ever wears aisle is all from companies that would sponsor me if I,
if I like Ruca or like this company
or whatever,
they would sponsor me if it was a fucking point to it.
Now,
how's your podcast doing?
I know you're doing a podcast now,
Eric Apple is that my podcast,
which is story time with uncle creepy.
That's just me kind of getting more in depth than just ripping you off.
Basically talking to my friends that are interested in me off I'd run out of the
people for me.
So it's everybody's ripping everybody off in this genre.
Exactly.
Uh,
and then the other one is there's two American animals.
It's me and my cohost Eric Apple,
who's been my,
one of my best friends for our entire lives.
We just,
we grew up together.
Um,
but we just,
it's utter nonsense,
pretty much.
It,
we just talk shit and have some fun,
just have fun and fuck around.
And so,
you know,
they're,
they're both a,
you can find them on Youtube or,
or,
uh,
was iTunes on any of this stuff you can do usually.
Yeah.
I heard one of them where I heard like one of the intros where Eric was talking
about sort of a lot of the social issues that are going on in the world today is
very aware of dude.
He tries.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a little abrasive at times.
Please.
Makoto was saying
he's,
but,
you know.
Yeah,
exactly.
Uh,
but no,
Eric's awesome.
You know,
he's,
like I said,
is one of my best friends.
He's,
he taught me how to change my daughter's diaper.
Did he really?
He walked in the fucking hospital and I was,
I didn't know how to change diapers.
He'd helped raise his sister and stuff.
And I'm sitting there and I was like,
what the fuck?
Well,
who are you?
He's like,
Nah,
Bro,
just to their great diaper.
Come here.
I'm like,
Jesus,
God,
he's like the uncle that takes us to Disneyland all the time.
But um,
you know,
if,
if you,
if you want to just hear us,
just having fun,
screwing around,
you know,
to American animals is always a good time.
Well,
now that people have seen how much Brendan Schaub,
you know,
has a,
how well he's transitioned from being a fighter to be in a podcast or,
and Brendan works hard.
I mean,
he fucking hustles.
He's constantly making new t shirts,
constantly promoting his episodes,
working on getting better guests.
I mean,
he's really gone at it and attacked it.
He's not taking it lightly.
And some,
some people they,
they look at podcasting and you know,
they just take it lightly.
They don't,
they don't get serious about it.
He got super serious about it and you know,
he's the to you two guys are the ones that have really,
we're like,
hey,
dumbed down,
do it,
you know,
like get it done.
So that's what I've been,
I've been really busted my ass to do.
And what,
you're an interesting guy and you're smart and you know a,
a person like you can legitimately transfer,
transfer and do,
do something else outside of fighting.
Yeah.
That's what I wanted to do.
You know,
I,
I like,
I just,
this the name is a little silly,
you know,
story time with uncle creepy.
But like I get to get to do whether it's,
you know,
like yeah,
he's still pocket interviewing,
you know,
just do a podcast.
Nick and Nate Diaz,
this should just get blasted.
They should,
they should do a,
let's get blasted with nick and Nate Diaz and just found fucking bong on the
table.
I would the size of a nuclear missile and just fire it up and just start talking
shit about everything and have people on how people get blasted with them.
Yes.
Get incoherent.
Forget what they're talking about.
Just blasted radio blasted radio slash two oh nine with nick and Diaz lasted to,
how the fuck could they not have an episode two oh nine in Stockton.
They have UFC 209 is coming up and it's not in Stockton.
I Dunno.
That shit is unconscionable.
They had one opportunity ever in the history of the UFC and then do,
they should have planned it.
Like I planned episode nine 11 to be Alex Jones.
He should've planned episode two oh nine to be in fucking Stockton with Nick and
Nate Diaz.
I guarantee you that shit would have gotten 2 million paper view bys for sure.
Well they said if it just bomb UFC two oh nine and then just that else.
And then city of study,
they find that they fight whoever you know,
you could get them fights.
Look GSPs back GSPs back GSP versus Nick Diaz is the perfect fight to make.
That's the perfect fight to make.
Cause neither guys fought in a long time,
neither guys in title contention and it's a super fight.
This a super fight right out of the gate.
Very true.
Good point.
So Tucker,
watching him warm up,
man,
his striking looks really crisp to be interesting to see and really well yeah.
Interesting to see him versus Sam.
But you can tell Sam's just trying to line up a shot.
So Santa throw some hay makers.
Exactly.
The dude throws,
hey,
but he's at least keeping his hands up for the most part.
They're starting to drop again.
It's a Cilia.
He's like famous for putting his hands right about waistband level and just
launch and bricks your way.
He actually has a fist underneath that beard.
I really think that that is the fight.
I really think that Nick Diaz versus GSP is the fight because it's a super
fight.
Both guys haven't fought in forever.
Both guys are not ranked and it's a fight you could sell.
Yes.
Like right out of the gate,
there's no repercussions.
But there's all show a lot of money we made,
and I'm hearing rumors about Eddie Alvarez Fight Nate Diaz,
but uh,
it was,
the reality of the rumors is I'm only hearing them online.
So I mean they might be total bullshit.
Like I could probably ask,
you'd have to read online.
Yeah,
I have a direct line to the UFC,
but meanwhile I'm reading Instagram posts.
Oh,
for real.
Is this real?
Oh Shit.
I didn't know it was for real,
but I love that fight to Eddie Alvarez versus Nate Diaz.
That's a good fucking fight.
Awesome.
There's a lot of good fights that could be made right now,
but it seems like the transition between [inaudible] and this new company,
you know,
between WME and the old guard,
it's like there's,
there's definitely been a transitionary period where some things are as well as
you think you do it.
Yeah.
Like that Brooklyn card was a hard sell.
It turned out to be like a really good fight card.
But the f the main event,
the featherweight about kind of a hard sell for a lot of people
and we all know that that title is just a place.
It's just a placeholder for Chris.
What people are mad that Chris is getting a test,
uh,
not testosterone,
a therapeutic use exemption.
There's a lot of people that are pretty pissed online.
And you're saying that you saw it was manipulated,
but I don't think that's true.
I think that they've found that whatever she's taking was the right thing to
take for whatever issue she's got.
Yeah.
They know everything.
They test you and they can see everything in your system.
They're there.
They're not stupid.
It's going to be very interesting to see what happens when Duran,
him,
he comes back if she's going to fight Holly Holm for rematch or if they're going
to go straight to Cyborg,
but what the UFC is going to decide cause cyborgs where the money's at.
Of course,
you know me.
Most people,
irregular folks don't know who Cyborg is.
She is scary,
but they'll know.
They'll know after that fight.
Yeah,
she's the,
she's this.
She's such a bad ass.
I mean,
I see you're at the gym.
She's fucking so tough and so hardworking.
She's at Ruca too,
right?
Isn't she training with Jason,
Jason Parillo.
Yeah,
she's,
that woman works so fucking hard.
She's always doing something like running a marathon,
doing this and that.
It's like,
Jeez,
runs marathons.
She just did a half marathon and then a couple weeks ago.
What was it?
Play Adrian and rocky,
that rocky three parody that an Duh
dude.
It's one of the funniest sketches of all time.
And I though is playing rocky on the beach.
It's that same as the got emotional.
Ooh.
And she's like,
well,
you know,
it's like really emotional and Cyborg plays.
Adrian.
It's hysteric.
How funny is it there sand
this day?
It's like that he,
that character that had not [inaudible] character is inexorable.
I mean,
that is,
he's connected to that.
I mean,
that is him.
That was always a goof,
like hanging around the gym.
It was always like fun.
To this day,
people think that I got in an argument with a Brazilian jujitsu black belt about
weed did.
He really did come up to me and was giving me a hard time about wheat.
I had a meeting with him yesterday.
We're,
uh,
we're thinking about doing an enter the dragon parody with,
I call it,
enter the death knuckle.
Um,
what we will probably do it.
What we'll same
is he still doing that little talk show that he was doing though when he would
sit down with people?
Oh,
Kenny from,
that was funny.
That was part of it,
that rocky sketch,
because every show is a talk show,
but he'd have a sketch that start at each show on them.
The first one was the Robert Dinero sitting with,
um,
Al Pachino in heat.
He did a scene where,
and Kenny Florian plays Al Pachino and,
um,
uh,
Hannah auto plays Robert Deniro.
That's a great sketch,
one of the greatest sketches.
Then he does a Josh Barnett one,
uh,
broke back mountain parody with her natto and Josh Barnett in the woods,
one of the greatest of all time.
And then he does,
he really does the intro.
Another one,
he redoes the intro to the incredible hulk show.
It's incredible because it had not those David Banner.
And when he sees,
uh,
when he gets child support notices,
it
infuriates
it's
dude the hand,
not the La Ronda Shell.
Are you kidding me?
He's funny,
man.
Are you kidding me?
What's interesting is MMA gets bigger.
Like that character is like more and more viable.
I mean,
that's a really good character.
He does.
Uh,
he,
he's just a total d bag.
Um,
um,
person
round to Gavin Tucker.
Sam Cecillia.
Every race has d bags.
Every race.
Oh yeah,
you got him here.
You know,
what's the ratio of the lease?
Dieback I would say Canada.
If Canada was a race
race.
Yeah.
I don't know many,
many dieback Canadians.
I would say they have the less assholes as far as countries.
I think that's the nicest country.
Oh yeah,
I would agree.
I would say Iceland never been.
Have you been?
No,
I'm just guessing.
Well,
there's so big.
I'd be like number one with like strong men.
They're like the most amount of those strong men.
There'd be kinky central banks out or something like that.
Something like that.
Iceland kicked him out.
Yeah,
didn't they?
They arrested like a lot of bankers.
I decided to just say,
fuck yeah.
Well,
the revolution do that when there's 50 people and yet frozen it on a glacier.
You're burning whale bones to stay warm.
That's racist.
I don't think it is.
Yes.
You're allowed to make fun of white people all day.
Nobody gives a fuck oil show.
I mean,
come on through the body.
Think about Mo,
I'm generalizing,
but a lot of black comedians start off with the jokes like why people do this
and this is how white people do it.
And then a white man would be like,
but can you imagine if white comedians did that?
Said this is how black people are.
Like any joke like that,
they couldn't even do one of them.
No,
you can use a black voice every now and then in your,
in your routine.
I think maybe you have but not like in a,
it's gotta be fairly positive.
Well one of the weirdest notions of people throwing around today is that white
people are the only people that can be racist.
Then black people can't be racist towards white people because they don't have
power over whites.
It is one of the most ridiculous interpretations of the Word Racist.
It's so fucking stupid.
It's,
but it's something that people are embracing.
Like you look at it online and they're like,
yeah,
tell him stay woke.
Let
people as they look really believing that you can't be racist and be black.
Like if you're racist towards white people,
that doesn't count like,
well,
what is it then?
If you just don't like all white people,
it's,
it's gotta be racist.
No,
no,
no.
It's nothing.
It's just,
it's just,
it's a free three stab at it.
Do you remember Dave Chappelle would play the white newscaster,
remember when men see is stolen?
See it literally does the same care.
Yes,
he did.
He did.
Oh yeah.
Dave Chappelle was fucking furious.
She did the same character,
like literally stole the character,
put the wig on everything.
I didn't know that the best one,
the best Chappelle sketch was when Chappelle did the racist KKK guy didn't know
he was black because he was blind
and KKK member who was blind,
and then when it's fucking robe came off,
the guy in the audience's head exploded.
Neil.
Oh,
that was the best get show of all time.
That's the best.
I mean,
it was the shortest running.
He's only two years,
but I think Chappelle show's the post fucking up and as a comedian man,
he can do sketch comedy and his comedy is fucking among the basket.
Some of his shit.
It's like you can't get any better than that.
Good.
He's got so many of those bits.
Yep.
Classic Bitch Shit you could do right there.
Boom.
He crushes Dave Chappelle crushes lies year after year.
He crushes.
Then we were watching a good fight and he walked away from everything from from
50 million.
Do you know why he too much pressure?
No,
no,
no.
They were,
they were trying to change his act.
What was happening was he was well,
look at the inside of Sam's like,
you're right.
Oh,
it's nasty.
Um,
what was happening was they had a DVD deal back when DVDs were real thing.
You know,
this is when you can make money selling DVDs and this,
this deal.
Part of it was they wanted to change the kind of sketches.
They didn't want him using the word nigger anymore.
They wanted him to stop doing certain sketches.
May just clean it up a little bit.
Yeah.
They'll like,
you could have it just as funny,
but cleaning up a little bit and Dave just recognize what was happening and he
recognized the compromise.
He just didn't want all these people telling them what to do.
He's like,
look,
we've made it so far.
It's so successful and so funny cause you leave me the fuck alone and all of a
sudden you're saying,
well we can make more money if you just,
if you just listen to us.
And he was like,
fuck it.
Well and went to Africa,
went to Africa,
hung out in Africa for a little bit and just realize like what am I doing?
And then from then on he didn't book any gigs for a long time and he would just
show up and do gigs.
He would bring a portable speaker and set up in a park in Seattle and people
would just gather round.
He wouldn't even let them know he was there.
He didn't use social media who just show up and he,
we started doing sets.
It's still to this day shows up places.
When I was in Denver,
I got offstage in Denver,
my second show,
Friday night I go into the green room,
Dave's there.
I go,
what are you doing?
He goes,
oh,
hey Joe.
I go,
do you want to go on stage?
He goes,
oh,
should I go?
Fuck yeah.
I grabbed him and I go out.
The audience was leaving and I go,
come back.
I go,
We're going to restart the show.
Dave Chappelle's here,
and they went,
what?
And everybody came back in and sat down and went crazy and Dave went up and did
another 40 minutes after the show was over.
But that's what he's doing.
Comedy just shows up.
Places just shows up after a show and does it set to somebody else's office.
Really enjoying it.
Yeah.
That's 100% of the fun.
It's all fun.
He's just doing the fun shit.
Exactly.
When shit is not having a schedule,
the function is doing it when you feel like it,
because there's definitely times you don't feel like it,
but it's time to do it,
but you don't feel like it.
Well,
he's doing some specials.
He got a deal with Netflix.
He's going to do some specials.
Oh,
Netflix is going off to him.
They got him on a special.
Chris stand up special.
Ooh.
Yeah,
that's going to be awesome.
Oh,
it's going to be a main number.
Netflix,
he's to suck.
There was nothing on it.
You remember that?
How you get it for eight bucks and it sucked and you've cancelled that shit.
Everybody cancel that and you're like,
okay.
They cope of documentary.
Like should we keep it for the documentaries?
And then you end up just fucking canceling it.
I never know.
It's awesome.
I never watched it until a few years ago and that was the best shit I was on it.
Who Watches regular TV?
I had a Netflix special in 2005 that,
uh,
Joe Rogan live.
That was Netflix.
Damn,
that's right.
2005 and I wasn't watching Netflix.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
you want to do a special on Netflix?
I'll do it.
I mean,
nobody saw it on Netflix back then.
Nobody had Netflix and they sold it to showtime.
I'm like,
oh,
finally.
It's the Netflix revolution.
Oh,
it is now.
Now it's off the charts,
man.
You know what I've been watching.
I told you untold history of the United States,
that Oliver Stone documentary.
Whoa.
Have you seen it?
No.
You gotta watch it.
It's,
it's the rabbit hole is deep and it's so crazy.
What's it called?
The untold history of the United States.
It's amazing.
It's Oliver Stone.
That's it.
Netflix came from $40 in late fees on Nepal.
13 rental.
That's hilarious.
That's where the idea came from.
Wow.
Yeah.
Netflix is awesome,
man.
And it's changing the game.
I'm so deep into house of cards now.
I'm on the third season of house of cards.
Holy Shit is started.
It watched like seven episodes and I,
I lost it that sometimes you lose it and it's good.
And he'd go back to a,
I'll probably go back to the Ventura.
I forgot the whole thing now.
Yeah,
I hear you.
I was,
uh,
I got to go back to narcos.
I haven't finished season two.
Oh Shit.
I'm on that one.
I'm on that show.
So good.
I just finished Westworld.
Oh,
I love that.
But West roads,
amazing.
Love that show a show.
And he was kind of weird.
Funny as I'm watching,
I'm watching this and I'm thinking,
damn,
I swear to God.
I'm thinking Tate would be perfect for the seeds he pops out.
I must've seen Instagram posts from a long time ago,
but I swear I saw the scene.
I'm like damn,
Tate's.
Got The perfect look for for this show and boom,
there he is.
There he is.
That's hilarious.
Sam Cecillia
[inaudible]
Tate
is probably one of the most successful character actors in the business right
now.
Yeah,
he's in everything.
I remember when I first started seeing him a movies,
I like check,
take it out,
but now it's like ridiculous.
My God damn Tate again because it change.
Look at this.
He's going for a leg lock here.
Oh neat.
That's another thing that's going to be interesting about GSP.
GSP has spent a lot of time with John down her.
He's in,
he's in New York a lot.
It'd be real interesting to see if he incorporates a leg lock game and it's also
going to be real interesting to see with all the,
you know,
if anybody's going to be greased and when they fight George and what kind of an
effect that's going to have that.
You're not seeing that at all.
And grappling,
Aria,
Eddie greasing and having an effect on leg lock games or anything like that.
Um,
who knows,
maybe who knows.
People are complain about it or I'll know in Ebi there's a rash guard rule.
I don't have a title.
You could wear anything you want,
shorts,
whatever.
But I think ultimately everyone's going to have to wear tights and rash guards
no matter what.
Just so that there is no,
what's the rule now?
Like what can you wear now?
You wear shorts,
you can wear shorts anyway,
anything you want,
shorts.
But you know,
just to eliminate any possibility of gracing.
Now there's a lot of dangerous leg lockers out there and there's a lot of people
that are really concerned about them.
And you know,
I'm not saying this guy grease their legs or that guy.
Uh,
I'm just saying it's,
it's really easy to do.
We're not checking,
you know,
so instead of coming up with this crazy ass tasks,
let's just make it more spazz.
Most people to have no problem,
learn spats were spats and then board shorts over it.
No big deal.
People do that all the time.
I just found it interesting that in Nogi those Donaher,
her guys weren't wearing them.
I was like,
that's really interesting cause they're all leg lock guys like Eddie Cummings,
Gary,
Tony Choice
you have to make,
you know,
um,
if you're going leg locks,
a lot of people don't.
They like the greasy leg war because it increases their defense,
their ability to pull out a leg locks.
If they're going to go into a leg lock paddles,
man,
they'd locked battles.
One little zig when you should have zagged and you know,
you think you're on his heel and he's got you.
There's,
it's so mother crazy.
The modern day leg lock game.
It's endless on its own with so endless,
everyone's got different styles and different paths.
It's insane.
How elaborate it.
Do you see a that g match between uh,
Gary Tona in Aaj?
No,
I didn't see that carry tone and got him in this horrific leg lock and age.
I didn't
it,
you see it?
Yeah.
Is his legs.
He got him in like a knee bar sideways and he had his leg bent sideways.
It looked,
it looked awful.
See if he could find that general.
He didn't tab,
he didn't tap.
But John Danner,
I made a whole point about how we should have tapped,
you know,
and he went on about how Gary tone and tapped with that flying triangle to a
shoe face.
You know when the Carl's Jr on Sug?
Yeah,
three.
Yeah.
And then they,
you know,
he dumped on her,
made this big Instagram post about how the importance of tapping and you know,
you see Aja not tamping while this horrific leg lock has put on them.
And then Gary Tone and made a post on Instagram about how we severely injured
him.
You know,
even though he won the bout and didn't get the tap,
he severely injured him.
But just tap people.
Yeah.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
Don't let your shake get ripped apart.
It's up to them.
I know,
but I mean doesn't that bother you like your,
your match with a boiler when you're ripping his knee apart?
It didn't bother me.
Did you hear it cracking and habit repin who were talking about it?
Oh,
what did he say?
I told him.
Did you hear that?
You pull out his knee and it's,
it's going crack crack.
And he goes,
I'm fine.
Yeah,
And then another one,
pop pop,
but what about that?
And he goes,
I'm fine,
I'm fine.
I'm like,
okay,
let's go.
Hell yeah man.
He didn't give a fuck
man.
Apparently he never taps the leg locks,
you know?
So everybody that knows him,
they knew he wouldn't tap.
What do you think the inside of his leg looks like now though?
Sometimes your leg can pop and it's just like your knuckle cracking,
you know,
because he was,
I think he was walking,
um,
after the match,
you know,
he didn't seem to limp anywhere and I think he was surfing a couple of days
later.
Uh,
so maybe it was just like,
it was just popping like a knuckle crack,
like,
or maybe he's just got chewed up meniscus in there.
Anyone.
It's cracker hunching around.
Maybe there's a lot of people like that.
They just get used to it.
Like Bas Rutten is bone on bone on his knees.
He just walks around.
Hey,
how are you?
I mean,
his knees are fucked.
He told me it's all bone on bone.
He's got no cartilage.
It's,
it's gotta be so much fun.
Waking up every morning.
He can't train,
can do anything.
I mean boss Rutan,
former UFC heavyweight champion of the world still looks like a stud.
Yeah.
Can't train.
I can't do anything.
He's got one arm is one arm is all fucked up because of his impingements in his
neck caused severe atrophy on his right arm.
His right arm shrunk literally to half the size of his left arm.
And uh,
he can't even lift weights with it.
I mean he's up to like 10 pounds a curls.
It's really kind of crazy.
You tell me.
Can't hold up a jug of milk,
like a jug of milk like that.
His arm would just fall.
Does the Interesting Fina Tyron Woodley Wonderboy too?
Well,
I think the,
uh,
I think we're going to see probably the same thing we did in the first one,
just to kind of a stalemate.
I don't know about that man.
I feel like if Woodley decides to take him down like he did in the first round,
it changes the whole fight.
But it,
but is he actually going to do that?
Well,
he just decided not to in the second fight or in the,
in the second round,
he just decided not to for whatever reason,
but it wasn't like it wasn't available to them as it was really weird.
And I asked him about it.
He'd say,
Ah,
I've no idea why I didn't take them down
Kevin Tucker.
It just seems to me that this guy,
you know what,
what happened in that fight?
But when,
when Woodley took them down the first round,
he dominated them on the ground.
Just beat him up and it didn't look like wonder boy had an answer.
It looked like he was going to get smashed.
Yeah.
And then the fight change from the second round on it became a kickboxing fight
and Woodley's still hurt him,
hurt him bad.
And the fourth.
But one thing that he took away,
it took away a big part of the kicking game of Wonderboy cause Wonderboy didn't
want to kick and be ticking down by him,
be smashed on the ground like that again.
So he kept it standing and kept moving back.
And forth for the waste and just sorta like kinda point fighting with his hands,
you know,
that's what it seemed like.
It was more of that way that that's how he's going to win that fight.
Yeah.
That's how everybody's going to,
he has to keep my distance,
you know?
I mean he,
his,
his inside game isn't bad,
but it's the thread of the takedown.
He's,
he's got no chance.
The timing of the inside.
I know.
And the power exchange too.
I mean you'd think,
oh how,
how much power,
you know,
tyrants got,
yeah.
Wonderboy could knock you out.
He can knock you out with Tyron,
could knock you out with one shot.
Yeah.
And Wonderboy most of the time it's a bunch of shots.
I mean he can knock you out clean if he catches you.
Especially with kicks.
It's just an interesting fight to see who makes the right adjustment.
Exactly.
That's yeah,
cause then they're going to go,
I mean maybe do decision,
I would think just cause just kind of the,
how the style matchup is there two guys that seem like they'll end up there but
I don't see a problem with that and I think we're going to see a lot like who's
ever game camp,
game plan can really work this time.
You know,
just one of the massive do it.
Yeah.
What a crazy fucking sport.
It's just,
there's so many variables,
there's so many different ways to win and it's what makes it so exciting.
But it also makes it so difficult to call.
I'll give you watching certain fights like a boxing match.
We're watching certain boxing matches and you,
you know how one guy fights?
No,
under the guy fights so you can kind of figure out what's going to happen and
you'd be with reasonable certainty.
But with MMA half the time you don't know what the fuck's going to happen.
Like half the time the best strategy for Woodley be just to continue taking them
down.
Like relentless.
That right.
I would say shot.
Okay.
I don't know.
I would say,
well he can knock you out too.
That's thing about Woodley is he can do both.
Wonderboy can't do both.
Wonder boy can't take Tyron Woodley down.
He's just not going to,
I mean he could,
he could wind up on top if you know,
like in the first fight with we went for the guillotine was choking the shit out
of them and somehow or another Wonderboy you got through it and it wound up that
w Wonderboy was on top.
That's possible.
Yeah.
But like shooting for a power double and taken down Tyron Woodley like not gonna
happen.
Maybe.
I mean maybe it can happen but it doesn't seem likely.
What's really likely though is Woodley can take him down and what's also really
likely is Willie can knock him out but wonderful.
I can knock them out too.
I mean,
wonderful.
What can knock people out?
He just,
it just,
he doesn't have the same amount of horsepower that Woodley does.
Enact accuracy.
It's Pitts place.
Perfectly perfect time and hit you with a couple of them.
His striking is so dynamic.
He can do so many different things,
especially off the front leg.
But Woodley's got that one punch smash power.
Like there's that,
that video of the fourth round or would the connects with a left hook to the
Chin and you see wonder boy's eyes robot back in his head and he managed to
survive.
That's one thing we learned about Woodley from that far.
Wonderboy from that fight,
that fucking dude's got heart man.
He can take it.
The fact that he didn't tap in that gay teen like Woo.
That was horrific.
Yeah,
he,
he was in it.
He was in a couple of real bad positions in that fight.
And you saw how tough he really is.
He's tough.
No doubt about that.
It's just going to be a matter of whether or not he can avoid the takedown and
whether or not he can be effective standing up and avoid the bombs.
Yeah.
But I was impressed with Woodley's ability to fight five rounds too,
cause that was always the knock on him that he's so big,
he's so muscular that he's not going to have the endurance.
But he heard him in the fourth you know,
can,
interesting.
What's so funny?
He laughed.
We laughed.
The whole muscular.
I'm cardio thing.
It's funny.
Why is it funny?
I Dunno.
You're not even high.
He doesn't like it when you say that.
Oh,
he gets mad.
But,
but it's a fact.
Sorry.
What does this movie,
this is a,
I dunno,
collide fast and the furious 97
at some point in time they're gonna have to stop Stephanie Hopkins in it,
so it could be fucking real shitty Westworld's on that's on vacation.
Just got to make some money,
man.
God,
that shows good.
It's on vacation,
on hiatus.
There's almost too many shows nowadays.
There is by far.
I hear about new shit all the time and I'm like,
I can't do it.
Yeah,
At the time,
people are always telling me,
dude,
you gotta check out the show.
I'm like,
fuck you.
I like sleep.
Well,
it's,
it's fun to get distracted,
but at the end of the day,
that's what it is.
You can only have so many distractions.
Here we go.
Hector Lombard speaking to various muscles.
Johny Hendricks.
Oh,
he's the freakiest of the freak.
Him and Yoel Romero,
same Olympic team here.
See where he works out when Lombard works out,
everything is short.
Like his,
uh,
his chin ups.
He does Chin ups like this.
Everything is like,
it's not,
there's no long,
big motions.
Tricep extensions,
very short.
Everything is like,
not like full range of motion stuff.
Everything's like short distances.
Huh?
That's interesting.
I wonder why.
I Dunno.
You know,
just his,
his style of strength and conditioning and working out
one 85,
man.
He's such a fucking Corolla.
What did,
well,
where's the training now?
He's att.
See,
look at that.
See how he's lifting.
Look,
everything is like,
he doesn't eat now.
He doesn't have like full range of motion with a lot of his uh,
exercises,
former world champion and one of them,
he's a freak when he knocked out Nate Marquardt.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
It's amazing.
That mountain.
There it is right there.
It's amazing that Mark Ward is still in there swinging.
Oh,
Paul Harris.
He beat the shit out of Paul Harris.
That was at one 72.
Right?
He's a fucking scary man.
It's just so strange.
This sport you get to see inside of a few year period,
the guys rise and then complete falling apart.
Yeah.
You just get to see
them at the peak looking their best and then you get to see them just really
when you just hoping and praying that they stopped doing it and it all happens
inside of two years.
It's like the music business.
It's worse though because they're getting beaten up.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're
getting abused.
That is like the music business in a way though,
right?
Like think of a big music act from like three years ago that you can see at the
Candy Club tomorrow night.
Out of all the bands get signed,
95% of them get dropped within by the third album.
They don't make it.
Most bands don't make it.
Only the very,
very few Megan,
it's just like,
it's just like MMA.
Someone was telling me about chance the rapper is that the dude's name that
doesn't have,
he's not signed to anybody is selling out gigantic arenas.
Technically,
yes.
Technically.
What does that mean?
And he's got,
he's said he's technically quote unquote at independent rapper.
Right.
So he's not technically on a record label,
but he's got great friends all over the,
all over the map.
Has agent is the biggest agent in the music industry or was Kara Lewis one of
the biggest,
so it's,
he's got all the help that everyone would need.
You don't need the backing of a record label,
which was like lawyers and promotions and all that.
You can do it all himself.
So the lawyer,
I mean the,
the,
the record label thing is kind of useless nowadays,
right?
Yeah.
It,
it doesn't
help you anymore.
Yeah.
Just so amazing change in the world with digital.
Amazing.
What happened with the,
I mean it started out Lars or which all rich that I say his name,
he saw the writing on the wall with a,
that Napster shit.
He saw what was happening and he called it first and then now you're seeing like
the business is almost a completely different business than it was 20 years ago.
It's all based on live a live performing.
There's no money in it.
I mean,
what does a person make from record sales is nothing.
It's point.
You stars still make it.
They'll still make money off of albums like this.
Kanye West just don't fuck how much you think you makes.
They're filthy rich.
Of course.
Of course it's filthy rich.
But is he making money?
You're filthy rich.
So that's how I'm saying.
Is he making money from record sales?
Obviously it's filthy rich because he's selling out arenas,
but is he making money from record sales still?
That's a good question.
Does that make sense?
God,
this is a boring conversation.
I saw an article just the other day was trying to find it right now to pull it
up,
but up it's just now saying how a lot of pop music or uh,
people are charging a lot more for their tickets now to 300 bucks on a lot of
their money back.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
I'm sure that's,
I mean you got to do something.
Yeah.
How else you going to pay for your fucking mansions?
Bentley's all they do is to,
are now.
Yeah,
I'm sure man.
Of course you have to.
Everyone's getting back together now.
Shit.
See what happened with guns and roses.
Holy Goddamn Shit.
I ended up in Mexico City,
uh,
doing ebi the same time guns and roses in Mexico City.
We went to go see him and man,
I was completely blown away.
They have so many hats.
I mean,
slashes up there looking like a god.
I was never the biggest guns and roses fan when they came out.
I was all into slayer and I was under darkness.
Aerosmith,
signs,
first farewell tour dates.
Oh Shit.
I go on for awhile.
It was hearing,
Oh shit.
They're all getting back together again.
I make money,
man.
Even I hear smashing pumpkins might be getting back to the original [inaudible].
Gotta go see that.
Jamesy Hahn,
Darcy
smashing pumpkins never really broke up and it's always been Billy Corrigan with
a different band.
Yeah.
So it's going to be him again.
So it's going to be the whole band again.
The original band,
that blue Corgan was going crazy.
I don't know my reading propaganda.
He's not,
I don't know.
I haven't heard that anyone can.
Conspiracy theorists now,
original smashing pumpkins lineup.
They're all fucking nuts.
Guy From Blink one eight two is that you're talking about,
oh,
that's what I'm talking about,
right?
He's down with aliens,
He thinks that feelings are,
what did he write?
Which one is,
this is Tom Delong.
He wrote a book.
What are you?
Right.
He thinks that they're visiting us.
It's got the doc daily basis.
Oh,
how about that fucking basketball player?
He was a
basketball player,
but things to world is flat.
Dinosaurs aren't real.
The unfortunate thing too is he went to Duke.
He went to Duke Boyfriend.
Damn.
Johny Hendricks barely made one 85 105.5 Lombard one 82 interesting.
I wonder if he's thinking about going down to one 78 lumbar.
It looks way more fresh.
Oh yeah.
Look in the bachelor.
Shit.
I'm just going to touch gloves.
Here they go.
Here we go.
Wow.
Joe Martinez instead of a w.
I wonder what's going on.
Buffers almost always at these events.
I wonder why buffers not there
just doesn't seem the same.
I like Martinez,
don't get me wrong,
but unless you hear
and you see him beat red screaming,
nobody gets to be public buffer,
some shiny ass suit.
He gets crazy.
They get to like hand tailored suits made for specific events.
Like he had one made for the UFC in New York.
Like it,
what was it two,
was it two?
Was it two o to o?
Yeah,
UFC 202 and it has the date and side of it all embroidered and shit.
I played,
uh,
announcer like Bruce buffer slash,
Dj and an underground fight.
Uh,
it was,
it was never back down to straight to DVD.
Um,
but I played the ring announcer,
so I'm talking as the fights are going on,
I'm kind of a ring announcer slash commentator.
Slash Dj and man,
it was,
I was horrible.
I was so bad in it,
but I did just try to do what Bruce buffer would do.
You know,
I was like Bruce Buffer,
say this name and I was just basically doing terrible Bruce buffer
impersonations and it's so cringe.
Here we go.
Oh boy.
Hector Lombard,
Johnny Hendricks,
four 50 54544503452 of the first round if you want to sync it up.
This is huge,
man.
Acts are just so fucking explosive.
When you watched him,
it's like you're watching it gone about to go off.
It's like a championship fight and the distance that he that he can,
he can close his insane.
Well the question is like how motivated as Johnny,
like how much did he prepare?
Is He,
is he back to training?
Like real hard all the time and how much better does he feel at one of the five?
I mean maybe he's just back to old Johnny Hendricks again.
I mean he doesn't look good physically.
Physically doesn't look,
it looks fat and unshaven glad you said that.
Good inside leg kick.
I didn't say that and I don't mean to be an asshole.
I just want to point out not the body chamber amongst us.
Yes.
I think if he shaved the hair off his GSI,
you wouldn't be saying,
oh,
big knee by Hendricks.
He clipped him with that knee.
That was a good knee.
Damn.
Johny Hendricks still in the mix here.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
You gotta remember Johnny Hendricks is a fucking hell of a wrestler and he hits
real hard.
Well he was at one 70 knocking people dead for a while.
But you haven't seen any evidence of that lately,
which is really interesting.
Who moved away from that left hand though?
He looked good there.
Look good there.
And moving away from that left hand.
But what Lombard?
It's like one fuck up.
Just one fuck up.
And you go night night
and he's so hard to take down.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
[inaudible] world champion right now.
He's Judah World Champ.
I believe he was a silver medalist in the Olympics.
No,
that's um,
Yoel Romero.
What did,
uh,
did Lombard compete in the Olympics?
I think he did.
I do not think he medaled in the Olympics.
I think maybe either way be connected.
Oh,
Jesus.
Lombard is connected.
A big right hand over the top.
I'm pretty sure.
I know Yoel Romero was a silver medal at the Olympics.
There's a,
there's a bunch of people that believe that you'll over married through the
Olympics for money
lent to the huge crazy conspiracy theories.
Yeah.
It's not mine.
CNN.
I could be,
it could be the library.
I have to hear all these funny,
funny,
funny stories about is my,
my wrestling coach.
There are Christians was on the,
on the Olympic team in the World Team with Joe Warren and all those people.
So I just,
the like the funny shit I hear about wrestling,
it's just for other animals,
the animals,
animals,
animals and savages,
they are savages.
They're the cornerstone of MMA.
It's,
that's one of the reasons why it's like y'all Romero is so interesting is
because if you talk to real wrestlers about Yoel Romero and he'll tell you he's
just a freak.
It's just such an incredible athlete and we're getting him while he's still,
I mean he might be 39 years old,
but he's still able to put on shows and move like a freak freak athlete.
Oh,
Johnny with the left hand over the top there.
I mean that fight with Chris Weidman,
Holy Shit.
That flying knee.
I mean,
dude,
he does it like nobody.
Like who,
who else?
Who else fights like Kim,
who else explodes like that?
Take off half your head.
He's so scary.
He's so scary and just abuse.
So stretched stronger than Johnny Hendricks.
Right back up.
Good defense by Hendricks.
Avoiding that left hand hits him with an elbow.
This could be interesting if Lombard did not expect Hendricks to last and this
fight goes into the second and third and and Lombard starts to slow down a bit
and you also got to think Lombard is coming off of a devastating knockout loss.
You got to remember that.
Who Do you,
who do you fight last?
Dan Henderson.
Oh,
remember he got hit with that back elbow.
He got an elbow guy.
He got fucking hammered when he was on the ground too.
Dude,
that was a crazy,
he didn't
move for a while.
But then clenching with them.
Yeah,
it is interesting.
It is interesting.
And this is like Johnny Hendricks is game.
Johny Hendricks is a hell of a wrestler,
was really good at manipulating bodies.
You want to play clinch with him.
If Johnny's healthy.
You remember when he fought George Saint Pierre and George's could not do
anything with him.
It was just picking door,
Jap,
throwing them around.
Well,
when George was trying to hold onto a single and Johnny was like,
yeah,
good luck with that.
Good luck with that leg,
man.
You're taking me down and was like,
I'm going to elite wrestler.
Like his level of wrestling when he was in his prime,
his level wrestling.
This is as good as America has to offer at many points in times like that
beautiful trip attempt by Lombard and Johnny Hendricks makes it through.
Ooh,
interesting.
Here's the other thing.
Hendricks looks kind of fresh here.
He doesn't look like he's tired.
He might've gotten in real good shape for this look.
End of the fifth round.
I mean for me to know because you saw some bad fights from him,
right?
He saw some fights where he self admitted that he only train four days a week.
The last fight,
he didn't look that good either.
It didn't look that good.
Magnified.
Yeah.
It was a real close fight.
That was a real close fight.
Yeah,
that was a,
and he didn't make weight for that fight too,
right,
exactly.
And that's why he's up at one 85 now.
Tell you what though.
You go back to the one,
the um,
the Johnny Hendricks at knocked out John Fitch,
the Johnny Hendricks at mark knocked out Marvin Kampman.
Yeah.
And he was just throwing bombs,
man.
He just,
he like a death touch hit guys.
They would go flying it slide back on their heels.
It was weird.
There was a couple of knockouts that he had,
particularly Fitch and Kamin whereas looked like he,
he had some super power.
Like he had some crazy over handling just video game shit.
Yeah,
snap someone life from him.
But that's one of those things,
it's like I was super excited to see fade or this weekend super excited to see
Faye dark.
Cause I'm always wondering like when does a guy like that?
Like how much does he still have?
Like how much is that the,
how much he takes all this time off he comes back,
it's going to come back.
Just like super pumped up to fight like his fate,
Oregon to come back as this,
you know,
this version of who he used to be or are we going to see the fade or versus
Maldonado that didn't look so good.
He,
he this,
the pictures of him with his shirt off and stuff.
He didn't look all that fit well,
he never looked all that fit but blab,
same,
worse than usual.
Well one thing that I saw when I saw the picture of the way,
and I noticed that as it looked to me like a shoulders are pretty full to
sounds.
Okay.
I should probably stop saying he looked strong to me is what I was getting to.
I you always fatal.
We're always carried a certain amount of body fat.
Never heard him,
you know,
he's never ripped and he was the scariest guy alive for a while.
Do you think he's the greatest heavyweight of all time?
Yeah,
I kind of feel like you almost have to give it to them for that era because it
was as someone that,
I mean literally I've watched the sport my entire life.
Like,
that's,
this is the one thing I've looked to.
He,
yeah,
he,
he was at that time.
But I mean,
since then there hasn't been a heavyweight that struck fear in and the people
like,
like we did maybe,
maybe Cain Velasquez a little bit,
but no one really cared for some reason,
even the changes kept getting injured on fortunately,
but when he was at his best,
he was as horrific,
so scared.
But I just feel like it's disrespectful to Fabrizio over doom.
Like realistically,
if we're looking at,
in terms of accomplishments,
you have to really consider,
like when did Verdomme Ketchum?
I'll go.
We completely disregarding how good fade or was up until the time Verdomme
caught them.
Are we not giving,
doing the credit he deserves because v for receiver doom has tapped out three of
the greatest of all time.
Tapped out Nogueira tapped out fader and tapped out Kane.
So it's hard.
But then he loses the Steve Bay,
he gets knocked out by Steve Bay.
So then you want to like reestablish or reevaluate and now he's fighting a
desanto sign.
Yeah.
Dos Anjos he's going to fight those Angelos.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
and I,
he's,
he's beat all the best people.
So I don't know from presales now finding dos Anjos steep pay is finding
Dosantos dos Santos Santos Dosantos.
Yes.
No junior tuning.
Dosantos yes.
Sorry.
He's fighting.
Steepbank okay.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That's going to be another good fight.
Remember that first fight?
The first fight was super close,
but it was a crazy war.
Who the hell out of each other?
Oh,
it was awful.
Ooh.
See Johnny Hendricks looks to me way better here at one 85 then he looked at one
70 his last two fights.
Oh,
we just clipped him with the luck or right hand.
Pretty slick for a fat boy too.
And he looks good.
He looks good.
He does.
He looks down his feet.
He's lying to his feet.
He looks fit.
He looks durable.
He just looks healthier.
I mean,
he may be not look ripped,
but the ways performing looks better.
Like he's able to take it.
Look at that.
See,
he's still throwing bombs,
man.
His reaction time looks better.
It looks better.
It looks better at 85 to [inaudible].
Same thing I say about Calvin.
You look at the Calvin that fought Tyron Woodley,
that Calvin,
it didn't make weight and Calvin look tired.
He just doesn't look the same.
Then you'll get the Calvin and fought Tim.
The one fought Tim Kennedy was a fucking world beater man.
Calvin gassed alum at one 85 is a god damn world beater.
He looks amazing.
I mean his,
his grappling defense was incredible.
And then he was light on his feet and his hands were flowing.
His Chin,
his iron.
I mean at one 85 that guy's fucking healthy.
And when he's healthy,
you get to see the real guy.
The real guy is super talented,
but we've been seeing the real guy that smothered by weight cuts,
like real hard weight cuts and they just take too much out of his body.
And I think you're seeing the same goddamn thing here right now.
I mean,
he might still lose this fight.
Hector Lombard still a fucking beast,
right?
But this is to me like the best Hendricks we've seen in a couple of years.
I mean,
and this is like a competitive fight.
Yeah,
he looks good.
Good left hand over the top.
It's actually when his head,
he's he and he's also a,
I think he's banking on the slow down cause the slow down with Lombard,
especially if he thinks he's got you hurt is a real deal.
Like with Neil Magni,
Neil Magni managed to survive a helacious dorm.
Do you remember that?
Yup.
Helacious he survived.
And then Neil,
Maggie eventually one by Tko he got on top of him.
He was beaten him down and Lumbar just didn't have anything left to defend
himself.
So that was the second round wasn't it?
He almost finish him at the end of one of one of the rounds.
Yeah.
And then he ended up finishing him after that.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I think it was the third round that he finished him and it was just a crazy war.
What's going on and breaking them up morning grabbing the fence.
So we're in the second round.
Second round.
What's the time?
Did they have the time backup?
What do got a minute left and Lombard slowing down for sure.
It just seems like some of those guys that have cardio problems,
a lot of it is related to the actual style that they fight into.
Ooh,
Ni and punch
the style of Lombard.
He's like so sprint oriented and when he has to adjust that style and then
become like a technical oriented fighter,
it's just not the same thing.
Like you're always on your heels in that first round and you first round,
you're always getting away from this just super athlete common Achoo this
swinging,
throwing lead.
Right.
But then in the second round you get a regular fighter.
Yeah.
And this is what you're seeing now.
You're seeing Lombard skills,
which are still substantial,
but you're not seeing any evidence of that freak athleticism anymore.
Now he's fallen into a rhythm.
So you like that.
Yeah.
So,
but see I,
he's throwing that kick,
like that's,
that's kicks landing and he's throwing it,
but he's not trying to murder you at that kick,
you know?
Yeah.
Same with death punch.
It changes.
It all changes in that second round,
which is really interesting.
Hendrick's keeps coming in with that knee.
It's getting close to this dude.
Lombard is going back to his corner and he looks very tired and Hendricks looks
pumped up.
Fascinating.
I had thought coming into this fight.
Yeah,
this would be a fight where you know Johnny Hendricks is in a a scary match with
one of the most fearsome Kao Artists in the sport.
I mean,
you look at,
especially his Bella tour highlight reels,
so get that knee.
That was a beautiful knee by Hendrix.
You look at his Bella tour highlight reel back when he was marking people over
there like,
oh my God,
everyone was afraid of him.
Oh my goodness.
He was huge.
And he came over here,
struggled a little bit at first.
Lost Tim Boetsch.
Remember that fight in a boring,
boring,
boring.
It wasn't a good fight for him.
Just didn't open up.
But the Henderson one,
the last one was the scariest lost cause he got rocked by Henderson the first
and Henderson rocked him,
took him down and held him down,
was beaten them up on the ground and then they had that crazy exchange or
Henderson caught him with an elbow to the head and dropped him off a single aid.
Yeah,
Dude.
And you remember what he,
his Instagram post hit American flag wrapped around him.
He said,
I smoked that Cuban.
That's so rude.
But it's acceptable because it's Dan had Dan Henderson,
he can get away.
Oh.
He clipped him with that right over the hopper.
Look at this.
Hendrix takes it look.
Looks good.
Still light on his feet.
Still moving and not Lombard.
Lombard.
Totally flat footed.
And the more Hendricks does this to them and feints him and gets him to react
and move,
the more it keeps Lombard from recovering.
So it's around a piece,
right?
Boy,
I dunno.
I'm not a good score.
Two rounds.
The first one I'd say around a piece.
Yeah.
Johnny Johnny's looking better right now than he did last time.
Could you give the last round to Lombard?
Is it possible not that you were given the last round of Hendrix?
No,
I'm asking.
Could you,
is it possible?
I don't think so.
So the last one,
you feel pretty clearly went to Hendricks?
Yeah.
The first round you said went to Lombard?
Yeah,
not by much.
I've been mostly talking shit.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Lombard throws what you would call short kicks cause it's shortly.
Yeah.
But some guys that have short legs can extend.
He throws the same way.
We were talking about how he,
like when he does his weightlifting,
he has like short extensions just like,
yeah.
Do you think he does that?
So we can be powerful and like little short punches in short bursts.
I have no idea.
I wonder if there's like a theory to that,
you know,
the ultimate fighter,
how they have two rounds into the,
if it's too high.
Oh,
nice.
Lumbar Turret.
Yeah.
What do you guys feel about that?
Which one?
A tie after a third.
It's interesting.
Just like the ultimate fighter.
Yeah.
Saw bad idea.
Would it push the fighters more?
Uh,
um,
I would imagine that it would a little bit.
Yeah,
for sure.
Right.
Give me more time.
And he would also like maybe reserve a little in the tank and be Johnny keeps
hitting him with that left knee man.
Yeah,
he's hurting with that left knee.
He sees an opening every time lumbar,
lumbar,
it's closing in and now Lombard is very flat footed.
You really need to win that first round,
you know?
Yeah.
At first round becomes very important.
When it's too round fight,
you know,
they always used to do that in k one and in glory they do it to like in that
fucking crazy one
night we're Joe Schilling the same way.
That pattern,
how do I get one night Joe Schilling at three fights in one night and glory last
man standing.
It was fucking crazy.
It was so much fun to watch.
It was so crazy in front row,
like Ah,
and he got dropped in like the first or second round of his first fight and then
he comes back and knock Simon Marcus out cold in the fourth after they had gone
to war for three rounds and made them fight another round.
It was crazy.
I mean that was,
and then he fought again and then he fought again on the same night.
I mean how the fuck is that legal
hell sanction that it was fucking,
cause he,
he had how many rounds of that and yeah,
like you said,
he got dropped in like the very first round or something like that.
He was,
if he was in,
yeah,
I think he fought 10 rounds.
So you know,
he fought 10 rounds in a night.
Was kickboxing heavy,
heavy shit right there.
I mean he,
the,
they were all three round fights,
right?
Or anything.
Item 11 where they thrive.
They weren't too round pilots.
They didn't make them two round fights in the semis.
They were three.
There were three rounds and he fought one,
four.
So one four because they went three with Simon Marcus.
You had the final with Artem,
but then you,
he fought like,
who did you fight in between Gan,
that knee that Hendrix caught him with that.
Look at that his head and let another one.
Oh,
he got tripped.
You got tripped.
Let's see how quick he can get up.
Oh,
he's just getting up.
He just got right the fuck up.
Wow.
He just got up.
He gave up his back.
Everything he knew.
Lombard was tired.
It slipped right off.
Slipped right off.
There's your argument,
Eddie right there.
It totally makes sense.
You want to promote offense on the ground?
In my opinion.
That's a cheap,
that would be the smart business.
Move Lombard's till closing in.
Okay.
Johnny's finally tired.
Oh,
they're both tired right now,
but lumbar,
it seems like he's a little fresher.
All of a sudden.
I think he smells blood.
Ooh.
That front kick to the body and again.
Oh,
Ooh.
That kick to the body.
Interesting.
Lombard looks much better now.
Ooh.
Oh,
nice leg kick by Johnny.
Yeah.
10 seconds.
What happens now?
Oh yeah.
He hurt his hand.
Wow.
He broke his hand.
He might've broke his hand with that one punchy through or just sprained his
wrist.
He's had carpal tunnel.
You ever done?
It is possible.
Good point.
Yeah.
That's going to sway the judges decision.
I don't know.
You know?
I mean what did he really do mean?
He hit him with a couple of good body kicks,
but then the hand,
I'm talking about the hand getting broken.
Who knows?
I mean there's nothing you can do about that.
No,
I know,
but still like in around he has,
he broke his rest.
He got hurt at the end.
I don't know.
He's kind of like,
no,
I don't think that would mess with you.
No,
no.
It's not going to have anything to do with the judging the end of that fight the
way it looks.
No.
Okay.
I think if we were really going to judge it,
oh you mean him running around at the very end?
We would have to push it,
push it,
push it one way or the other.
You know that ending ending with the wrist.
What do you do?
You really remember the first round,
clearly.
I remember moments in a second.
I think you're taking down once that method that you,
you were doing when you were doing it for the UFC where you were the unofficial
Harold Letterman for the UFC.
That was great.
That was fun.
And you had a really good point to it and you,
it helped me because you would like quantify it.
I'd be like,
why did you give it to that guy?
And you're like,
well he got the two takedowns but he hurt him with the leg kicks and hit him
with a punch.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
I see.
Like I just felt like that matter more.
Got to take notes.
You've got a whole system.
If you're going on air to give your
analysis of the fight,
you gotta know your Shit.
So it was really good.
You should do that again man.
If they had like,
you know when the HBO boxing going to be,
Oh,
you know Eddie Bravo is breakdown and blah blah blah and have all your little
number at,
you'll have a fucking little chart,
but the way you wrote it down,
was he the way he did it was really good.
The hologram,
a good system.
I feel like Johnny Hendricks might have this barely paid attention.
That's fine.
I'm just over here.
My unofficial take on the official take big rig I where I see,
I told you,
I know motherfuckers doubt me.
I have no idea how it's going.
I don't have any idea,
but I felt like Hendrix look better in this fight.
Then he has an a long time and even really know after the fight he looks way
fresher.
Fuck weight cutting man.
Is One 35 a possibility for you if,
fuck yeah dude.
I mean for real,
maybe that's the solution because you imagine someone's going to Photoshop your
face on a guy like
hurting from weight,
cutting the fuck wait,
cutting Photoshop,
Steve,
get on it.
That's the thing.
It's not hard for me to make one 25 right.
But I know he shuts down.
You can actually do it,
but it's obviously vastly healthier to not do it.
Yes.
Because when you don't do it,
you don't have these issues.
Right.
You don't ever get like up to a point where you can't swallow food or any of
that.
This is all I used to.
But then after I got sick in Ireland,
that went away.
But I still gotta I gotta get that in a minute.
Getting sick in Ireland cured it.
No,
I don't know.
He went away.
It just stopped.
It just stopped happening.
As bad as it was,
because for whatever reason I'd have that seizing up my esophagus and I would
either pass out and throw up or I would just feel like I'm going to pass out and
then my throwing up would last like an hour to
a couple of days.
Oh God.
Damn,
dude,
that's horrible.
They had no idea.
So we,
oh,
whatever.
I'm fucking under the good shape.
I need to fight,
so let's do it.
So I don't know.
I bet she's fucking a long time.
It's just,
you know,
I need to just feel better eventually cause this isn't working out.
It's fucking killing me.
How many times have you competed at band point?
Oh,
a bunch.
A bunch.
What do you,
how do you feel different in flyweight bantamweight?
Um,
no means are just bigger than me.
I don't have the big of a frame,
but whatever.
I just want to fight.
But how did you feel like physically while you're competing?
Oh,
did you feel different?
No,
I felt fine.
So at one 25 you were feeling fine as well,
like when you've made weight and been able to find them been healthy?
Yeah.
Do you think it's potentially that as you get older you've just done it too many
times?
Just cut way too many times.
You're body's starting to reject it.
That could be it too.
Yeah.
I've been doing this my fucking whole life.
You know,
and I've,
I've finally got it figured out where it's easy,
where I spent the last half of my life doing it in a really negative,
harmful way to my body.
And you know what,
I think it also is to,
I think you're probably tougher and you get,
as you get older and you get like more accepting of pain,
you know,
you find that a lot.
And like older fighters in particular,
there are a lot of them are like,
like Randy coture like late in his age,
he was just so tough because he had experienced so much shit had been through so
much shit he had been through and his mind was so fucking strong.
You know,
like Randy coture dude,
I remember when he beat Tim Silvia and nobody gave him a God damn chance.
Nobody gave him a chance.
He was fighting the heavyweight champ who was a giant.
I mean,
Tim Sylvia is a huge man and Randy [inaudible] seven,
six,
eight,
some shit like that.
And he's,
he's almost,
yeah,
he's gotta be in that range.
I said giant.
Tim was huge.
And Randy hops in with an inside leg kick fake to an overhand bomb and just
drops the hammer on Tim Silvia knocks them down.
Remember that?
Oh yeah.
Which Eddie,
I was talking about older fighters that are just tough guys like hen,
like Dan Henderson is some older dudes that are just so fucking tough that I'm
wondering if like,
maybe your weight cut is easier just because your mind is different now.
You know that you're just,
you're just more accustomed to all the pain from the surgeries and all the
different things you've gone through that you just can eat it better.
There's Woodley again,
Jesus Christ,
that,
that could be a definite thing.
I've been through a lot of painful things.
That's my cup.
My old coach said,
Collin Oyama,
uh,
he,
he was just like,
you just have a different threshold.
And he's like,
you've died,
Moan about other guys.
My have other teammates.
He got shot like five times and he's like,
you should guys have just different pressure on both of you guys have died
before.
Cause he gets just,
I don't know what it's,
what it is.
They come across to lever,
you've got some super spiritual power sun.
And I was like,
Oh,
you know what else has that shit a court?
Mcgowan says that Shit,
Matt Brown,
[inaudible] Court,
Mcgee rather court Mckinnon's a comic.
He doesn't have that at all.
He's a nice guy.
I just,
Shane Miguel a senior.
No,
it was a good guy.
I
can't even imagine him being in a fight,
but court McGee has got that unbreakable spirit.
I mean,
for whatever is his body holds up as much as his body's can hold up.
His mind's gonna just push his body to its limits.
Yeah.
Like when you seeing him in fights,
like a lot of his fights,
particularly our earlier in his career,
he's had some tough fights lately,
but he's,
he overwhelms guys with cardio and would drive.
He runs with weight vests on in the altitude and Utah,
you know he's at a pit elevated.
Yeah.
That's where I knew him from,
from the pit,
but he's one of those guys,
he'd same thing,
had a drug overdose,
died.
They brought him back.
Those guys that have been to the other side,
they're just more,
they're just,
I don't know.
There's something scary about them.
It doesn't mean you can't beat him.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
every,
every one of those guys has lost.
But I mean,
Matt Brown at his best,
marching towards you,
trying to kill you is one of the scariest human beings.
Really frightened it's ever,
ever lived.
I mean,
until you take him out,
you're in,
you're in a hellacious battle with a demon.
You know,
Matt Brown is just coming at you elbows,
knees,
kicks,
punches.
He smells any blood.
He's moving in on face angry
Matt,
which acts like he's died a couple times.
He probably has.
I mean,
there's nobody on the planet like Mad Horowich.
Yeah,
he's gonna let you guys super,
super interesting guy.
Yeah,
there's a lot of wild.
Uh,
you'd think maybe it's time to
not fight anymore.
Is that a weird thing to say?
Well,
yeah,
and you can't even make a fist.
I think.
Uh,
what else am I going to do?
My brain still works.
Um,
fuck it while I let me.
I should save it while it works.
Um,
how old are you?
32.
Okay.
So it's,
it's,
I'm not looking to fight for much longer.
Okay.
Know I made all that other stuff though,
that esophagus one day and then gallbladder the next day.
Yeah,
we don't,
we don't know what it maybe,
maybe,
maybe it's better to be broken alive.
You know what I mean?
I don't even know.
Right.
It's done through close your fist dude.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You have a gym,
right?
No,
you don't need to get a goddamn jam.
Everybody.
Anybody in the fight game,
unless you have some kind of job that,
uh,
is a secure and there's,
I mean,
shit,
why not open a gym?
I teach me about a fight.
That's what you do.
You're a professional fighter and make people want to learn how to find teaching
people much.
Well,
I think,
well,
it's better than fighting when you have esophagus problems.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But what do you do?
Talking logic over there?
I mean,
you got to one fight.
It's Esophagus.
The next fights gallbladder.
It can't even make a fist.
You should open up a gym,
man.
Do you got to do it eventually?
I can still beat motherfuckers up.
But do you want to open up a gym?
No.
Then you should know,
but it was not talking about staying alive.
I'm talking about staying alive though.
He's trying to talk me into things.
I don't want to do that.
I'm talking about staying alive,
man.
Don't do a gym.
Then I start to,
I have a rash guard and I've got the podcasts and stuff and we're going to up
much and other stuff.
Okay.
I've got,
I've got many irons,
a million different ways to make a living in this world.
I think the most important thing for everyone is to try it.
At least tried to make a live and doing that thing that you really enjoyed
doing.
You love teaching Jujitsu.
You've always loved teaching Jiu Jitsu for you.
It's a totally natural thing,
but there are some people that just don't like training other people,
man.
They just don't enjoy it.
I don't,
you know,
I guess it's,
it takes every kind of people you know,
but it's okay if you really want to make it as a podcast or you could do it.
You could do that too.
Man.
You're funny.
Eric's funny.
You guys are interesting together.
It's a good idea.
I've got two,
I've got two shows,
so hopefully they'll work out what I'm going to work out.
At least.
I feel like the thing with those things is just trying your best and being
consistent and trying to improve and you're going to have stumbles and you'll be
better in other shows.
Then you were in certain shows,
but just keep doing it and you,
you know a fuck load about fighting dude,
and I feel like the big brown breakdown that [inaudible] does is one of his most
important podcast and he's getting millions of downloads now for that.
It's big cab because he's inexperienced former UFC fighters.
A smart dude,
he understands fighting.
He's,
he's controversial,
is not afraid to call things like he sees them.
He's not attached to anybody.
No one could tell him what the fuck to say.
And because of that,
his podcast is getting millions of downloads,
you know?
Also another option is if you don't like teaching,
you could be the owner.
You don't have to do any of the teeth.
Don't listen to this dude.
It's the same thing with the MMA business.
He's trying to draw us all in together for some pyramid scheme.
Say,
Hey ted,
planet 10 played in San Clemente,
Joe Rogan fighting championships.
Yeah,
just send me a black dog to run.
Call it,
call it out on the beach.
Uncle creepy.
Emma May have a big kid's program.
Yeah,
there we go.
Exactly.
He's with Ray Sefo here.
Interesting.
Travis Browne walking into the cage with Ray Sefo,
the legendary fuck.
Yeah,
that's right.
And um,
so that they're not in Vegas and brick you on Dell.
Who's awesome.
Yeah,
I love that it was there a nicer guy on the planet?
Honestly,
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean it might be,
it might be the nicest guys ever lived the old line down,
the interactions I had with him,
he's the nicest phonies and
right up there they could be roommates,
you know,
like what are these guys smoking best friends,
man.
Yeah.
He's a super nice guy,
man.
No,
Marcel is one of the Nice Skype they would live to between Marcello and Kelvin
Gastelum.
He's a nice guy too.
Oh,
there's
a lot of Nice guys like a teddy bear.
I still believe in Travis Brown,
man.
I really do.
If Travis Brown could get back to that footwork and movement that he had with
Stephan's.
True.
Yes.
You know the,
the,
the will to come back that he had with Alster.
I still think that Travis Browne physically looked at tools that he possesses.
If he could put it all together and be like super motivated and then have his
mind strong and just believe in himself.
He still got some of the best school best tools in the heavyweight division now
as his athleticism,
his song so long in his movement.
Remember when he used to move almost like a giant Dominick Cruz,
he would see him popping around and move and as a big heavyweight,
like this is a super unusual,
I see a guy that big that can move that well,
but I mean,
who knows?
Maybe he's had some knee knee issues or something.
You know,
you really don't know.
I mean,
he did have that hamstring blowout.
Remember when he fought big foot on his legs just gave out,
right?
Yeah.
His hamstring just blew out in the middle of the round and he went down.
I don't remember what it,
what it was that he tore.
So leave it was a hamstring.
And I wonder if his leg got fucked up in that going.
Is this a conspiracy theory?
Eti my making it more conspiracy theory about Travis Browne's lack of movement.
Did his leg explode?
That's fake news.
I know it definitely gave out on him and the big foot fight,
but I wonder if that was a,
an injury that continue to be significant.
Did someone put a banana peel or was it a rollerskate?
How many times have you been injured and look,
whatever the injury is,
you came back to the point where you could fight again.
But that feeling was always there.
Like it's always been compromised.
How many times that happened to you?
Uh,
once this whole thing,
the whole arm thing.
Both parts of your arm is this Brown said it might have been the very first kick
he through his left hamstring pop.
The extent of the injury isn't known.
It soon became clear.
It wasn't working with a stable foundation.
Yeah.
So his,
see when,
when you're in your hamstring pops like that.
The thing that I would think another issue cross would be the knee because of
your hamstring is not connected anymore.
Your knee is going to be all mushy and shit and you're probably not going to
have the ability to keep yourself from a twisting it.
You can wind up fucking your knee up.
It's at least it's possible that you could wind up fucking up.
I just think that like when he was younger,
man,
he was so mobile.
Now that's when he was training down in San Diego.
Yeah,
that's true too.
Right?
He was training with Dominick Cruz.
I wonder if maybe they decide after a while that that takes too much energy for
heavyweight.
Is that possible?
We'll put that there.
Maybe he chose to change it that way,
that when you went to Tain,
right?
Yeah.
The,
the,
the human body can only take so much,
I guess.
So don't know how much I'm supposed to talk about this,
so I probably shouldn't talk about it too much.
But I was talking to DC about cane,
you know,
about,
uh,
him,
him coming back,
you know,
and apparently he's back to a training again.
He had back surgery.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
like some,
some things,
but when you start,
I mean,
apparently the doctor said he's good to go.
He's,
he's ready to fight again and he's trained in light and getting,
getting back to the group.
But when you see a guy like that that has that kind of crazy indomitable will,
and then his body just starts to break it.
It's like just red line and everything.
Yeah.
Eh,
Bang.
Yeah.
Now when one of those things happens,
how often are you ever 100% again.
Oh,
man,
100% was a long time ago.
Right.
How do you think that's the same thing?
Just as off the record,
but for a guy like Cain,
it's not off the record.
People are listening,
what's the word?
Um,
unofficially.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
You,
you,
you never get back to 100% but you,
you know that's just right.
That's life.
Like significant injuries,
very diff.
Tito Ortiz,
pre and post,
all those spinal surgeries.
Totally different cider.
That's crazy.
Totally is having frontline worked on.
Yeah,
I dude,
several times he's got fused disks.
He's got fake discs.
He's got his neck fused.
You ever see them working on his neck?
Yo,
bad.
How about that video when they're hammering into his neck with a fucking
screwdriver or whatever the hell they're doing.
That's horrific.
And that guy went back.
Yeah,
that guy went out and fought and got guillotined after that,
you know,
I mean Chels son and almost getting them.
That's all.
After that,
his neck,
his neck is screwed together.
Yeah.
That's to suck.
It's the nuttiest sport man.
There it is right there.
That's the video of them working on Tito's neck.
He put it online.
The sick bastard.
Look at that.
They've got his neck open.
Yup.
Look at that shit,
dude.
They're just sucking things out of there.
Taking in there.
Oh fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
And look,
they have to hammer it in place.
It's so hard to watch,
Dude.
It is so fucking hard to watch.
I'm squirming.
Well,
there's no way they could have put mine on video because they went through the
front.
They had to pull out my or pull my organs to the side.
Oh Dude.
Yeah.
There,
there's a special doctor I guess.
I guess a cardiologist.
They,
that splits all the Oregons and opens everything up so the doctor can go in
there and do some screw.
And did they did the main and then look as it takes my butthole pucker up.
I don't know how many hours I forget,
but they put me out and I woke up and I was laying there and this guy's just a
wizard at it.
Apparently I got a really good doctor.
I was,
and they put a fake disc in there.
And how long has the fake disc good for?
50 years.
50 something like that.
I don't know.
What do you do?
What if you're still alive?
Um,
get your,
get your shit fixed again.
You only get a engineer 95 I don't know what I'm going to do,
man.
Disc operation at 95 might just jump off a building.
I don't know
how to fly shit.
Huh?
Sometimes I think what if one of the screws gets loose or something?
Ooh.
How about this?
By however they did it,
I'm not sure how they did it.
I'm sure there was some kind of screwing involved.
Oh yeah.
Right.
They didn't use glue.
Some kind of jailing.
Yes.
Yeah.
I've got screws in both my knees and uh,
sometimes I think about that.
They stay in you.
Your body absorbs some of them.
Like on one knee,
you can't even tell like the screw marked,
like the body absorbs whatever the screws made out of Ou Derrick Lewis coming
out swinging.
But on my other one,
it's still in there.
There's still metal.
The two big boys.
Yeah.
This is dangerous fight.
Very dangerous fight for both guys.
Anything can happen in this fight.
Ooh,
nice leg kick.
Travis Brown light on his feet on the outside.
I just still think this dude has some extreme physical gifts and his ex in,
in moments,
he's been extraordinary.
You know,
if you looked at like that superman punch to Stephan Struve,
you looked at when he knocked out Allister,
you're looking at when he knocked out Schaub he's had moments where he's
extraordinary.
Yes.
And he's not done.
Look a look at his frame of how long has it laser and he's a heavyweight.
He's not done.
He's,
he's uh,
I mean easy.
It's just gifted.
Did that frame yeah.
He's also a savage.
Yes.
It's like I just,
I just,
I still believe in Travis Brown.
I think Travis Brown just made some changes,
you know.
I know he's done a lot of training at black house for this fight and that could
be real beneficial for them.
Probably needs more big guys to work with.
But he looks good here man.
Woo.
Nice leg kick by Louis.
See Louis in my opinion,
like he improved his cardio.
Ue,
you heard him,
you heard him with that,
that kick to the body.
He's an he's hurt.
Wow.
He heard,
um,
the good at surviving.
Wow.
Very interesting boy Travis get in there and Niamh to the body.
Wow,
this is interesting.
He's going to feel terrible.
If you let them survive was any time.
Yup.
Front kick to the body and again,
he's kicking you from so far out.
He throws a good round kick to the body too.
Very interesting.
Oh,
inside leg kick.
Look how far he is.
Oh,
you heard him?
I can't hear you again.
The front kick to the body.
He heard him.
You heard them.
Oh,
Derek is firing back.
This is interesting,
man.
See,
this is way more kicks than we've seen of him in recent fights.
Look at that beautiful
leg kick slides away from any pause.
Possible counters.
He looks fucking great and I sit of that left,
left body kick or the right body kick.
He's been doing it with the right leg.
There you go.
Oh,
both
those are his babies,
but
I liked him.
That we'll kick has gotten more people in more fucking trouble.
The Chris Weidman wheel kit,
that is the wheel kick heard round the world.
Oh,
he heard them again.
He says slapping him with his toes a little bit and it's hurting him.
Oh,
beautiful leg kick.
Oh Buddy.
Went down.
Oh Shit.
Back up to his feet.
Very nice.
It's fine.
It's fun.
I guess.
That's exactly what he was hoping.
It wasn't going to.
Holy Shit.
Oh,
he threw the front kick again.
Derek Lewis with bombs.
Derrick Lewis improved his.
Oh,
beautiful.
Beautiful.
Wow.
Finish him.
Come on.
Let's go.
God Damn,
he's Tad.
Damn Derrick Lewis can take it.
Holy Shit.
Whoa.
He's tough.
That will lie time minute 40 minute,
40.
Wow.
Can you recover from those during the fight?
Yeah,
you can recover,
but it might not totally recover.
You still hurt.
You know,
and you're,
you're definitely more susceptible to body shots so bad too.
So she,
that sternum shot there?
Yeah,
man.
That uh,
solar plexus shot the way he just landed that knee.
Oof.
Oh,
and if you've ever been liver hint,
as anybody ever hit you in the liver,
in the stomach where you lose your breath,
you know when you can't breathe.
Is that the liver?
Now liver is weird dude,
because sometimes people can hit you in the same spot and nothing happens.
They get hit.
You right there,
Pam.
Nothing happens.
But other times,
just for whatever reason,
and it doesn't have to be the biggest shot either,
it's just a perfectly placed shot to the liver and your whole body just goes,
just locks up and you can kind of like,
you can kind of fake it.
You can kind of move around a little bit.
Sometimes it's hard.
It's,
it's horrible.
You know,
everyone talks about the head trauma and fighting,
but what about the body trauma,
Oregon Trauma?
Is there trauma there too?
It's a good point.
Maybe there's damage,
like permanent damage damage done there too.
Of course there is in the chest and the ribs and stomach.
Imagine Travis Browne,
Nino in the chest,
a little kick to the ribs.
How the fuck does that not permanently damage you?
Of course it does.
Does some this,
there's gotta be some bleeding in there.
Okay.
Now if there's some bleeding there,
there's some tearing.
There's tearing is some scar tissue ripping and tearing and some important
organs that are getting squashed.
The wheel kick.
Yeah,
it's your liver man.
Your liver is a big part of what gets hurt,
but you get caught with a turning sidekick to the guts.
I mean,
that's horrific for everything,
especially the way you throw him in
there.
Who could survive.
The only time guys survive it is if you catch them wrong,
you catch them with your toes and you don't catch them with the heel.
But when they get hit with a heel,
if you're extending as they get hit,
it's there so much force.
It's one of the worst things in the world.
Kevin Ross survived one in his last Bellator fight.
He got nailed like early seconds of the fight.
He got nailed with a right to the liver and he said it was one of the most
painful things he's ever experienced in his life.
You didn't see a god damn thing and his face,
he just tucked his arm down and kept moving and kept fighting and about 20
seconds later he was 100% recovered.
How do you see the evolution of the sport he's,
you've seen how much it's evolved over the last what,
20 years or whatever.
I mean it's,
it's crazy.
Maybe what does the future hold?
It should keep evolving and maybe one day instead of two or three guys in the
UFC with the,
you know,
the power of that turn inside kick in their arsenal.
Maybe it's just like everyone,
it will be standard.
I think 20 years is the front leg side kick and the turning side kick should be
standard.
Just like the front kick is.
They should be standard eventually everything.
Yeah,
year Rodrigues those will be standard.
Oh you have to do is learn how to do it.
Everybody that knows how to throw a good right hand.
Everybody knows how to throw a left hook.
Everybody then knows how to throw a leg kick.
You could learn how to throw a perfectly timed sidekick a perfectly time
spinning back kick.
Will you have any legal force?
I'm not special.
There's nothing special about me that I can do it.
I'm a 49 year old comedian.
If I can do it.
You're telling me you can't do it.
You could totally do it the way I do it.
All you'd have to do is learn from the type of instructor that I learned from
that teaches you perfect technique and they emphasize that you never fuck with
that technique.
You always do it the right way.
Anybody and these guys can learn.
10 years ago,
if some UFC fighter told,
told you that he's got it,
he signed for a fight and he's going to start training on a taekwondo school to
get ready for his fight.
You would think he was crazy using his mind right?
10 years ago,
but now,
now it's not a bad idea to go to your local taekwondo school and get your spin
on right.
Get Your Kung Fu on.
You know what I'm saying?
Them spinning kicks just to get those spinning kicks down.
Oh look it
dropping bombs.
Travis is in trouble,
but he's,
he's got a lot of heart though.
He's hanging in there,
hanging in there,
but he's got,
his legs are going.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
he's got to move.
He's trying to move.
He's hanging on there.
Holy Shit.
Standing Cocoon right there.
Here we go.
Oh,
what are you doing,
Travis?
Come on.
Oh,
Jesus.
Trapman should've kept that.
Oh Man.
He's hurt.
He's still kicking
to the body.
Beautiful Shot.
Yeah,
he's still in this.
Oh my God.
This is incredible,
dude.
Remember that Overeem fight,
man,
remember that ovary and fight?
He was down and out and he came back and knocked him out.
Travis Brown's a form.
All
big mistake.
Big Mistake.
What the fuck?
Oh,
huge mistake.
He just pulled them in at mount half.
Now he's just too tired to,
he wasn't always getting dailed.
He's in trouble,
man.
He's got to use that.
Use that under hook.
Get back up.
Don't stop.
Keep going.
Derrick Lewis.
Oh,
Derek glues takes him back down again.
Wow.
Whew.
Christ.
Holy Shit.
This is a great fight.
Okay.
Damn.
Two 30 to go.
Ooh.
Halfway point baby.
Sometimes the best time to take someone down as,
as they're getting up.
Oh Shit.
What happened?
Yeah.
Oh,
big elbows by Louis.
Damn.
Like I know anything about tank down.
This is a big fucking when if,
if Louis winds up winning here.
Holy Shit.
Woo.
Oh,
I thought I was going to go to the dark.
Yeah,
exactly.
Beautifully lit.
Back Up.
That's a professional get up.
That's a professional job as brown.
Two minutes to go with around what a fucking round.
Oh my God.
Oh Shit.
It looks like it's,
he got clipped.
That's it.
Stop it.
Oh my God.
You took too many shots.
Took too many shots.
Three too many right there.
That's a big win for Derrick Lewis though.
Holy Shit.
What a fight to survive those.
Goddamn fine.
Have we ever seen a fight like that with those body shots and the way they were
landing in and all the drama he was standing there holding his stomach.
Wow.
We've never really seen that one.
That one fight.
Fuck.
Yay.
Did what?
A fire and that fire fight and what a what a victory for him to the way he ended
it to stop them.
Knock them out cold like that.
Yeah.
It's terrible that he took those extra shots,
but I didn't know chipotle.
I for four to six weeks.
That is definitive as it gets.
Why?
Why'd you put,
I dunno.
What does that mean?
I don't understand.
Let's see that again.
Do Travis Brown tried to tried to hang in there,
man,
but look at this,
right?
Boom.
He catches him with that name.
Paulo.
There's the left.
The left really hurt him,
Joe.
He's just winging them.
Oh,
look at that right hand.
That's Oh,
beautiful.
Beautiful.
Like going around the guard.
Good placement of his punches.
Look at this.
Boom.
Right elbow.
That was an elbow right there.
Boom.
Here it is.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Like right there he could have stopped.
That fight is totally unnecessary.
The last few shots,
let's see if they even show the last few shots.
Like boom,
right there.
That fight is over.
Like doubt.
Those are two completely unnecessary
shots.
That referee should have jumped in earlier.
Yeah,
that's unnecessary.
It's unnecessary.
But Travis is known for coming back.
It's true brain,
but he wasn't,
there was no break anymore.
He was done.
He was gone.
He was unconscious when he took those last two shots.
But Fuck Derrick Lewis.
Damn,
he's good to,
who's tougher than that guy?
Man.
Fuck.
That was awesome.
Each those shots,
the body survives,
comes back and knocks him out in the next round.
Wow.
I was super impressed with him in the Roy Nelson fight because I felt like in
the Roy Nelson fight,
like Roy throws big bombs.
He's a strong guy.
I was like,
this could be an interesting fight.
He'd get tested like Derrick Lewis get tested,
but instead he just overwhelmed Roy and he was throwing nasty combinations in
his conditioning was so apparent and there was a big change in his conditioning
and he,
he even addressed it.
He was talking about it.
I just,
he realized at a certain point in time that if he wants to compete at the upper
levels,
he's got to have the gas tank.
So you see it now with him,
man.
Fuck.
That was crazy.
Perfect.
What a nutty division man.
The heavyweight division is just so different than any other division because
there are so fucking big and they hit so hard and even though they're big and
they can take more,
you just know in the heavyweight division one crazy punch and everything's all
fucked up,
you know one way or the other like that was,
that was a fight that could have gone either way.
Right.
I mean that flight was going back and forth,
body and the head crazy.
It's just
the overview.
It's,
it's interesting that the heavyweight division right now,
there's not like,
I mean there's the big fight between steeping junior dos Santos,
which is probably going to be some crazy war judge them by their first fight,
but there's not like clear fights after that.
It's not like one 85 you got Yo Romero who's waiting right behind him,
shock array waiting.
Either one of those guys could be fighting for the title right now and it would
make a good argument,
you know?
Yeah.
All of the other divisions are stacked us as hell.
The heavyweight division looks better than ever,
but it still doesn't compare it to like 55 70 and even 85.
There's so many fights,
so many awesome fights.
You know what I think though,
if there's one guy that stands out,
it's Francis and Ghana,
that guy stands out as like one of the scariest.
He's,
he seems scary to me.
Like I would,
and I would wonder if they would make this fight,
but I would love to see if Cain gets super healthy.
Uh,
if Cain is surgery successful and he feels good when he comes back,
I would love to see Cain vs in Ghana.
I want to see,
is the Brazilian in Ghana?
No.
He's African.
He was a big French guy.
Yeah.
Where is he lives in Paris.
But we said the wrong country last time.
I think we said Kim Nigeria and he's from Cameroon.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
I think so.
He's a fucking beast.
Jesus.
Ooh,
scary.
That dude's a nightmare.
Oh,
he's so big.
I wonder if they do in God.
Oh,
versus Derrick Lewis.
That could be crazy to good lord.
Yeah.
Someone's going,
someone's going to see it's going night night.
He's hurt,
man.
Okay.
He's,
he's still hurting us holding inside.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a tough dude right there.
He kinda crazy nickname to the black beast for real.
You want to go with that,
like to win.
Let,
if he wins the title.
Well,
we still have the black beast as the heavyweight champion and he comes out with
a fucking crazy outfit on like a pro wrestler.
Black beast.
What a crazy nickname you can have.
Whatever the fuck nick that he wants to know.
Don't get me wrong.
God Damn,
he's tough man.
Just Bang.
Ooh Man.
I'd like to see that in slow Mo.
It seemed like he just caught him in the solar plexus or something or caught
them like under the rib.
Really interesting man.
The division,
what'd he say?
What?
Most knockouts in UFC heavyweight history.
He's already third crazy as that loungers number nine history.
That's is crazy.
That's not,
he's only a couple away from the record.
There's a that there's a lot of fights for him,
a lot of fights for him at heavyweight now,
but I feel like I'm
in Ghana and Cain Velasquez is some shit that I'd like.
I'd like to find out what's going on and I think fighting or who was,
I think I'd heard that it was a potential fight.
Rumble Johnson has heard that online,
right?
Oh,
he could do it though.
He could do it when we're talking about it.
Well,
he fought heavyweight outside the UFC did knock 'em out.
No,
he wanted decision.
My Gpa dropped them in the first round of broke his jaw though.
So horrifically that his jaw was like literally one of these things,
whether your teeth up.
Have you ever seen it?
I remember it happening.
It was so nasty.
The pictures of it,
the fact that he,
he did it and he did in the first round and then they want fighting,
fighting the rest of the fight like that now.
Yeah.
That's crazy to get your job broken then punched again after it's broken half
like it's maybe like,
it doesn't hurt as bad,
just go numb.
You just got to split splitting up a whole,
can I hit with a bat?
It's fine.
Because people have fought like that before.
Oh,
Kim coture did that and she split her job.
Right.
Broken.
That's where it breaks on some people right in the middle.
So crazy.
She finished force that you have to have to break your jaw and people still
fight like that.
And her split to like,
he was bleeding.
Yeah.
One up.
One down.
Yeah.
It was horrific.
It that Vegas,
I think it was she.
Fuck,
that's got to hurt so bad.
That's your face.
So this is it,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yes.
This should probably be the end of this broadcast is probably one of our most
boring fight companions ever.
I don't know why we just mellow.
There was controversy.
That's right.
And very little marijuana until deep in.
Yeah.
But Derrick Lewis,
I mean,
he's gotta be like,
what do you think?
Like top three contenders now,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
you got it for doom.
Dosantos um,
who else?
Frances and gone.
It was like top 10 now,
right?
He's like six or seven or something like that.
He's got to be like number three or four.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Derrick Lewis.
It's a big wind farm man.
Just do it like that.
It's good.
What's that?
You got to go back to,
I mean,
it's amazing when early in his career he got heel kicked in the head.
Remember he got hooked kicked by Sean Doors.
Sean Jordan Hook kicked him.
It's crazy.
The way he did it to mitre owned,
starched him.
Remember I sent that,
I sent him a picture of,
you know,
remember that ad,
the hippo enhancing hippo.
Yeah.
After he hit that he'll kick.
I said in that picture that like good job did well,
he's a crazy athlete for like as big as he is.
Sean Jordan could do back flips and he's 260 pounds round.
Yeah.
He said he's a fic motherfucker,
but he uh,
he stopped Derrick Lewis with a hook kick to the face.
One of the only hook kick Kaos we didn't Koom with the hook kick,
but put him on Queer Street and then he put them away afterwards.
But that's such a weird technique for a giant dude to throw,
you know,
it was like his,
his,
his head was lower than his ass.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And he just sort of swung his leg out there,
but it landed perfect.
Was,
and then mitre owned stopped him again.
I was so bummed out about yesterday about the fate or fight not happening.
That was such a bummer man.
They pulled mitre on the day of the fight with a kidney stone.
What the day of the fight.
Yeah.
And apparently they offered it to check Congo and he said he would do it fade or
said no and they offered it to the other guy that check Congo FOBT and fit.
I was like,
Nope,
I'm going to wait for mitre own.
They just going to run it back.
Russians or civil year.
Well,
I mean,
but I got,
yeah.
Got Your money.
Do you think he gets paid?
He that was your point.
Yeah.
Like free money.
I get what you get at that trained.
Yeah.
I mean you already trained there had to be some sort of a clause.
Yeah,
totally.
Makes Sense.
Totally makes sense.
This is just a crazy fight,
man.
I mean this is as close to getting stopped as anybody has ever gotten to come
back and win by four Roche's knock out.
I mean this is right up there with check Kongo versus Pat Barry except Congo did
it with one shot.
Oh this is nuts.
Wow.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
See he just on everything.
Oh yeah.
See two completely at the very least to completely unnecessary shots.
He could have stopped it all off a lot.
Yeah,
a lot earlier than that.
But they also get to edit it out too.
And I keep showing it.
Yeah.
Well we were talking earlier about one day someone having all the techniques.
Those kids are out there right now I think.
I think if you started training MMA when you were like,
you know,
12 years old and now you're 20 you know,
guess there's that root canal.
Fucking Aaron Peko.
Oh yeah.
There's a perfect example that kids have heard.
For example,
I haven't worked with him yet cause I've been in training camp and watching him
move around.
He's fucking 20 I think.
Yeah.
Know,
he's 20 yet.
Freak wrestler.
Yeah.
Olympic level wrestler.
A fucking freak striker.
Good,
good boxing and was like,
that's the fucking few causes kicks.
I haven't seen much of it,
but you know,
he just,
I,
we just see each other going out of the gym.
Does he have submissions?
I Dunno.
I,
I've worked with him yet.
He's also one of,
um,
uh,
one of our nick curse on his disciples.
Exactly.
So He's,
he's in free.
He could shape like freaky shape.
You know,
Nick Curse on the guy who trains Dosantos.
He's got that,
um,
he's,
he's comes from the Marinovich.
Does that school have a strength and conditioning?
All ply owes explosive from the feet up,
you know,
all like jumping over hurdles and shit like that.
I don't really pay attention to like fancy strength and conditioning.
I respect the hell out of it,
but I,
I don't really,
uh,
what kind of shooting do you,
do you still lift weights,
right?
No,
I'm just doing yoga right now,
man.
Just try no weights at all.
Nothing,
man.
I love you.
I've got an I had a,
well it's only because of your back.
Yeah.
You know,
I had back surgery eight months ago and it's still tender,
you know,
it's still,
it's not healed all the way.
And I came back and I did Jujitsu.
I came back a little too early.
Uh,
went hard for like a week and then a man,
I was in the shower to go,
my back is sore is how I know what the hell am I doing.
I just had back surgery so I just how many months was that before you started
going and started rolling hard again?
Like at five months.
What did the doctor say about that?
I didn't tell him
but of course know but,
but the good news is I don't think I did any permanent damage cause I haven't,
haven't lifted weights and I haven't done,
I haven't sparked you just I do teach Jujitsu.
I can teach quite easily up 90% of the positions.
Um,
but it's the pressure.
Any time someone puts pressure on me and I got to start twisting 100% to get out
of something or if I have to to it just,
it just too soon to just,
I came back too soon.
So I decided that to,
you know,
I've been wanting to do yoga.
I know how important yoga is.
I've been for the last 20 years.
I'm like I got a deal,
I got to do yoga.
You want to be that 75 80 year old guy that could walk on his eventually I've
always known it but I just been procrastinating.
I've just been so busy.
Everyone's doing yoga,
Danny's doing yoga,
Joe's doing yoga.
Everyone's like fuck youngest,
his shit.
And they get obsessed with it.
And I know I had to do it but um,
this forced me into it finally.
So it was a blessing in disguise that I came back to where like,
cause now I'm forced into yoga and um,
I'm just going to give yoga a chance.
It's tough cause I do the hottest class and it's hard man.
I'm like a total wipe out man.
I'm just like falling apart.
And there was so hot and so it's the hardest one,
but it's that the best time I love 10 30 in the morning.
I wake up 10 15.
I just get in my car and I just jammed down the street.
I get in the right when I literally,
I get out of bed and go to yoga.
It's perfect timing.
It's perfect for my life,
but it just so happens it's the hottest one,
the hardest one.
But,
um,
and I,
and I conk out halfway through 30 minutes that I'm dead.
I'm just lying.
They're just completely drenched in sweat,
just dead.
And um,
but I've only done it for like a month.
So,
you know,
I'm proud that I could go 30 minutes,
you know what I mean?
I don't,
I'm not hard on myself.
I'm like,
shit,
it's hard to breathe in this motherfucker and to hold those poses in pictures.
Yoga looks so easy.
It's like they're doing this big deal,
but to hold your hands up like 90% of the time for an hour,
you're always holding your head,
man,
that kills your shoulders and you're like,
I can't even,
I can't even hold my hands off anymore.
It's so hard to explain.
We go with it.
Well,
there's certain poses that you do like this one,
like the beginning,
one of the beginning poses where you have your hands together like this and you
keep your palms touch.
You have to keep your palms touching it,
pressing against.
You could have facet and have your hands separate,
your elbows bent,
but when you're fully extended and you're keeping your palms touching,
it's very difficult.
It's very difficult to maintain struggle.
It's hard,
man.
That's hard.
I'm that beginner guy that's just running out of every class I have to run out
and take a break at the 30 35% they don't let you leave at my place.
She goes out and says,
does anybody need to leave a?
You have to clear that with me and please let's not walk in and out.
Just try.
Just if just lay there,
don't do nothing,
don't lead.
I don't care.
I leave.
I've only left the class because I had to throw up.
I thought it was going to throw a highly in the room.
I came in,
I was a little bit sick and,
uh,
I pushed a little too hard and then somewhere around an hour in,
I was like,
I'm gonna fucking throw up.
I,
that's me every day.
So I had to stop and lay down and I was like,
maybe I can calm myself down and get back to it.
And then when I get back up I was,
it was worse.
And I was like,
I've got to get outside.
I didn't know that was the toughest.
I thought that was a normal yoga class and I was a super was.
So I just went and it was the perfect timing.
I'm like,
dude,
this is like,
I thought it was a normal class.
They turn up the heat,
you hear about hot yoga and um,
I can,
I can't even breathe.
And when they,
when she opens up the door at the 30 minute mark to let some fresh air in,
that's like some
kind of wind of God and eternal life,
like just flushes.
You feel that when and you're like,
oh,
it's like you're drinking what?
You know you're dying of thirst in the desert and you've got a giant bottle of
cold water.
That's what it feels like that when rue,
I need that win.
And I didn't realize,
I thought that was a normal class.
And I went up to the,
to the front desk and I said,
um,
are all classes this hot?
She goes,
no,
this is the hottest one.
There's classes without any heat at all.
There's different levels and you're at the hardest one.
I'm like,
no shit,
no wonder I fall apart in that.
But the last day I went Friday,
I made it through the whole class,
but I had,
I set up my towel right by the door smart.
So when she opens it up,
I get that rush.
I don't have to leave.
David can right there.
My problem was going to the other side of the room.
I was too deep.
So the is just line up right next to that door mat right there.
Boom.
I'm there five minutes early and shit.
You know,
and when I first went,
I first went in,
I felt I didn't want to be that total wipe out.
So everyone's stretching out.
Everyone's wrong every once in like a different poems and stretching.
So all I can do is I can get into full lotus on like in Lotus.
I'm like,
yeah,
like now what?
And I'm just sitting there,
you know what I mean?
Cause I can't stretch any other way.
I have zero flexibility.
This motherfucker's or guru.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what I was thinking.
But they never got to know full load.
It's,
you never do that.
And the routines,
we were doing all this shit I can't do like when,
when we get into Lotus,
I've never done Lotus and agent.
That yoga class,
that pigeon one though.
You do a single notice.
That's basically you're getting the same stretch the toe stand when you have it
up like pigeon one yes.
Your face down.
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about that,
that one too,
that was like tree,
some tree.
I'm still confused with the terminology.
I'm like,
Damn.
I'm like one of those dudes that comes at 10th Plan.
I was like,
crack had what?
Like I've been doing it for two years and I barely pay attention to what the
names of things are.
Slowly.
Um,
uh,
you know what inspired me is Joey Diaz doing Jujitsu and he's always telling me
the stories of those first,
the first day that he w he walked away,
he showed up and then like,
I forget how the story goes exactly.
But he had a real horrible time in Jujitsu,
but he kept going.
He couldn't even shrimp across the room.
He said he couldn't even shrimp.
He would just be dead.
He couldn't breathe.
He had leave.
You had to go outside and get some oxygen.
And I thought about that.
I might,
Joey stuck it out and I have no choice.
I have no choice.
I know I cannot quit yoga.
So from this point on,
man,
I want to flake,
but I know I can't.
It's going to help you or do you just,
yeah,
for sure.
And I'm going to give it some time and we'll see how I feel in six months on my
back fields.
It's feeling pretty good now,
but it's still tender and in some places,
but I haven't done any Jiu Jitsu,
so I don't know if be doing Jujitsu right now.
Maybe it'd be sore as hell again.
So it's really hard to tell.
And um,
I don't know man.
I'm just going to give you good a sh a chance for awhile before I start rolling
again,
just to see if maybe yoga will work as therapy is therapy to fix my head.
Hip hit swept down here.
All those great stories about DDP Yoga,
you know what I mean?
He's gotten mad testimonies.
Well guys were in wheelchairs and they couldn't walk and they thought it was
Devon pages.
Yoga is very legit now and he just,
he just set us up with a whole little lifetime thing about it.
I was talking to him,
I'm really excited to try it out.
You know what?
So I'm thinking it's,
it's his style of yoga,
but it's still yoga.
It's still younger.
What he's doing,
it's his style.
Everyone's got their style.
So I'm thinking,
um,
man,
I under I,
it's just hard for me to breathe in there and eventually I'll,
I'll,
I'm going to be really into it.
You got to do before you go,
there you go.
I don't drink that.
Drink a lot of water within an hour or so before you go,
that's hard.
Cause I woke up and just go.
I understand.
But that's part of why you're having a hard time.
It's a very grueling,
rigorous physical workout.
You want to have some food in you hearing them squats,
right?
But you're not on any kind of key to genic diet or anything,
No,
no.
So that means your body is burning off blue glucose.
So you're burning off carbs.
So if that's the case,
you need eat something before you go there.
Like you're not going to have any fucking energy just like you wouldn't do
Jujitsu that way.
You shouldn't do yoga that way either.
I know you've done Jujitsu hungry before.
It's terrible.
So worst feeling in the world when you're hungry and you go to Jujitsu and you
your your fucking gassed out because you're feeling weak.
But if you didn't even have a Clif bar,
you had nothing like you've ever lift weights when you're hungry,
it's terrible,
right?
You feel so weak.
You know what,
that's,
that's my problem.
I got to eat gummy.
Oh Man,
I gotta wake up 15 minutes earlier.
No more than that.
More than that.
I wake up an hour earlier.
You want it to digest,
wake up,
eat your food.
There's some beating exercises and then go.
Yeah,
but if you were going to go running,
what kind of shit would you do before you went running?
What would you eat?
Who Runs?
If you were gonna die,
ask asking rates.
Sprints in the pool.
They'll sprints in the pool that you were doing.
If you had to do that and you knew you're going to do that,
and how long would you want to eat beforehand?
Probably like two hours,
right?
Maybe even more or something like that.
I would like maybe even three hours before I empty stomach Clif bar.
Get right to it and you're fine.
Clif bar,
it's like perfect Ms. Sugar gazing.
You don't get right into it.
We're going to have to ease into shit.
It's really light.
Just enough to get you going to power through the round before.
Before I do seminars,
that's my ritual is a Clif bar.
I don't want to go to breakfast and have French toast or some bullshit like
that.
I just want a Clif bar and let's go.
Well,
that's good.
Foreign rock star fucking love French,
so that's,
that's good.
That's a long as you have something where you need something similar to that to
a young discipline.
Maybe a little more because I think yoga is more akin to those pools.
Sprints than it is the teaching a seminar yogas.
It's fucking really
hard because everything you're doing,
you're doing 100% if you're doing it right,
you're balancing,
you're holding these positions,
you're flexing your stomach and you're tightening up your back and you're
extending your legs and you're minding your body that these are all the
movements I still need.
I still want,
cause you're not there for very long.
It's like long routines and you go throw up your some positions just once,
maybe twice you go back to it.
That's it.
There's so many other ways you can twist and bend your body.
It's basically just reminding everybody,
don't shut this down.
Don't shut that down.
Don't shut this down.
I need this working.
It just every day it's reminding of body,
don't shut this shit down because if you don't remind your body,
you will get shut down and you'll be that 75 year old guy that can barely walk
to the TV,
turn it on and go,
go to the bathroom,
take a Piss,
walked to his car to go to the market can barely move and you're 75 you're just
like ready to go.
You taught your body to be like that.
There's enough old dude's,
it looks Helio Gracie,
he was in his nineties and he was still out and about doing armbars on people.
You know what I mean?
Yoga is the best way cause it goes through everything.
It's like,
it's like all organized.
Okay.
We got,
we mapped out all the twists and the bends and all the holds and all the ways
you could use your own body wave instead of external weights.
You're using your body and all these different ways and hitting all your
muscles.
At first I thought that was no,
I thought the whole was,
that was no clinching and in Yoga,
but there is,
you clinch your legs all the Goddamn time.
There's all these positions.
We had clenching and you're squeezing too.
So really there's Yogas,
everything.
That's all you,
it seems.
DDP was always tell him he gave me a yoga lesson.
We went to 25 and finished and he showed me what his DB,
DDP Yoga was all about.
And at that point I wasn't ready to stop lifting weights.
I was like,
I just want to like if I stopped lifting weights,
you know,
I'm going to lose all my strength and I,
get,
you know,
uh,
paranoid about that shit.
But now I have no choice.
I gotta stop the wades focus on yoga and um,
you know,
once I master all the Shit and get my balance together,
I see how you can turn up the strength and really gets him,
you know,
you might be able to get all the strength you need from yoga if done properly.
I am hoping,
I'm hoping it's not going to have the same amount of ability to pull things,
but here's the thing,
you don't have to stop lifting weights.
Like there's no reason to stop just because you're doing that.
I think it might have totally different way of lifting weights now,
you know,
and the first person I had heard about this from was actually Felicia.
Oh,
you know Felicia?
Oh.
Teaches people that he'd do kettlebells.
Kettlebells.
Yeah.
She was telling me a long time ago about not going to failure a long time ago.
She was saying,
she's like always leave something in a tank and they just do it more often.
She was like,
don't do it to failure.
And I was like,
okay.
I mean that's interesting.
But I didn't look into it.
And then I heard Pavel Tatsu Alene talk about it years later.
It's good news by the way.
So what I do now is I don't weights to the point
where like I like last set,
I don't do that.
I do less sets,
I do less reps,
I just do it more often.
I'll do it like two or three times a week.
So I'm never super sore so I'll get out of it.
I'm never exhausted.
And the difference between this kind of strength work and the other kind of
strength worth cause the other strength worth,
I would do it,
I would blow my shit out and then I was done for like a day,
two days and just super sore,
couldn't do anything.
Now I'm never like that.
So the,
the idea that we always had of like,
you gotta go to fail,
you've got to break everything down to build it back up to a week.
The body part policy says bullshit.
He says,
no,
you just do it less often.
Take bigger breaks in between the sets and do it more often during the week.
That's a fantastic,
yeah,
I think these motherfuckers out there in a lazy cause it's still takes time and
you still do it with a lot of effort,
but he's like anything more than five reps is bodybuilding.
He's like,
you don't want to do more than five reps.
You want to do short,
shorter,
shorter sets.
Where'd you find this out at?
Popple Tatsu lean.
He's a,
well,
he's on everything.
It's on youtube as well,
but he's also in the library.
You'll be confused.
You want to know which way to turn as his fake news.
Real News.
Super well-respected Kettlebell guy.
He's actually is the godfather of kettlebells.
He's the guy who brought kettlebells over to America.
He's got those.
Um,
so if you had a pull up bar at your house and if you just,
did you,
when you did your Max every like once a day,
every day.
Once a day,
did he or Max,
he think he's talking about that kind of stuff.
If you had a pull up bar at your house and every day,
every day you did like a 10 in the morning and then 10 at night,
which is not to failure.
Like if you do it like say if you can do,
you know,
if you can do seven chin ups with a 50 pound kettlebell hanging from your waist
instead of doing seven,
that's too much.
One to three.
If you can do 15 chin-ups straight,
do seven just do five to seven do it often.
That's a different way of getting strong.
Exactly.
And you'll still get strong.
It actually gets stronger quicker.
My wife's strong.
Appropriate because you don't get beat up a pill up,
pull up,
pull up bars are amazing.
They're great for your shoulders,
hang from him all the time.
If you get those goddamn gravity boots,
you split those into those.
You can hang from your ankles.
You can sort of loosen your backup from there.
You can do those setups from your ankles.
Hang.
Are you doing a little l with your legs when you're hanging on my bar have to,
I have to lift my legs up and my bar.
I have to buzz that.
Okay.
I like system.
Yes,
but it doesn't give you the same benefits or your lower back cause you're
tightened up.
I like to do it in a hang.
I'm unfortunately,
my bar at home is not tall enough.
I should get one that's taller.
I like to hang where my feet aren't touching the ground so I could relax my
back.
Totally let my gyms go to gyms on the road.
A lot of gyms on the road we'll have like a,
you know a bar.
That's what,
whatever the height is that where your arms are fully extended?
Probably more for other people.
I'm like,
I'm only five,
eight but I can hold onto that bar and if my toes aren't touching the ground
then I can relax my back.
And when I'm relaxed
my back,
I could feel it like extending and just sort of loosening up.
But between that and yoga exercises,
like the one where your reach behind your calves and you grab your heel and your
stent,
that is pop in my back like crazy.
Like I feel my back.
Every time I do it,
I feel a little pup pup.
I could feel my back stretching and the amount of tension that I carry in my
back and like,
like during the day,
like being sitting in a chair,
sitting in my car,
it's almost nonexistent now.
It's just from doing yoga a lot.
I think it strengthens the whole spinal column.
That's huge for it.
I've,
I mean I've gained so much from Yoga.
I love it.
I've been doing it for probably four years now.
Wow.
Um,
not enough.
Do you feel like it helps your kicks a week?
Um,
maybe.
I mean there was times where I was doing it three days a week,
but then there were times I didn't do it for a few months,
so it's just,
just always I have a yearly subscription or a yearly pass to the place at my
house three times a week.
If I'm in town on the weekend two times a week when I go out of town,
just for right now,
I just,
I'm just trying to hang through the whole class and trying to get my belts
together.
Like all those poses,
like the standing splits and all that.
Yeah,
I've been able to do that.
Right.
There's so much shit like that.
Just the side,
Ben,
when you do the side bend and I go down right here,
this is what I do,
and then there's that back surgery.
I mean that's like where it really bends.
You're talking about the lowest link.
They're like,
there's this one lady in my class.
Yeah,
there's One lady in my class at the waist.
She can just literally take a right turn.
It's the freakiest thing ever.
Like what is going on with your rib cage is doing that.
Is it that um,
her bones are lined up in a special way or that that's a possibility?
Anybody could do that.
If they stretched properly,
anybody would be able to do that sheet.
This one day in my class,
she goes so far.
Right.
I just can't imagine that my body has ever been able to do that.
Not as much,
but is there a way to take a regular guy like me or you have no side Ben,
and it's just like tendons and muscles that have to be stretched,
right?
Yeah.
It was actually have a pretty good side,
but my side bends actually pretty good.
But what?
I'm fast can you get really good?
Can anybody get really good at that?
I think anybody think you can get real good at it,
but I'm never going to get as good as that lady.
Yeah.
Her body just goes,
oh,
this lady in my class,
her body just goes over the,
we could get good at basketball,
but doesn't mean you're going to be Michael Jackson.
What am I saying,
Jackson?
I did whatever.
I do that all the time.
Michael Jordan is the Michael Jackson of basketball.
Good point.
Except the kid fucking
back beans.
What about backbends?
How far can you go back?
Can you that that much man and is it a little bit more than it was and getting a
little bit better?
I know I'm hanging in there,
man.
I'm like,
I'm hanging in there like a trooper.
Eventually.
Eventually I'm going to,
if I stick it out,
I'm going to get good at it.
I think you know,
it's like Jujitsu.
I'm done trying to,
it would be nice to be good at it cause I,
right now it's really embarrassing.
Everyone looks over at me and they're like,
oh my God,
look at this guy.
I feel like I can definitely show you Abbott and Costello episode.
You have them doing yoga.
You know what I mean?
I'm terrible.
You'll get better,
dude.
The worst balance,
but you don't want to call moves,
right?
Just think of how I'm talking about standing,
standing matter.
Think about how good you got.
Jujitsu moves,
right?
That's you're going to be able to get that good with yoga as well.
It's just,
Oh,
you just gotta be willing to put in the time.
The way I describe it,
it's like you're building a mountain,
one layer of paint at a time and so for me it's like two years in,
I still suck.
I'm not good at it.
I'm looking forward to it.
Definitely better than I was.
Yeah,
I'm way better at Yoga than I was.
You probably can do a lot of the yoga.
Should you have a crazy balance from taekwondo?
Like Geo Martinez?
Oh,
Richie Martinez.
They could jump into yoga right now and just cruise right.
That'd be easy.
They would want to do some crazy yoga,
some power,
Yoga and shit.
We have to do those side things from there.
Like legs are extended versions.
There are options.
Like there's certain spots where you could sit in frog or you could stand frog
or you could work on your inversion right here and some people are doing crazy
handstands.
I'm in frog easily.
Boom.
Mike,
this is my,
my world frog.
Are you kidding?
That's the best one.
I got the best yoga pose I crushed with frog.
That's bone.
This is my,
I do this every day and Jujitsu.
Well most of the classes that we do the uh,
what fails me first is my feet and that's way less than it was before.
And what's interesting to me is I always thought that like from kickboxing or
you know,
just even lifting weights and my feet are probably pretty strong.
My feet are so weak.
It's kinda crazy how weak they are.
And with Yoga,
like the thing that would hurt the most is the arches of my feet.
My feet would start hurting.
That doesn't happen anymore.
And what's interesting is that was always happening.
Also what I would go skiing too,
when I'll go schemes,
terrible.
First of all,
get these fat fucking caveman feet.
They're too wide.
So they don't fit into most,
most of the shoes have to buy my own shoes because they don't fit in.
The ones that are like if I buy a size 11,
they don't fit my size.
11 I have to get like size 11 has to be wider.
It is to and my foot would always hurt.
Man.
What are you doing?
Jim went louder or something.
Something happened here.
Did it disconnect with them?
Um,
but my foot would always hurt the most when I was small.
That's what his shoulder,
it's not real.
It's not a belt.
It's not,
no,
he doesn't have a belt.
Oh,
okay.
Thanks.
That's some shit you buy at the store.
I drank.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious bitch.
Oh,
did you fuck up and drink one of those?
Yes.
Oh No.
I didn't touch my cannot getting me son of a bitch.
I said no at first.
So he convinced me.
But anyway,
from doing yoga for two years now,
my feet don't hurt anymore.
They don't hurt in yoga.
My balance fails me before my feet family or my hamstrings get sore.
Oh my caps.
Oh my God.
I have the weakest calves on the jobs.
I have no cabs,
ma'am.
That doesn't hurt me at all.
It's interesting.
My meats,
my hamstrings,
it's always my hamstrings hurting.
Like when that one,
these standing on one leg and you're pulling your foot back and extending your
lag,
it's always Mike supporting hamstrings like about enough for you.
You fuck.
And like my feet.
Dot.
It's,
I mean arches of my feet just kill me.
I'm like,
okay,
I just have to like not have to sit on my ass.
That's the one thing that doesn't happen anymore.
It's shocking.
It took literally look over a year and then after a year and my foot just from
steady,
going steady,
sucking,
my foot's eventually got strong enough where it doesn't happen at all anymore.
So now when I go skiing,
my feet don't bother me at all.
I got 30% better as a skier because of yoga hundred percent cause my big problem
was my feet.
Yeah.
Now I could ski easy.
I'm like,
it's not that I was,
I was always freaked out.
I'm like,
why do my feet hurt?
Like getting good at it.
Oh yeah.
I'm pretty good guys.
Not Good.
Like real,
just a snowboarding.
I'll switch this with the promise.
Snowboarding is fun.
I bet it's awesome.
But if you fall down,
you kind of tend to fall on your fucking head because a lot of people get Kol.
You get good at it.
I know three people that got chaos.
Kol My friend,
Amga,
Josie,
jumping,
jump.
Did you jump?
Yeah,
exactly.
Don't jump.
Just be happy for flying down the mountain.
You don't have to jump.
I don't jump.
Fuck that shit.
He never fell.
Oh Shit.
The first day you got to sacrifice the first day.
First Day.
I tell everybody,
you're just trying to,
you're trying to work today just to enjoy your second to,
so you live your first day.
You're not going to have fun.
Do you think that I would sacrifice since I've skied for a few years,
everybody starts skiing.
I started skiing and then once you switch and go,
Oh shit.
It's like going from uh,
um,
like uh,
Microsoft to apple really is that much better.
Ah,
very few people go from snowboarding to skin really snowboarding's different and
feels different skins awesome too.
You're going down a mountain.
Either way,
you look at it,
you're going down the mountain.
It's just a different angle.
And different turns.
It feels like you're surfing on the God damn mountain,
but what bothers me that is he,
you're stuck on that board.
Yes.
Like what I like about skiing is when you fall,
you kind of fall like a person.
Like you know the huskies pop off and then he can roll.
Like I never gotten hurt falling because I know how to fall.
As soon as I know I'm falling,
I just go with it and then I'm not trying to like plant my leg and stop it from
happening.
I just roll and go with it.
That's,
that's like,
it's the same thing what you're saying because I've done both.
But you're for Sarah attached.
It's like,
it's like I understand where you're coming from.
It's like a guy that's a done karate and he's feeling comfortable with it,
but he doesn't want to do Jujitsu cause it's just way more dangerous and you're
like,
I see why you think that,
but actually it's not more dangerous.
You know what I mean?
It's just like that.
So you could fall and control yourself just as you got a snowboard
boring,
you'll get hurt just as easy as you would.
Let me ask him cause the same thing.
He also does it.
What do you agree with this?
I've been snowboarding like my whole life,
but I started skiing.
Of course my parents had a scheme over here like to um,
but yeah,
you fuck yourself up to any other one.
I put myself in the hospital snowboarding.
My cousin put herself in the hospital,
ski skiing.
I just put yourself in the hospital snowboarding hitting my head.
The guys that my brother
Joe,
my cousin's shattered his,
he knows people shout at the collar bones,
they're trying to flip in the air.
Don't slip exactly the right thing to do is how do you shatter his wrist,
shatter his heels.
Nobody gets hurt.
Just snowboarding.
Skiing is jumping a,
I'm like a road gap and a road gap or yeah,
some sort of gap that's a road.
But then you can jump over it,
you know.
Oh he's trying to jump things.
Yes.
I'm not dying on the mountain.
Oh Shit.
If you already like and scam barely after all this time.
Nice key.
Don't get hurt.
Didn't get hurt.
Don't get hurt dog there.
All right,
I'm done.
I ski for like a couple of hours and I'm good.
I just go,
Jesus Christ.
This isn't that fun.
Snowboarding.
That's all you got to snowboard,
man.
Maybe I'm just,
you got family loves to hurt themselves trying to kill nobody.
That's not a people man.
Animals have feelings.
I don't know if they do cause you eat 'em all the time.
I'd never heard it didn't.
I thought it was just about that and I was raised eating in the car.
When when you pull that Burger King,
did you care about
that's not real meat.
Yeah.
If he didn't eat all day,
someone's going to die.
Look at the race.
Say Sas food.
Meat isn't real meat judging.
I'm just asking.
I'm just trying to,
they're very concerned about cruelty to animals.
That's why they make those burgers that aren't really meet.
They're not real.
Would you guys say that they
figured out how to make test tube meat now get it down to $11 a burger.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like they,
it was like $300,000 a few years ago and they got it down to 11 one,
two kind of cancer that's going to cause all kinds,
everything.
Everything
comes near the first going to test it on inmates.
They're going to get inmates fake me.
So we're going to turn fucking,
they going to see what's up.
That's going to be the beginning of the nightmare of the living dead.
Exactly.
Come on me.
He's going to turn people into fucking Zombie movie about fake meat.
It just seems like there is movies called fake meat and it's,
I don't know.
Well,
here's what's crazy.
And Bang brothers,
there's a recent study they did with,
uh,
with rats,
I believe it was where they fed them meat from older animals and meat from
younger animals.
And it turns out that when they fed them meat from older animals,
it's sped up their aging process and compared to the animals that were fed meat
from younger animals.
That's why the politicians want to eat babies.
That's like with the whole blood thing,
right?
They change out your blood for that.
That's a new thing that they think possibly while they're doing it,
they don't know if there's,
there's no real proof that it works on people,
but they have shown that it works on rats and mice and they think it might be
more of a function of there's things in the new blood that aren't in the old
blood anymore that you need and as soon as you get them,
you,
you just be behave like a younger person versus the,
it makes you younger.
They think that it's just your body at a certain age just lacks the essential
properties of the blood that it has when it's young.
So when they've shown it and in rats and in blue it was actually mice.
When they showed how they put young blood in them,
they started behaving like young mice and also when they put old blood in the
young mice,
they started behaving like old mice.
Man,
that sound,
that's,
that's why they're into babies.
Baby blood.
You know what?
I wonder if they could pull the blood out and that actually kill him.
Just like have them around just for the baby blood,
didn't they do then blade,
you know what I mean?
They just have a bunch of babies.
Which body goes hanging there?
Cruelty,
free baby blood lipid.
Let the babies play in the nurseries and baby fine.
Well,
they can make this meet and they can make this fake meat if they can make a fake
meat.
What if,
what if they made like fake babies that were headless that just gave you blood?
Then you're going to fucking find some reports on these fake news sites that the
dying,
when the blood is dying,
when the body is dying,
it's,
it needs to be that in the process of dying
the blood,
something happens to the blood.
That's where the gold is slow.
It seems to me that there's a bunch of people that are looking at the human body
like it's a math problem or they're just trying to,
okay,
let's try that.
Nope,
that's not doing it.
Okay,
let's try the,
what's the password?
Is it that and then one day they're going to find it and then got a bank.
Okay,
we got it.
You're going to live to a thousand we win.
This is probably a kid today that is going to live to a thousand and it might be
completely dependent upon when they catch you.
Yeah.
Like maybe they catch you,
you know,
and they give you the immortal,
immortal gene they injected in you before you quite hit puberty.
Like right.
They figure like you gotta make a decision when you're like 11 or 12 do you want
to live forever?
Do you want to die like everybody else?
I don't know,
dad,
what do you think?
Well saw and I'm going to die and I won't be here for you.
You got to figure out whether or not you take it and if you got to give it to
your kids and then one day you know you're going to be 70 kids still going to be
20 he's going to still be 2080 he's still 2090 you're still,
he's still 20 you're dying.
You're,
everything's falling apart and shaking.
The kids out there playing tag football didn't give a fuck.
Surfing slinging dick all over the place.
He's still 27 years old.
He's 20 you're like,
what in the fuck?
What did I do?
Like I made an immortal,
you can still get hit by a car though.
Damn.
So you can still dial yourself or you'd have to die and people would probably
engage in much more risky activity.
They would heal like little kids.
It'd be,
I mean that's,
that's going to happen.
They're gonna figure.
They've already figured out some incredible stuff with stem cells.
They had a guy who was paralyzed and now he's able to exercise with his upper
body.
He's able to move his upper body.
Like this is a a first with stem cell therapy.
We're just finding this out.
The library and Youtube.
I found out,
I knew answer library and Youtube.
I looked at all sources,
bro.
All Bro.
Sources.
We mean we're living in weird times too because I think we're just one
generation or two away from people being able to completely change what they
look like,
like at a genetic level.
Like if you seen what like,
like some kids are doing today,
like young kids,
like young reality star kids like the Kim Kardashians getting extensive plastic
surgery at 20 just ridiculous report.
Did they really get but jobs?
Oh yeah,
100% a hundred percent a hundred percent yeah.
Did you didn't even need it.
Yeah,
but you want to keep that business going.
You got to take it to the next level.
How the job is that like knowing the fact,
oh well I'm not a doctor,
nor am I a detective.
But I'll say yes
it or not.
I am sure.
I don't know if she did admit it.
There's a before and after photos.
She's got a fucking ass.
Pretty sure it's,
if she wanted a big ass,
she fucking got it.
She got,
she got her ass one.
That's the biggest,
most gigantic ass based on her.
Her proportions like,
yeah,
like all of this.
She looks like a normal thing in the hips up.
She just looks like a little frequency at the globe.
Freaking Ooh,
holy shit dog.
And in a giant,
large like Derriere to tremendous,
if you know what I mean.
I mean,
let's stop and think about that because that didn't exist 20 years ago.
It doesn't,
it didn't exist in both ways.
Natural and unnatural.
It didn't exist,
exist natural because there weren't girls were doing squats like you didn't get
those crazy like crossfit acids and some of these girls have now when they look
like they're a thoroughbred,
they can leap over a building.
Some of those crossfit girls that are developing these muscular acids that
didn't exist 20 years ago.
He never saw that you and you see him like all the time now.
I don't know if it was the time I grew up in,
but I've accepted I'm totally cool.
Um,
fake titties,
real titties,
fake titties.
I don't really care.
You know,
I'll take either,
but ass is,
you can't have a fake ass little where you cannot have a fake bravos throwing it
down.
Like,
I don't know.
I can't accept it except I can't.
Okay.
Personally,
do you think maybe in the future if they came out with a legit fake Dick,
like legit,
would that look back go through or not?
And I'm not talking about like early prototypes that don't give a shit.
The problem with the problem with fake Dick's,
it'd be like the same problem with fake boobs.
If you go back to fake boobs from the eighties bold,
now they feel like basketball.
So things are hard as a rock and disgusting and they feel weird.
They don't feel like a fake boob,
but a fake boob circa 2017 they figured out how to,
a way to make it soft and mushy.
It Phil's Phil's outstanding,
right?
Agreed.
It's got a but a fake Dick.
I don't think that women would have the same appreciation for a fake Dick that a
man has for fake tits.
I don't think women are buying it.
No,
I don't know.
I think you're right.
No,
I think it's the same thing.
The hair extensions in two what's going on?
He can wear your hair extensions ladies.
Doesn't it seem like a hair transplants?
We've found out now it's been 20 years or whatever,
do or don't work.
They can work.
The problem is the rest of your hair keeps falling out.
It's like that bit that I used to do about it,
that they take hair from a,
uh,
it's like taking people from a neighborhood where everyone's really healthy and
move him to an area where everyone's dying.
It's like they stay,
but the other stuff goes away.
So like for me,
my problem was I had hair transplants and the hair that's duck was like all the
hair I had left and they didn't like it filled it in at first.
Then the other stuff started falling out too,
and it got to this untenable position where there was just,
is not enough hair up there.
It's a solver.
It's time to just scorch and burn you.
I should have shaved my head from the jump.
I just wish I did.
I wish I had shaved it.
Who's that?
What do you show him here?
People.
Hair transplants.
There's,
that's the dude from the Brady bunch.
Yeah.
I mean you can definitely get your hair thicker,
but my hair was destined to fall out.
It depends on like how much your here is destined to fall out.
My hair had no chance.
If you had to like a little bit of a chance,
like maybe if you're only thinning and then it brought it back on,
but my hair was going son,
it was on its way out.
Your hair has to stop dying.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And the only way it does is if you take Propecia,
which has massive problems of its own and just really bad for you and causes
depression and just,
it's just unhealthy for you.
You know,
I told you about one of my singers and I was a drummer and the speed metal bed,
what am I senders ended up getting a extensions.
Yeah,
like a whole bunch of extensions.
There was like a wig.
It was basically a unit.
Will you support him?
Because he had long hair from the age of nine but he was one of those guys,
all his brothers,
they all lose their at 18 so he was the dude with the longest hair in high
school,
but as soon as high school ended,
he lost all his hair.
So they decided to,
he decided to not wear a regular wig because his older brother.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
We just literally saw,
I'm sorry.
We just literally saw in the highlights,
the version of the Gary Good rail.
Yeah,
but with a hammer fist.
It was crazy,
Eddie,
that you brought that up because that is exactly what she just did.
Jamie,
run that back a little bit.
We want o hear hand that shit to me.
Where would we point
it?
That TV
wash this Jay,
Eddie's so funny that this happened because this is exactly what you were
talking about.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
She got into that position.
It's literally the same position.
This is crazy.
Look at this watch.
She gets her down,
she traps it,
but instead of elbow on,
she's Hammerfest sinner.
I mean that's the fucking Gary Goodrich,
right?
They're crazy.
It's crazy.
That is nuts.
I haven't seen that since that fight and it to see it right there that I had no
idea man.
Cause that was,
I think this fight was in the prelims or whatever.
I missed it.
I had no idea.
I missed it to Carla Esparza and random Marco's.
Yeah,
I had no idea.
Zero idea.
What is this Jamie?
What does that toggle Santos knocks out Jack Marshman.
Oh,
we'll kicked him.
Bam,
Bam.
Wow.
Thiago Santos is bad ass.
Look at that blank.
Oh Jesus.
How did such a horrible kick to get hit with your fucking heel with that,
you like that?
How bizarre is it still to this day that you know you,
you can kick someone full blast with all your bones,
but your hands have to be covered by a leather pad.
Like how crazy is that?
You can clang your heel off of someone's eyeball and no problem.
The hardest part of your body,
your,
he'll literally can stop on the ground.
It's not another part of your body where you can walk up to the ground and smash
up.
I could stomp on the ground.
Barefoot is no,
I can't punch anything.
Pair handed like I can't punch a tree.
I stomped trees all time.
I'll walk up to a tree.
Doesn't even hurt me at all.
Right?
Your heals crazy,
your heels,
it crazy bone and the fact that you could bounce that off someone's head when
you're spinning around like a Ballerina full blast and whip your leg into their
head swollen like a bat,
but you can't,
you can't have bare knuckles.
It's so bizarre.
Rogan fighting championships right there.
If I turn the skull,
if I changed him and that's why I would want a hundred percent change.
Bare knuckled,
I don't care what anybody says.
And when you say,
well you break your hands that way,
well you then you shouldn't be doing that.
Then we should figure out what actually no wraps,
sir.
No wraps.
This is what I think.
I think what,
what,
what actually works.
If you don't have anything tightened up unnaturally with wraps and tape and
gauze and t,
you've essentially got like a soft cast that keeps your wrist in place,
that allows you to just throw bombs with impunity.
I don't think that makes any sense because that's not a real skill in the real,
I mean,
you can still punch people,
but it's not a realistic application of luck.
What could happen with two people just using their bodies.
You've added in this extra element of rap.
Okay.
That's the same way I feel about the cage.
I feel like the cage allows people to get taken down and stand back up where
they might not be able,
it's ads in
this artificial thing that you're handling.
You have to deal with no raps,
no cage basketball court.
We already got that.
An Ebi.
Yeah.
That's basically bi.
W s very similar except with Ebi.
You're not throwing,
throwing kicks and punches,
combat Jiu Jitsu are that starts,
but you're not kicking head kick,
you know?
Nope.
Or palm strikes now,
but on the ground,
but only on the ground.
Not standing up,
wrestling,
standing up.
Only on the ground palm strikes.
It's designed not to add knockouts are Tkos to the show,
but to open submissions up.
No,
there will be an a TKL every now and then,
but I don't think there's going to be that many with just your homes.
Do you ask no elbows?
No nothing.
Oh,
but some guys can hit so hard with their palms.
Remember boss smashing guys with his palms rushing him.
Well he figured out a way to pull his hands with my hand.
Doesn't even go that far back.
Like my hand stops.
He was right there.
That's as far as my hand goes back.
But boss gets his fucking hand back like an extra 10 15 degrees.
I don't know if he stretched it or it's natural.
So he was just throwing punches.
He was throwing palm strike punches and just smashing guys.
Well here,
if you a accidentally throw an elbow or a closed fist strike,
stop the time that guy gets to be on your back.
Just like Ebi overtime.
And then we start in regulations.
Still start with the guy on your back with the leg hooks because you can't take
a point away when there's no points.
There's no points.
So what do you do?
You have right there,
Bam.
Any,
any clear elbow striker closed fist strike.
I stopped the time you start on the back,
you know that'll just ensure the no one's tries to take you know that that
warning shot.
Oh,
that was just a warning.
No warning.
It's clear shot.
That's automatic penalty if they Kayo and with that punch or an elbow because
the problem with that is if somebody,
that's a promise sacrifice that that might be want to sacrifice that.
If they want to catch somebody on the jaw,
they get,
it's a DQ.
Have to be a deal.
If the guy gets knocked out DQ.
What if the guy gets really hurt too?
We give them five.
I give them five minutes to recover and then he's going to be on Dude's back
from that point on.
What if he says after the five minutes he can't come back?
What if he says he got too fucked up?
Like what if somebody drops a bomb on him and he stays conscious,
but he's like,
dude,
I'm out of it.
My feet aren't working.
I can't do this.
I can't go.
I can't get hit again to Dq Dq,
so that'll live the opening for guys to to fake it.
That's a double.
That's a double DQ.
No,
the guy that threw it,
it's going to be dqued for sure.
Right?
For sure.
Guided through it,
but it also leaves room for someone to fake it that,
but it wasn't that hard both out and the other guy wins because we're only doing
four man combat Jujitsu.
Turn it.
Okay.
It's a four man thing.
We're still doing the regular Ebi rule.
16 land welterweight tournament Sunday,
March 5th on UFC fight pass,
but in between the rounds of the regular Ebi 16 Man Tournament,
there's going to be a four man combat Jiu Jitsu tournament.
Wow.
Yeah.
We got some animals doing it,
dude.
Fucking beast,
man.
It's going to be
interesting how it turns out.
Imagine Ebi,
but you can palm strike as hard as you can on the floor.
Combat Sambo combat.
Sambo is one of the best martial arts for people enter into MMA.
Even number Grumet off.
You see with or and combat sambo.
You fight with a judogi on with stripe on the lake shore.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Sure,
sure,
sure it is.
It is.
It always short and it gets a little short.
It's not full length.
He had been there.
That goes back here.
It's like the,
it's enough that you could get a good grip on each other.
They're cut off sleeves,
man.
I think they're like karate kid.
Like Kilkee Shin a thing.
I think so.
I think it's like the thing,
it's like,
it's almost like it is,
I think a little sleeve fate combat sambo.
I think it's more long than you think it is.
I think I know what you're thinking of variations there will be different,
but I believe probably that should be a Jujitsu.
He's got a full sleeves fedoras fighting in combat against the guy from the
university that,
and we know what they do have though.
The,
Oh damn.
Fado was a beast in this shit.
See this is not in a cage and they're fighting.
They also have shoes on,
but they're doing ground impound.
Look at this with headgear on has got to stop.
The world is not as is missing something here and look what they've been doing.
They've been doing this for a long time.
The world,
the world really needs to zero in on what,
what they're doing in Russia with the combat sambo
now.
But let me ask you this,
why is that better with Judogi on instead of just doing combat sambo,
like MMA amateur style.
Cause that's really what it is.
It's just there's more grappling because they're allowed to grab ahold of the
Geek.
Yeah.
It's very strange because in a lot of ways you could get more vulnerable.
You're putting yourself into positions that you might not be in.
So they're doing,
they're doing a version of MMA,
but you can grab each other better because you have all the g like this kind of
shit.
And you also,
there's no cage.
The basic idea they're doing,
it's the size of vote,
like an Olympic wrestling match.
Yep.
Right.
That's all you need.
You don't need,
you don't need a cage.
It's better off without a cage.
Honestly,
it's way better off without a cage and when people stand up,
they actually have to stand up.
You can't push up against the end,
better seating for everybody.
You could see better.
That's the most important thing right there.
The most important thing is you can see way better as a spectator,
but it's new IFCs most of the time,
most of the guys are looking at the big screens.
It's hard to see through the cage.
It's hard to see through the fence.
It's that easy to see through the house as you keep psychos from different
rushing onto the mat and you know working people in the head,
no you don't want to,
you're not going to do that.
I NMA event.
Those guys or those guys would never have the balls to do that.
Dude.
You imagine if Anderson Silva like lost by some funky way and people were
betting and there's a bunch of Brazilians in the crowd and they stormed the
American stormed cause say 1990 setting show.
It can happen.
Look,
dude,
people get in fights all the time inside the ring.
I like the no cage at all.
What do you think about the GE?
I think that's okay.
He's taking a totally different approach.
I don't see a problem with that.
It's different.
You know what I mean?
At least there's punches and strikes.
Oh yeah man.
I know what I mean.
So the Gig,
there's nothing wrong with the gay,
you know right here.
It's amazing.
Okay.
You might not want to grab the sleeves as much if someone can punch you,
you know,
I think maybe you don't grab the sleeves as much,
you know?
I don't know.
I haven't really even looked at this.
This is going to start paying attention to this
crazy way to fight,
man.
Cause he can hold you in this position.
That shit.
Anyway,
he's pounding on you with a Gian in a lot of ways.
It's more dangerous and a lot of ways,
this is your argument,
Eddie,
for MMA.
Like there's no grease involved here.
No grease.
Zero Greece.
Yeah,
and they're wearing jackets.
I'm saying make them wear Reebok rash guards.
It'd be so goddamn cool
or let them continue to,
oh,
he just ripped.
That guy showed the shore.
I mean maybe let them wear the judo pants too.
It how much,
how about let them wear whatever they want.
If they want to wear a rash guard,
they can.
If they don't,
they don't have to,
but here's a,
here's a whatever they want.
Here's a point to think about the way he is right here with the shorts on.
It's not as big of a factor because we're where he's going to most of the time
be in contact with is covered with cloth,
right?
Yeah,
because his legs are going to be wrapped around the other guys.
Upper Body.
It's going to be a wrapped around his arms.
All that stuff's covered in cost,
so he doesn't even need pants.
Yeah,
so it's just a different approach.
Instead of using a rash guard like you came up with,
it's just using MMA.
Maybe combat sambos the fucking way to go.
Maybe that's a geek for real.
Maybe when you really stop and think about it,
man,
that's a,
that's a really,
because they're already doing it.
They got it down.
They shut out of there.
You should have a variation for an Ebi.
Well,
you know what,
with combat Jujitsu,
we're going to see how that goes first.
It could be a disaster.
Yes,
it could be a total disaster or it could be a total success.
It's going to be,
you know,
I think Jiu Jitsu with some palm strikes,
I don't know how that can be bad.
I don't know how that can fail.
It's an,
it's a little closer to MMA.
It's not an a,
it's not even close,
but it's a little closer than your regular submission.
Only Jiu Jitsu match.
So to this
fade or when he was at king,
he'll get here fade.
Oregon's semi shell look at this shit man.
Holy Shit.
He was so dominant dude.
And you know the one thing,
oh Jesus.
And one thing you got to read really be impressed with when it comes to faith
oars victories is that he fought that crazy shit.
When you can stomp and soccer kick like go get that.
I mean that is just a wild way of fighting during the pride days when he was the
king,
when he was the best fucking heavyweight in the world,
they have the craziest rule system in all of MMA.
Stomps,
soccer kicks.
You could basically do anything that you needed to hit on the ground.
Yes.
Ooh,
yeah man.
Dude,
he was a monster.
Big Daddy.
There's
big daddy.
Big Daddy comes up.
Yep.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Come on man.
I have pictures of me.
And when Daddy got Amsterdam Training Jiu Jitsu from 2001 well this one Kevin
random and slammed him and as he's going down,
he's holding on looking at him.
He's literally landing on his head trying to hold onto a Komora.
I mean who survives like that and then the escapes and taps him right here.
Yeah,
he got him in a Kamora.
Yeah.
Fader was something special,
man.
He was really something.
He just got up reversed.
Just rolled them over.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Loosen them up with these punches.
Trap the arm and Bingo.
Got It.
Yup.
It's going right to that.
He's not messing around.
It's like it's hard to knock someone out.
Look at that.
As soon as you wrap that up tab to get outta here.
He was also knock dudes out from that position.
He,
the other thing that you gotta give him credit for,
you've got to get fade or credit for the ability to tap guys out and knocked him
out.
Cause he was a guy that was always threatening with submissions,
catching people with a armbars,
catching people Kimora is everything.
Yeah,
he could do everything.
He could rear naked,
choke you everything and he would explode and take everything that was
available.
Would you allow and Rogan finding championships in basketball arenas with rash
guards.
Would you allow a stomps to the head?
Yes.
What about a kicks?
And he said everything hundred percent Dan.
Hundred percent we need a backer.
No,
no gloves.
Knees to the head.
Soccer kicks to the head,
but really good referees.
Crazy.
Some crazy millionaire.
I wanted to finance it.
I'd say good luck,
dude.
You could use my name.
Oh really?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Rogan.
Funny Championships.
Oh Shit.
Let's do,
I think it's got to be,
so if you do really well,
eventually I'm gonna see you.
But uh,
not a sewer.
They,
it's not a good name for it anyway.
It should be something like unlimited fighting or so broken.
Now I,
you shouldn't have my name in it.
It should be something like,
um,
they should,
you should come up with some name that like,
that shows how it has the most,
the most limited
restrictions player of the year.
It can get the HR,
no gloves,
no gloves on the Indian reservation,
right
or wrong.
Gore,
Mexico,
Bubba casino.
That might be Mexico's when he was doing a basketball arena,
hologram basketball and an on an Indian reservation.
You need,
he would need really good security though,
especially on amateur fights,
on Indian reservations and things like that because people will rush that
fucking Matt,
you're not going to stop people from Russia in the map.
That's the one thing that saves people in the cage.
It's like when they rushed the cage,
it's a whole event.
It's hard to get to,
everyone's got to sit in the bleachers,
you know.
No one's allowed to sit on the floor.
Everyone sits on the bleachers.
Yeah.
That's your shit.
There should be,
it should be difficult to get to the case or get to the bat area and there
should be a lot of security.
Yeah.
You're going to have to have people standing by and all these areas also to
block people to block fighters.
Keep them from going into the crowd is going to have to be someone that makes
like almost like a physical wall that stops them.
If someone's bum rushing.
Yeah,
but there's got to be like a warning tracked and you gotta like not,
you got to respect that warning track has got to be a big ass area as you get
into the outside ring.
Yeah.
You gotta break Selfie shot.
I going to want to go once you know there's no where to go,
you're not going to go that way.
When there's a fence,
you'd lean on it,
your pressure him,
he's leaning on the fence.
But if it's not there,
it's not going to do you any good.
Like if,
if they,
if you've got pressed against the fence and they break it immediately after a
while,
people would be like,
what's the point of pushing him against the fence?
And they're going to break it up in one second.
You know?
So then there's not going to be strategies that involve the fence,
so it will be no fence.
No,
exactly.
But you could do accomplish the same thing in a,
in a ring.
There's no reason to go on the outside.
You're going to start looking around.
It's just like a wrestling match.
It's like combat sambo.
They're not trying to get to the outside.
Yeah.
You know what you could do,
you actually could do some sort of offense,
but you're not allowed to go anywhere near it.
What's going to happen if you touched it?
You can't do it,
but you didn't want the fence because it's all about the visual.
It's all,
it's all about the visuals.
You'll be fine.
Maybe electric,
basketball,
maybe like one of them things or a dog collar.
You don't want to do you step out of bounds.
I think I get to a free shot.
You ever seen an electric fences?
The dogs have where they get to a certain part that gets zapped.
You set up the stakes in the ground.
It's like a radio frequency and when it gets to a certain point and the dog
passes that line,
you know it's about if you take someone and you push someone out of bounds,
your opponent,
they stop it and that guy gets on your back blooming.
It started from there.
Could you imagine if you were front row and you saw Travis Brown and Derrick
Lewis dog and your way trust someone to try to defend a take down the other ones
trying to get it and they're coming straight towards you and you realize,
oh my God,
that guy was blocking is not going to get two on top.
I'm going to get crushed.
And you get crushed by Derrick Lewis and Travis Brown on top of you.
You're stupid front row seats now bitch.
Right?
Like you ever see that happen in a basketball game?
We're dudes falls on Jesus different.
That's not going to happen in fighting.
It could easily happen.
And finally you would have to have a good amount of space,
a good amount of space,
and I wouldn't take the front row for a fucking bet.
No,
I would do.
Yeah,
he made it like to the,
that guy leaped into the audience and he made,
the guys will have a little pads like you know pads.
Oh my God.
Nobody's going to be doing that is so exciting for to save balls from going.
He's just crowd a bounce.
That's all.
But I did fly into those people and someone could have died.
He's 400 pounds.
He's so big.
If he landed on your hand and talk there,
no guitar player invest in Atlanta.
He just smashes all your fingers like crack,
crack,
crack and you're like,
eh.
You ever get those?
You know those disposable chopsticks,
they give you some Sushi places and you fucking break.
I'm wrong.
Oh God.
Then he's tried to get clean to the top and it's dead.
You got one and three quarters chopsticks and then one quarter chopstick.
He just so depressed,
but just shitty chopsticks trying to eat you spicy tuna roll.
What is this guy doing?
Was another guy flying into the crowd.
Same with shack with the whole team gets out of the way here.
Oh No,
that's Alaris boy,
those are athletes.
Heel Quik.
They moved.
When you see Shaq barrel and down your way,
I think the front row should be all security with kicking shields.
That's not a bad hold the fuck up.
Your vision you,
Oh you have him down your chest.
Some guys who the person is not going to get to see.
Exactly.
So like those,
those referees and you can get in those towns.
I solved it.
You just have security on the front row and you want to look bad.
It might work.
I think this is probably a way to do it.
You know,
had a real good way.
Honestly.
Frank Shamrock,
he had a a recessed arena.
He had a,
I remember that he had it set up a little thing where there was like,
it was a flat area and towards the end it kind of went up a little bit like a
pole.
Looks like an actual frank,
frank shamrock fighting arena.
What did he call it?
He had a name for it.
Shoot the shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Maybe that's what it was.
Maybe we would just shoot bucks maybe and then member the Yama Yama.
That's what it was.
But no,
that was afterwards.
Frank shamrock did it first.
The Yama thing came afterwards.
Let me see.
Frank Shepherd Yama thing was the guy from the UFC the early days.
He's river that no,
no,
no.
Why can I not?
It's not art Davies.
The fuck is wrong with my memory lately.
Campbell Mclaren.
No,
the other Guy Art Davey.
the other guy got the cash.
Put it all together.
How can I not remember his name?
He's a great guy.
God my brain shit is this frank shamrock spot on.
There we go.
This show,
he's got like a little bit of a raised edge.
This may be the length Swick he may have figured it out long ago.
Well,
you definitely had a good idea.
He was right at the fights look like and that no holds barred movie though too.
Which one?
No holds barred.
This is awesome.
This is exactly what we're talking about.
Bob Myerwitz,
Jesus Christ.
Mary,
what's,
there we go.
This is it.
Yeah.
I mean essentially it's basically what we're talking about.
Look,
because when you get to the edge,
it goes up,
it goes up and you know what's going on.
Everybody knows what's going on.
I think he could give it a little bit more and get a little bit more distance.
I think the center area could be a little larger,
but I think essentially nailed it.
Oh,
Jesus,
this is great.
Oh fuck.
Yeah,
it is.
Hey Dude,
that's a great,
you know what?
He was ahead of his term,
frank shamrock.
Shamrock ahead of his time.
Actually,
that's the way to do it,
right?
Someone's right to invest in that.
That looks pretty damn cool.
I think it's going to have the best vas.
They're all immediately,
because what are the best seats at UFC is the risers on the floor,
the risers.
Everybody gets a riser.
Yeah,
and we see it as a riser.
Yeah.
I mean this is,
this is exactly what you were looking.
Oh Man.
Frank,
Jesus Christ.
Frank nailed it.
He nailed it.
Mike Swick with the beautiful knock out there.
Shit.
Let's see another one.
Look at this frank.
Frank would have viewed idea how many views is it happened and what was it
called?
Was it called?
Chicago has 9,000 views.
Oh my God.
It's called shoot box shoe box number one.
And it says Mike Swick versus who's the gentleman he fought.
What does it say?
Which Bacon?
My fucking name dude.
Amazing.
You should invest in frank shamrock.
Is that the only video of shoe box in testing and bacon and shit.
I'm here to give out advice for people for free run with it that I'm not,
I don't want any money.
Just take my,
well I think the basketball court idea is perfect but that's it.
That's the way to implement it to the basketball court or if that seems like a
highschool jammer,
mass Halco cause that's risers immediately.
It's the way to implement it.
Maybe a little larger move and it has a metal fence.
Do you see the metal fence?
I don't know about that and I don't like the metal fence.
Maybe you have like every 10 yards.
You have a dude with a kicking shield,
you know what I mean?
Huddled down in the frogs.
The frogs dance.
We need a man to state a frog stands for seven bouts.
Can you do it soldier?
I'm all about the frog stance,
bro.
I to back squats against the wall.
I'm all about the Lotus position and I double up with the horse dance.
I have the kicking shield.
I think it's definitely better than a cage.
I think the cage also gives,
it gives it a weird douchey connotation.
Right?
Cage fighting.
Yes.
You know it always had that weird sort of pit bull on a fucking chain with
spikes coming out of a snack feel to it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It seems like to look at it for what it would,
it really is like martial arts in its purest application.
You would want no cage.
Yes,
I agree.
Frank shamrock nailed it.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Damn.
All he needs is rash guards and no gloves,
no gloves,
rash guards.
So the rock fought with no gloves.
He fought,
he did everything.
He did all the styles.
He did Pancrase back when they had slaps.
Yeah,
he fought MMA when you didn't have to wear gloves,
like when he beat,
when he became the UFC champion,
did they have to wear gloves back then?
Yeah,
sure.
For sure.
Definitely for sure.
I think 100% when he was fighting,
he wore gloves
when he fought Kevin Jackson arm barred them.
I don't know about in Japan.
Didn't know about that.
I think by them they were wearing gloves,
which everyone does have a Jackson,
frank shamrock.
You have see Japan,
they were wearing gloves.
Here's what I definitely know that in my tenure with the UFC,
when I started in 1997 you did not have to wear gloves.
You could wear shoes and they let like way smaller people fight way bigger
piece,
but when you could still grab cups,
you can still grab someone's crotch.
I remember volleyed g the lead Ishmael fought some Japanese character and has
got Japanese dude gave him a Wedgie from hell,
you will.
You were allowed to grab shorts and his shorts were just digging into his ass
and balls.
It was horrific.
It was totally legal back then when he fought frank shamrock when he fought Dan
Henderson and I think it was battle Kade,
I think,
or one of those weird one off shoots.
It was frank shamrock toehold,
Dan Henderson,
and I don't think they'd be wearing gloves then.
No,
but that was,
that was a different thing.
That was an all grappling thing.
That was all grappling.
Oh,
was that was uh,
Matt Hume
against an Olympic wrestler all grappling there were,
no,
that one was all grappling.
Yeah,
that was all grappling.
The one you're thinking of with Dan Harrison versus frank shamrock was all
grappling and I don't remember,
it was a pro grappling thing.
Matthew,
they were trying to find the best grappler and then they were trying to find the
best striker and Dan Gable did commentary along with,
I think it was John Perretti,
I think it was John Perretti and Dan Gable.
I might be wrong about Peretti.
I think it was John Peretti's event.
In fact,
think about what happens in battle Cade.
No,
no.
He did that as well.
But I think he had already left that by the time I think it was called the
contenders.
I think it was a submission grappling event only that was called the contender.
See if I made all that shit up.
I don't think
I'm 100% positive number.
It was at the same show where Eric Paulson had long hair and he was getting his
hair pulled.
Don't think that's the same show.
And the guy in mezcal was pulling his hair.
Yes.
That was a different thing.
Oh No.
Oh Eric Paulson against um,
a black kickboxer Chi or the are black box.
And I remember that.
Which show was that?
Boy,
I don't know.
That was like,
we're bart veil fought.
Didn't Bart veil fight on that card?
Member Barn Vale.
But we fought.
The dude was on a model Hawaiian bone breaking style.
That was his style.
Remember that dude's it have like crazy style,
serious history and then may history so many non UFC shows that went on that
just disappeared.
They just couldn't.
So docs then boy and frank shamrock beat Tito Ortiz.
Holy Shit.
That was a crazy fight.
Yep.
He's,
Tito was a gorilla and frank shamrock has outpaced them.
Just kept him going and kept him going.
Warm out,
kept him going.
The adventure you just hand was hammer fist.
At the end of the fight.
Tito was just done.
Me and frank shamrock played Mexican prison guards in a movie with Mickey
Rourke.
We're both Mexican prison.
Amazing.
And in in wardrobes that were like really trying to dirty up our uniform and
really try to make it all messed up and dirty.
That was pretty racist.
What year was this?
This was a long eight,
maybe seven before make Rourke had that comeback.
This was before the wrestler?
This is after the wrestler,
was it?
Yeah.
He made the comeback already.
This is a movie that if 50 cent was in it,
it's called 13 the wrestlers way before 2008 right.
What was the wrestler?
I didn't realize how many movies are made by big name actors that you never know
about that just they just consider them failures is letting go that you know,
there's so many movies that you never see.
They decided to pull the plug midway through production or something.
They just released it on DVD all quietly.
They didn't tell anybody about it.
That was,
I didn't know.
I thought for sure.
Uh,
Mickey Rourke's in it and at 50 cents in an adjacent stayed them is in it.
It's called 13.
I thought it was going to be big.
Nobody watched it.
It's submission.
They buried it.
Yeah.
Um,
so the contenders submission,
grappling,
go to all,
don't look for the intenders.
That's right.
I'm pretty sure that was the name of it.
Yeah.
What year was that?
1990 what?
90 97 Yup.
That's it.
It was all grappling.
All grappling.
Yup.
Frank shamrock versus Dan Henderson.
That's right.
Kenny Monday versus Matt Hume.
Another Olympic wrestler and Matt Hume submitted him.
Wow.
That's right.
Frank shamrock.
Dan Henderson.
Can we see that?
Oh yeah,
that's online.
He got them in a toehold.
They got him in until it,
but I could've swore,
I dunno.
I could have swore I was a regular.
No,
no,
definitely it wasn't.
I remember it super specific.
Here we go.
Full screen.
Look at this.
Holy Shit.
27 years old at the time of Shams,
Dan Henderson,
27 Frank Shamrock,
25.
Holy Fuck.
You know,
it's really crazy.
By this time,
frank shamrock can only been trained in like seven years.
Right?
Seven years.
That's a long time.
He started when he was like 18 years old,
didn't he?
Didn't he start don't have gloves.
Yeah.
No,
this is not a fight,
dude.
This is a grappling match.
100% cause look,
Dan Henderson weren't shoes.
Yeah,
1997 but 1997 again,
she could wear shoes in the UFC and you have to work ups.
Trade tellig men fought Vitor Belfort in vittores debut and Trey Talbmen did not
have gloves on.
I'm almost positive.
Look at this.
And Scott for Rosa,
he was another guy in the tournament.
He had gloves on.
I totally forgot all about it being a grappling match.
Yeah,
well it's a long time ago man.
And um,
Dan Gable did commentary and let me hear the,
of the volume on the commentary so we could figure out who look at that.
Bam.
He jumped.
He jumped back for that leg lock.
That's Peretti of course he's got,
yeah,
it's John Perretti.
John Perretti,
one of the most underappreciated commentators of all time.
Look at it.
And he's got some seriously,
look at that bad and he's gone
and look with the heel.
What's that?
What's the issue is where it hits a toehold right here.
Yeah,
man.
Especially with that shoe.
Or it could be a heel hook.
Whereas yeah,
that's a heel hook kilo.
It was a heel hook.
Damn.
That was nasty.
Yeah.
That looks like high level leg lock you in for them.
It did do French homework was a beast.
He was a beast.
You went after that lag.
Wow.
That's a gem right there that just got resurrected that,
I mean,
he follows his leg up.
He fucked his leg up.
Let's see what happens when he stands up.
Oh yeah,
man.
His leg is fucked up.
And especially with those heels,
with the,
uh,
the shoes on heel hooks with wrestling shoes on.
He was like a talk.
That thing in there,
it's not going nowhere.
Frank shamrock versus Allen goes crazy.
Pancrase those crazy rules that if you,
if your cotton and anything on the ground,
you're in trouble.
You could grab the rope and you have to restart grabbing.
The girls get to restarts.
That's the dumbest shit ever.
This is beautiful.
Who?
Who's this?
A frank shamrock again.
Yeah.
This is high level stuff right here.
Go to Matt Hume versus Kenny Monday.
See if you could find that Matt Hume versus Kenny Monday was,
isn't it amazing?
What's online?
Seriously.
So much cool.
Shit's crazy.
You never called caution records.
It's a strange time for being able to view things,
but it does happen.
Look at that.
Bam.
Go full scale.
Boom.
Ba Ba boom.
He's the fucking ring announcer.
This is insane,
dude.
Come on.
Wow.
Again,
people forget how fucking good Matt Hume was.
People Forget.
There's a reason why Dimitris mighty mouse Johnson is the pound for pound best
fighter in the world.
A big part of it is this guy's fucking brain.
Fuck yeah.
This guy knows a whole lot about fighting.
He's so high level in so many different things.
Sure.
James available digitally.
Well does Kenny Monday was a serious wrestler too.
He just didn't know what to do with Matt human.
Matt Hume I think gets him in a toe hold.
I think that's where I got confused.
What's the format here?
How do you,
what's a good question?
What if there's no submission?
That's a good question.
I don't remember what the rule set was.
Okay.
I do not remember how they set it up.
It's a circular cage though.
Yeah.
See Kenny Mondays on top.
Oh look it
up.
It fucked up cause he had absolutely no idea.
He went for it and he gave it up and he's got the toe down.
And what is he going to do here?
Cold.
Yup.
Right there.
Oh,
he got him.
Yup.
So that's where I,
I confused it.
Ooh Man.
Think about that in that show.
That was 1997 you know,
we got this big,
you know,
leg lock revolution going on right now.
Yeah.
But that was basically the first metamorris
star style Ebi style,
all grappling shells.
I can't believe I forgot about that.
John Perretti.
Wow.
John.
And you know what?
We had two high level leg locks displayed in 1997.
Incredible.
Right.
It's like opening up an old,
it's like opening up an old judo book from the 1920s and seen it all blocked
off.
You're like,
what?
I thought the Brazilians made up an Omoplata and you're like those old Japanese
judo books,
you realize that it's all been done before.
Yeah.
Well it is kind of incredible.
It is kind of incredible when you go back and get to watch that.
We've seen some nutty shit man.
We really have.
We've seen martial arts just evolved.
What about Hickson's grappling show?
Remember that?
And I think this was 2007,
what was it called?
It was called Bushido.
Oh,
that's right.
Yep.
And you were a gay if you want it to.
He had some,
I think there were some Gnocchi matches too.
I think Shinya Yogi thought on that.
Marcello Garcia found on that one show bricks and he could've kept that going.
And then there was um,
a Rico chip rally had a show and it was called the professional submission
league.
I think it was PSL.
No,
it was a dam professionals submission,
I think.
And that's when Jack Ray fought Randy coture.
Yeah.
That was a good one.
Marcella Garcia fought Jake shields and Cameron Earl on that one girl.
That's right.
Remember that Cameron are off on the Hixson one two didn't eat.
Jeff Glover fought Hobson Maura and that,
uh,
answers to be weighing five crone.
Gracie.
You know,
there was a lot of all grappling folks shows wow.
For this era,
you know,
and you know what,
you know what they all have in common,
all of them failed.
You know what I mean?
We're not,
that's why I'm not like,
you know,
people say,
dude,
he'd be guys doing so well my listen,
there's no,
it's not like there's a pile of money than anybody's making.
We're going to show to show trying to survive know,
fight pass.
That's giant.
Yeah.
So can you tell us?
Yeah,
no,
you had a meeting.
Yeah.
That's UFC fight pass.
Like what?
He tells us
a ubi 10 Ebi 10 was in December.
And that show was when GL Martinez beat Eddie Cummings.
And that was so huge on a few different levels.
I mean the Danaher death squad has been dominating and they've been dominating
us.
They've been beat tapping us out in Ebi over and over and the fact that Glb
Eddie Cummings,
Eddie Collins is the best leg locker that's ever lived ever.
Nobody's as good as that.
He coming with a leg lock,
there's nobody out there.
He's the best.
And for Geo to serve vive in all his leg locks for like seven minutes,
six minutes,
something like that.
Eddie Cummins was all over his legs deep,
deep as deep as he wanted.
Geo was stuck.
Cause like if I tried to get out of it,
most people are trying to get out when Eddie Cummings bites deep and you know if
you can nip it in the bud,
yeah,
you want your attractions,
you want to get it out,
you want to nip that shit in the bud.
But if they get in deep and you try to get out right,
right then and there,
sometimes it's good but sometimes it's not the best idea.
Sometimes like if you're caught in the arm bar or like the arm bar position and
you're defending your arm right now,
might not be the best time.
Let's be patient.
Let's get a little position.
Let's set this up.
Let's wait for the right timing.
You have to have patience and timing.
And you know,
geo survived.
And then,
uh,
Eddie Cummins jumped on his back and he survived that and they went into
overtime and Geo bidding beat them in overtime and,
and because of their dominance and B,
because how vicious Eddie Cummins is with those leg locks.
It was a ginormous win for 10 planner for Geo.
And for me it was,
it was,
uh,
the most epic match in Tennessee.
Plan of history.
No doubt.
That one right there.
Just tell everybody.
There's another one.
It's going to be March 4th,
March 5th,
after Tony to the March 4th UFC
every night.
Tony Ferguson Against Khabib Woodley,
uh,
Thompson.
And then the next day,
boom,
the bi,
the Walton white UFC fight pass.
If you have a apple TV,
you can get UFC fight pass on apple TV.
That's how I watch it.
It's dope.
Watch it on a big screen TV.
It's awesome.
There's plus UFC fight pass.
Just tell everybody has fucking every fight like every,
if you're a fight fan,
it's the greatest resource ever.
Everything's in HD.
Everything's there like pretty much every fight from pride.
Every fight from the UFC thing.
If it's not every fight,
it's pretty much shit.
Most of them,
which ones are not fighter.
He's just to research opponents passed on the TV network.
I love,
I love being on fight pass.
That's awesome.
Now man,
it's awesome now.
I mean five passes,
they've got millions of subscribers now and it's just blowing up for the UFC.
It was a risky endeavor like to start
flex.
Look,
that's the future and to,
so your question,
Ebi 10 was such a hit with the reviews and the numbers fight.
The guys from fight pass contacted me and I went out and had a meeting and they
told me they were really impressed with the numbers and they want to get behind
Ebi even more so we've been going back and forth.
I have another meeting with them.
We want to do something really big,
but we just got to work things out.
We want to go just fucking destroy with like a just a big giant show.
But yeah,
talk about it.
Well you don't have to talk about it,
but I just tell everybody has never seen it.
You figured it out.
Fast rule sets.
It's so exciting to watch.
It makes grappling,
especially submission grappling.
And you give it a a finish in a lot of fights and you put people in bad
situations and it's just awesome.
And you're seeing like the level of grappling is coming out of there.
It's so exciting.
It's incredible.
It's so fun to watch.
It's so good for not just Jujitsu,
it's,
I think it's the best thing to ever happen for competitive Jujitsu.
I think your rule,
your rule systems,
the best thing that happened and the fact that it's blowing up on fight pass.
But I also think anytime we're seeing any of these,
all of these different organizations,
like even the one with the geese were,
you know,
Gary Thompson tone and fought a j for all those things.
And Chael Sonnen thing sug good for everybody.
Yeah.
Everybody including MMA giant Polaris.
Just like glory.
I think it's good for MMS.
Hopefully.
Good for MMA or kickboxing.
Yeah.
Good for him.
And may even in Beltour for the UFC.
Yeah.
All of it.
Good for everything,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Positive.
Dammit,
mother fuckers.
All right.
That's it.
Let's wrap this bitch up and did like four hours and by and change,
right.
Thanks.
That four hours I'm going to be,
I'm going to be a 10th planet,
a Seminar Planet J J.
Dot Com.
Yes.
Uh,
and creepy and two American American animals.
See Ya.
Bye everybody.
See you soon.